thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello everyone and welcome this is the
plans for the aim chess rapid the fourth
stop off the Champions chess style it's
going to be a fantastic day a big fight
I'm International Master Tanya Dev and
alongside me there can be no chess
without Hess Robert it's been a while
how you doing
hey Tanya I am so glad to be here
covering this event with you the
Champions chess tour is always full of
excitement the chest world has been
buzzing with Norway chess and many other
great events like the Karen's cup shout
out to Anna zatonski for winning that uh
she's an amazing human being got a GM
Norm proud of her but today we focus on
the aim just rapid
so much action the Chess World has been
buzzing and as you mentioned we're still
getting over all the
and uh for a certain Magnus Carlsen it
was on his last event in July we know
the news chat you know the news he will
be back to re on his spot in the
Champions Chester by playing the planes
tonight Robert it's going to be fun
yeah you know he's hungry he wants to
make his way back to division one in the
next event he's already won a leg of the
Champions chess tour but he wants more
he wants more but it's not going to be
easy Robert I've got to ask you we know
that Magnus is in are you also expecting
Hikaru to show up today
it's a big question after winning Norway
chess he may be traveling he may be too
busy but he has won the chessful Masters
and of course no dearbeck Abdus atarov
you can't say enough about the Wonder
kid from Uzbekistan he won the chess kid
cup so Tanya we're into event four
already
uh this is the road map after 2023
Champion Chester Robert we are about to
kick off the fourth one the aim chess
rapid we're down with three Magnus
Carlsen taking the first one Hikaru
Nakamura with a win in the chessable
Masters and nodded back winning the
chess gate Cup in a grand style and
today we kick off the fight for that
fourth spot it's all about making to the
Champions chess store playoffs eight
players will qualify into that the
winner of one of the six major events as
well as the top players to finish in the
tour standings everything to fight for
tonight
oh yes indeed the aim chest rapid
promises to be a great one just by the
list of players The Who's Who taking
part in today's event but we'll get
there Tanya I just you know I'm getting
ahead of myself but it's just been
already a great season and we're only
halfway through the sixth events that
will determine who makes the playoffs
come December
store standings as well critical to make
it to the finals in December let's take
a look at where we are with the
Champions Chester with the players stun
things let's bring up our tour standings
to three of the six events uh before we
kick off the fight for the aim chess
rapid and we see Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru
has been on fire in the Chess World he
is world number two right now Robert
he's back to being world number two and
he's had phenomenal back-to-back
performances
OTB as well as online we saw him at
Norwich s that was fantastic as well as
protest League he was amazing in the
chessable Masters in behind him in
second place currently is Fabiano
caruana who hasn't yet booked a spot in
the season final so it's going to be a
fun to see him back in the mix and
Robert we see the tour standings it's a
big mix of established Elite with the
big names the big talents and the
youngsters of the Chess World
and all the players you see on this list
who have not already won an event
they're either rooting for themselves or
a repeat winner because if players keep
winning that opens up more places from
the tour standings to qualify for
December's playoffs so some great names
on that list Jordan front Forest
Vladimir fedosev who won division two of
the chess kid cup I mean they are
looking to stake a claim to the playoffs
in December where there's a lot of prize
money up for grabs
yeah six hundred thousand dollars at
stake on the line in that playoff and
the season a final it's a fun ride to
get there and for that fourth spot the
action starts today and we do know that
there will be big names playing let's
take a look Robert let's talk about the
format that's coming up because it's
absolutely brutal uh there will be two a
different
formats that we will be seeing in the
playing stage today we stopped with the
Swiss before we move on to the match
play and this and for those of you who
are new to the Chess World a Swiss event
in a Swiss event a player plays a
different opponent in each of the rounds
they're paired against each other based
on their scores and at the end of nine
rounds the rankings are based on the
final result of the players and in this
one it's all about finishing in the top
72 of the Swiss stage the players will
have 10 minutes on the clock with a two
second increment and then rub it the top
72 move on to the match play and that's
just half the job done
yeah because in the Swiss stage you can
Coast at the end if you get off to a hot
start make a few draws but when we get
to match play it's just 1v1 and only two
game matches uh you can't just try to
Coast there there's no sailing through
so I like that they first have to get to
the slug Fest of the Swiss and then they
have they choose their opponent and
that's the cool part of uh this format
is you could choose your opponent but
then you have to prove it one versus one
I love it I love all of it even the
Swiss stage we see all these big names
but alongside them the lesson known
Grand Masters but they're super
dangerous as well and Robert we've got
some names that are coming in who will
be fighting in the plane chat we know
Magnus did reveal that he will be
playing but take a look at that that is
just some of the big names who are
signing up for this one and Robert I am
loving this already we've got Magnus
Wesley so yeah the world championship
Challenger he will be back here and of
course we've also got the 14th World
Champion Vladimir kramnik and alongside
Ali Raza this is gonna be a fun night
Robert give me one name you're excited
to see out of that list well I'll give
you a name you weren't expecting if I
were Danny wrench I would say holy Jesus
snaps oh my goodness but when I look at
this list of names it's kind of like the
who's who of Chess we have superstars no
matter where you look at the initial
player rankings I'm super excited to see
Vladimir crumnick take part again Magnus
Carlson in his first play-in that's
really exciting for us as commentators
for the fans but maybe not for the other
competitors
it's gonna be a night of entertaining
Jazz action Cutthroat competition we
start with the Swiss stage of the planes
let's just talk regulations and format
get everyone up to speed with the action
that they will be seeing now the Swiss
stage is open to a grand Masters and
just the mix that we see of players
makes it so not just entertaining but so
unpredictable as well now it's not just
Grand Masters we will also have other
title players international Masters who
have qualified by finishing in the top
three from the Monday qualifiers again
throughout the day we will see the time
format of 10 minutes with a 2 second
increment and a standard chess scoring
system a player wins the game scores one
point a draw means half a point for both
players and if you lose that's zero
point and Robert this format and scoring
system usually means that even if a
player has a slow start he's got the
time to recover and come back yeah you
certainly do losing the first game even
losing the first two games does not mean
you're completely out of it your tie
breaks will suffer and that becomes
important when you look if you're tied
with a bunch of other people but you can
afford a couple losses here or there but
you really don't want that of course not
at this stage and you say standard
scoring format Tanya I'm thinking wait
didn't we just see Norway chess where
it's three points for a win and then
Armageddon if you win that one and a
half points to one for the loser room
again things are getting crazy in the
Chess World and they're only going to
get crazier in just about two minutes
I'm all up for crazy I love it the
action is about to kick off and Robin
we've been talking about the big names
we were fighting it out and I've got a
question for you and for chat as well
what do you think is Magnus here he he's
here to prove a point after what we saw
at the Norway chess it was a tournament
a dismal performance by him then when a
single classical game has he got a point
to prove tonight
well the point that he needs to prove is
about a statement he made where he said
he cheated on the Champions chess store
with the grand chess tour and now he has
to work his way back through so I think
he was only interested in proving things
to himself I don't think that he cares
what the public is saying oh this is not
the same Magnus of a few years ago when
he was 28 80. Magnus is the beast when
he's playing he's always the favorite in
the tournament so I think he just wants
to outlast this very stiff competition
and it is a long day ahead for him with
chess and all the action and the
different formats and we are about to
lift off and of course we saw the big
names who will be fighting alongside
Magnus in this one and Robin you've been
calling the action in this planes and we
often see names that we that are not
household names also qualify into the
match play and these opponents are so
dangerous because the top guys don't
have that much experience playing
against them you just don't know what to
expect
yeah no this is an event where you don't
look just at the rating because if you
don't see a 2-7 to start a player's
number you're like they're not 2700
they're not a super Grand Master no
problem yeah guess again Alexi serrana
for example one of the many worthy
competitors in this play and uh he can
take down anybody right that's happened
before he's been in division one uh
Ralph mymedov and many others have made
their way to the top division Jordan
Forest he doesn't have to plan this
playing because he did so well in the
chess kid cup beating hit card Nakamura
in a match so I I think you can't count
anybody out in this field any
Grandmaster can take down even the best
players like Magnus Carlson
and that's exactly what makes this
season of the championship Stars so
exciting because that's what we've been
seeing the big upsets the big comebacks
and uh Robert do we have action I
believe we do have liftoff already for
round one
we do indeed so let's get right into the
chest and the first name that I clicked
on happened to be Wesley so another
player who has not automatically
qualified for the top division and he's
gonna have his work cut out from this is
just game one Tanya but Wesley in this
field as well
yes wow Wesley so also out of Norwich
has decided to play in the plane to run
his spot in the Champions Chester and
Robert it is already quite an
interesting opening we see uh there is a
battle in the center uh Bishop has been
developed by black hair is Wesley
thinking about maybe striking
immediately and he does it yeah no this
Pawn on D4 here he's just trying to gain
control of the center and what's so
interesting about these positions is
this bishop on G2 this is not a Catalan
but it has a similar feel to it right
Tanya with a bishop on G2 is way
stronger than counterpart excuse me on
C8
yes wow and we see development
continuing and again coming back to the
point of fighting for the center that's
exactly what we're saying that's an
interesting choice by Wesley because
this means that black has the option to
actually double up white spawn on the
c-line yeah those are those pawns um you
know they are getting doubled on uh C3
and that would mean that the diagonal
clears up so if this Knight captures on
C3 the bishop on G2 is a happy piece so
I think at this stage we know what we're
looking at I like White's position Tony
I don't know about you but I think that
Wesley he's gotten what he wants
yes and we see that is being played out
that Bishop on G2 you just got to
compare the pieces often in these
positions it is going to be a struggle
for black to develop that Bishop on C8
with the g2 Bishop just blowing fire
down the board on that long diagonal so
looks like things have gotten on to a
good start for Wesley Robert what do you
say do we have a look around should we
jump to some of the other exciting
opening action that we're seeing let's
do it I mean I see so many great names
and each Geary is playing in this
competition so why not go to his game he
might tweet about this decision later
but that's okay at the moment Tanya we
uh can try to pull up his game and
um see yeah we don't have the game up
just yet but we will in a second
um but yeah Anish is playing against
Clementi Sita
wow all right we will get that game
started in just a few moments from now
but right now what we have ahead of us
is a Wesley sauce position with the
white pieces and it looks like he's got
the dream position out of the opening we
will pull up anisha's board shortly uh
Robert so many great names fighting it
out I'll tell you what the one player
I've been wanting to see in division one
is Vladimir kramnik he's come so close
in these planes but either yet to see
him in division one tonight might be the
night
yeah tonight may be the night and I
think a lot of players hope that it's
their time to shine so uh we will have
many people trying to get there
um first attempt at division one that's
what everyone is playing for and uh well
I I just so many great names I'm looking
levana Ronin is playing I'm just gonna
keep listing off names I see that
abhimanyu Mishra is in that's the
youngest Grandmaster of all time uh we
have alireza farouza he was on the
notable players list but they're just
Sam Sevin you Yang Yi we could go on
forever
he's just
fret event of the Asian Championship
where he tied for second so he's
definitely informed one of the Indian
youngsters to watch out for and as you
mentioned we've got big names we got
left playing a niche Magnus Jana
publishing Wesley Soul alongside so many
Grand Masters who were not household
names once again but also players who
are so dangerous and hungry for those
points and the games are on and Robin
what catches your attention
yeah we are gonna get some games on
screen for you all we're just working
through a few issues just to be
transparent with everybody uh but so
many superstars I'm still looking at the
list of players you know I'm seeing some
of the names on my screen I mean just it
goes on Dimitri kolars who played in
division one at the chess kid cup that
was not a fluke that was not a mistake
he would like to return to the top
division so uh yeah too many names are
catching my eye Vladimir krumnik I think
everybody wants to see him play as well
so many names out of caught our
attention
very soon we're just we're just seeing
some technical issues we will go into a
break and be back with all the chess
action
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
oh my goodness Knight d8 whoa Bishop G5
was made way fantastic
You're Gonna Leave the chance Rook F7 oh
no
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
apologies for that a technical delay but
everything's been fixed and we're ready
to jump into the chess action a lot has
happened Robert from where we started in
the opening phase we do have some
results coming in as well round one
almost done
round one is almost done and well this
game is still in action here it's
between alireza farrugia against Aiden
suleimanley and Tanya it's not King of
the Hill there's a king on E5 but it
looks like black has the upper hand but
not much time remaining
oh yeah and the clock is definitely a
piece in this position Black's got 12
seconds Bishop C4 already walking into a
move that has been given a question mark
a bad decision here but he remains in
exchange up and a very difficult
position for white to defend but the way
to defend is to go on the offense The
Rook King and Bishop for white have to
start putting threats against the black
king and even in some positions
threatening a Checkmate get in with that
King to E6
oh my gosh King E6 Bishop G5 Rook d8
would be a Checkmate so black does need
to be careful and only 4.4 seconds
that's the nature of Rapid chest you
start with 10. suddenly you only have
less than 10 seconds
are being picked up but Robert I do feel
that white has to find a way to start
threatening Checkmate down the board
materially black has a clear advantage
in the position should be winning but
look at why he's just gobbling up all
the pawns yeah and you can get this Pawn
going that would help his Checkmate in
one you have to stop that and he barely
gets his move off in time with King d8
that way his King can run to C7 but
after B6 the king may have to continue
running away
the bishop for white with the B Pawn
that becomes a big soldier in the
position gives a check King C7 you've
got to check on F4 but the blacking
attacks the white Rook this is crazy
stuff going on and black white wins the
rook and now is white winning the
position after picking up the Rook on H2
it looks like it should be winning but
perhaps Black's Pawn is fast enough to
distract White's pieces if this bee Pawn
is lost then suddenly we have a
theoretical draw rook and Bishop versus
Rook that is a theoretical draw if
there's no checkmating net so perhaps
white will have to bring this Rook here
take this pawn and black gets the B5 on
batana come on there's six seconds on
your clock you're gonna hold this
position
good luck doing that and especially
against the player like Ali Reza playing
the white pieces he goes for the E2 Pawn
while white black gives a check white
doesn't have time to put that rook in
the middle to trade it off now this is a
rook Bishop versus rook and Robert these
are still tricky to defend I'm expecting
alireza to play this forever yeah but
yeah I think we will see some good
differences to among the increment
really helps you get two seconds bonus
per move and this Rook you typically
want to stay near the black king he goes
away for now that way he can check in
the right time and as long as this King
can't help out then black will be within
that drawing range
wow it sounds great theoretically Robert
but practically never easy with just
eight seconds on the clock I would
probably end up losing this position
nine out of ten times and against alirez
are probably 10 out of 10 times chat be
honest this cannot be easy to defend but
right now the white black is still
holding his own and it's all about white
trying to set up a mating net against
that black king here
doing an amazing job by the way he's
pinning the bishop taking a long range
stance and he needs to run away with his
King so if this Rook goes in the second
rank the king can keep running but what
white is about to do is run this King up
to the D3 square and try to make this
King so you can move step by step with
the King and Bishop
all right now if you move to King up
there was a check so white doesn't have
the time to do that and Solomon blocking
that sixth rank with the Rook the idea
for white is to put that Bishop on the
D6 on the E3 square and bring in the
king to D3 but we see Solomon stops that
once again not letting the white king
get over to that D3 Square
and look at this the king can't get in
it can go to D4 but that doesn't get you
anywhere and this King it goes to see
what into discover check but it's
because the king and the Rook remain
close that's so important in this end
game
attacking the rook and now there is a
decision he decides to offer a trade and
of course always are going for the win
and I think it's going to come down to
that 50 move rule alireza will play
until that point but if he's not able to
make progress which basically means get
a Checkmate in the clocks the game will
be stopped after 50 moves and there was
a check made in one threads of The Rook
is stationed passively on the first rank
but the white kings in the wrong spot
that king would prefer to be over on D3
and as soon as you get there The Rook
gives a check so all he really is trying
his best here
he is and now you will get to the D3
Square no check but just having those
two squares for that black Rook on A1
and B1 is enough it is barely enough but
just about cuts it for defending this
position alireza tried to make progress
that's a big threat Rook H1 winning The
Rook oh it's over it's over yeah as soon
as you oh what as if the King was coming
yeah his King could have left forward
into the position I think he'll get
another chance time just because black
has no time but that was a missed
opportunity
while the players playing on second
three seconds for Solomon he goes
without Rook to C3 One Missed
opportunity will alireza get a second
chance before hitting the 50 move Mark
if he's getting it yeah I knew his game
once his King gets to the third rank
successfully this Rook gives a check the
bishop blocks the King goes here you
check right here the king is forced back
otherwise it would have been discovered
check and now it's about technique and
if this Rook leaves there's Bishop check
here Rook to D1 mate this is great
technique right now Rooks and Rook C8
coming in with Rook C1 a big threat on
the board how do you find it it's on the
board but it's a bad move Robert yeah
The Rook goes to D5 and blocks it these
Rook uh rook and Bishop versus Rook end
games are very tricky maybe afterwards
if we get a second we can show what the
winning technique was but unfortunately
the most natural response allows black
to set up defense and it is a draw so
let's go right back because
changed here
wow and it does look like the 50 move
Mark was hit two big missed
opportunities thereby Ali Raza the game
finally played in seconds Solomon does
manage to hold and with that this ends
in a draw Robert you were telling us the
right technique show it to us how it's
done
uh I'll show it in a second hopefully
um sorry about that everybody I misled
you there but we will get the
opportunity to show you how to win this
end game in a second but what's the
results what are the standings it looks
like some of the regulars at the top
over there
we do see the standings and wow the one
regular who's not at the top is Magnus
Carlsen going into round two which means
that he did not manage to win his game
that or did he win his game Robin I
think it was heading towards a draw but
Robert Magnus eventually managed to
score a full point there yeah no Magnus
winning is no surprise for anybody but
let's dive in right now if we have a
second here that in this position where
white went Rook to C8 going for
checkmate the direct path uh here I
believe the quickest path is actually
throwing in this check because once the
king slides over to D1 then The Rook
comes to C8 and you have the connection
of this bishop and The Rook coming down
to C1 and unfortunately for black
there's no way to block it on the first
rank so this check is very important
because after the check on Y8 if the
King goes to uh F1 then this king is an
amazing net no matter which way you turn
and you can bring your Rook somewhere on
the eighth Rank and try to go for
checkmates on the board
wow
definitely a rook Bishop was this Rook
it's not only easy the fan it's also
very tricky to actually find
pattern and in seconds we see the
world's best players not being able to
do this and with that this game ends in
a draw Robert let's get an update on the
results as round two is about to kick
off we actually do have liftoff and
we're going to start with Magnus Carlson
playing with the white pieces and this
looks alike it started with an Italian
and wow Laura frassene he's going for it
with F5 opening up the f file eyeing
that F2 Pawn frosting a player who might
be a bit familiar with Magnus Carlson's
chest not just because he's a top
Grandmaster himself but has he been part
of the team right fresenay has been a
part of Team Magnus and these lines are
very interesting Tanya wear black side
steps the pin on the diagonal plus the
king in the corner and that way you can
strike with F5 so Magnus he can take
this Knight on H6 that forces the
doubled isolated pawns for black but
that also opens the G file for some
pressure against the white king
hmm
wow and Robert we are jumping into round
two but I'm just gonna quickly update
some of the big results that happen in
round one and Vladimir kramnik also
scored a big round one Victory Magnus
Carlsen winning his game Peter swindler
winning his game so some of the big
hitters scoring that first Victory and I
have to say I know as commentators we
are not we are supposed to be biased and
not have favorites but I'm really hoping
to see a big finish by big vladio it's
gonna be fun to see him in division one
and this one is going to be a big game
we can already see fire on the board
well you say fire the board I'm looking
for shirov and you already mentioned
chromic that was a whole controversial
time in the Chess World where Vladimir
kronik was able to take the throne from
Gary Kasparov but should he have been
there in the first place that's a
question that won't be answered because
there's I don't even want to say split
opinions I just think that Alexi's
opinion and Vladimir's opinion maybe
they didn't have the same one let's put
it that way
well that's a a chat for another day
Robert but I can tell you that this
position as well Magnus and Laura's
Center are not having the same opinion
as well they are having a Face-Off
currently lots of Pawns being liquidated
we see a trade on that E4 pinning that
Queen on E8 there is a lot of pressure
on laurent's Center with this Rook on e4
and the E5 Pawn pin is it a bit of
trouble for black because I would be
worried with the black pieces here yeah
what you need is to connect down to the
F2 square but with this Pawn on D4 not
going anywhere anytime soon the bishop
it's just staring into the center rather
than inflicting serious damage and while
this works on e4 pinning the E5 pawn it
could also swing it's a kind of Rook
lift that Rook can go to H4 at some
moment and start targeting the weakened
black king side so Tanya I would be
worried if I'm fascinated it looks like
that move was a mistake and it's because
the bishop doesn't have the diagonal if
this Pawn were ever to move then Queen
takes G3 is a thing but for now the
Knight successfully goes to G3 protects
the Rook on e4 this looks great for
white
yeah but he's so tricky Laura fresna the
Frenchman he is setting up his own ideas
eyeing that g file some potential
sacrifices on H3 Magnus still has to be
careful and let's not forget in this
time format anything can happen it is a
fiery position Knight G3 what I love is
how White's Knights are keeping
everything together that Knight on G3
stopping any activity on the G file
making sure that the G2 Pawn isn't pin
but still a lot to play for black can't
continue with developing that light
squared bishop and he does it Bishop D7
connecting the Rooks Robert as white I
would be worried about potential
sacrifices on the F3 Square as well as
the H3 Square once the Rooks are
connected and things can't get out of
hand do you think this is the moment
that we leave Magnus to it and get some
updates on the other game I really like
what you were just saying I think Magnus
agreed that looks scary so he brings his
Bishop to C2 I see the question mark so
objectively
practical perspective it's a very good
move because it keeps all your pieces
well defended and it allows you to
create further pressure against the
black king so while it was a mistake we
acknowledge that I actually think from
the Practical point of view when you're
down to under eight minutes in the clock
it was a quite a decent move though
fresenet is not going to be too
displeased about all the pressure he has
in this board
I'll tell you what I'll be displeased
about if we see a repetition with the
Knight jumping into H5 attacking the
queen and falling back but luckily for
us chat none of that is happening
because Magnus is going for the kill he
plays Queen D2 so now Knight H5 can be a
big threat on the board with the 8-6
pawn Under Fire as well Magnus also
bringing his last toy into the game do
not forget your pieces is the first
advice that my coach gave me when I
started playing and I like that The Rook
from A1 will jump into the game yeah no
it's looking like white is about ready
to bring all the pieces to the party and
the bishop on A7 that's not invited at
least not yet so I think oh oh there it
is yeah it happens it did and this D4
Square because the queen was pushed back
to G7 it brings another piece to attack
but look at this move by Max that is a
very calm decision just King the G2 you
know why because once this Pawn takes or
goes to D3 no longer is this night
hanging I'm gonna go back just one move
here that if White made a carols move
like A3 something completely random then
you have to watch out for moves like D3
where now Queen takes G3 is a
devastating threat because the pawn F2
is pinned
wow ideas everywhere and that's why the
king lived by Magnus a nice little
defensive move just stepping out of that
diagonal we see a trade on C3 I love
that Laura has this Central Square for
the night the knight from C6 can't jump
into E5 and Robert the Bishop from D7
can line up to C6 on that diagonal I see
the eval Bar says that Magnus is doing
well in the position he's up and
exchange but the white king is still not
safe and in these formats it's so much
about King safety Bishop C6 in the air a
big threat The Rook from it joining the
party as you said this can get super
tricky yes this Rook has options of
where to threaten the white king side
and Bishop C6 is a nasty threat as well
I think this Rook needs to be replaced
with a bishop I think if White's Bishop
were on e4 then suddenly the F3 Pawn is
defended the king's feeling a bit safer
I just don't know where to move my Rook
because Rook H4 at some moment will be
hit by Knight G6 and things like that so
it's a tough decision for Magnus Carlos
I can you see him going wrong here Tanya
and F3 was hanging so it's hard to also
find a good spot for The Rook Magnus
again making a move that's been awarded
with a question mark That's one award
that you definitely don't want and in
these positions we do see with that move
white skin gets even weaker black does
have the option to anytime step up with
that bishop and now it will be a deadly
pin he first falls back with the Knight
defends it the Knight is headed to H4
the attack continues tricky Laura yeah
no tricky but principled he sacrifices
in exchange to rip open the white king I
mean that was a very good decision by
him and now Magnus needs to find
probably some only moves because this is
getting into territory where he could
just be losing in the next few turns so
where do you even move your king I think
King H2 makes sense but still this
Knight weasels its way into potentially
the F3 Square where that would be a
devastating Fork
yeah the one move you don't want to move
it make is that knight from G3 jump into
H5 attacking the queen because then
we're gonna see a double check with the
G6 Knight coming out of the way and a
mate potentially a mate on G2 that would
be game over so white doesn't have the
time to start a threatening blacks Queen
on G7 this is big big problem for Magnus
and he mentioned Robert that the planes
are super fun to watch but perhaps not
so much fun to play and I don't think
he's having any fun in this game no I I
think that he's looking at this board
and saying can I switch colors is that
allowed come on I'm the number one rated
player on the planet Rook E1 is
apparently a losing blood or Knight H4
check feels automatic but that was a
true blunder that Knight could go into
F3 with a fork of pieces over here the
king can't set to H2 or G1 because then
you'd win the queen on the spot but
Knight H4 that feels automatic step one
then the key is after Knight F3 winning
an exchange back can you convert that
advantage
I love that step one and you might not
need too many steps after that once you
win the material black back and Laura is
heading in that direction look at
White's ugly Pawn structure the King's
Super weak black will be up an extra
Pawn the two Bishops having a bishop and
that's a bishop pair that's absolutely
monstrous imagine Black's Bishop coming
to C6 Robert this is not looking just
bad for Magnus it's looking busted for
him it looks completely lost I would
play Knight F3
I don't even know where this queen goes
but I'm gonna take this Rook anyone F2
is loose Tanya Bishop C6 is a threat
how do you keep your F2 Pawn protected
because if you're Queen E2 then when I
take and you take back I have Bishop C6
the end winning a second exchange I
think this is hopeless at the stage for
Magnus
wow Magnus Carlson starring at defeat in
the second round of the planes against
uh one of his seconds that is a tricky
situation to be in Knight F3 played it's
on the board Magnus with five minutes on
the clock and that's not his biggest
problem right now his position is
falling apart yeah I really just don't
see even like a three move sequence for
him because F2 is loose and that's a
problem because the Knight loses its
Defender there's no stability in White's
position also by the way black currently
has a bishop in one Pawn for a rook so
when this Knight takes a rook at the
very least black will end this series of
moves up a pawn with a bishop pair and
an attack so this has gone really wrong
for Magnus Carlsen I think he's gonna
lose this game
wow and we're getting some big updates
we're talking about and it sounds
strange to say but former world champion
Magnus Carlsen we also have the current
world champion in the mix ding Lauren is
fighting it out he is in round two
currently his game is on against Darius
swers and uh Robert fun fact the
England's username on chesscom is Chef's
house
it is indeed because he's cooking yeah
and he you know he is cooking on the
chessboard maybe he's making some good
dishes he'll have to see his culinary
skills at some point he's done that in
Norway chess in years past but look at
this position he is trying to exploit in
isolated Pawn on A6 maybe it's Pawn on
D4 a bit overextended if I can play E5
at the right moment so it seems like
that was a bad decision just now from
daru spirits but I think his position
just looks bad to my eyes white clearly
with a promising position at this stage
but the one issue is if you ever take on
C4 you drop this E4 Pawn so that's the
big question Tanya is it worth taking a
c Pawn for an e-pawn usually the answer
is no but ding says yes
he is up for fighting this one out he
does go for it counting on that default
Pawn being super weak the evil Pawn's
been picked up a lot of Trades happening
and this means that dingler and ends up
with an extra Pawn but black still has
some trumps the rook and the Queen on
open fires it does feel like there's an
initiative there's a big threat on the
board white can pick up the bishop on G7
and queen D4 check isn't that why is
that not winning a piece Robert it will
be but after Bishop takes D4 but black
is just trying to figure out what to do
because normally you play Rook d8 but
white may just play C3 and say all right
you want to take me on D4 do it you'll
fix my Pawn structure so I think ding
you know he saw that his Pawn structure
was hanging the balance a little bit but
he realized that he can successfully
take this Pawn on D4 after giving up his
Central Pawn and kind of looks to me
like an extra pawn and the only way that
I seek to keep material equal is to take
on D4 because C2 is loose at the end
there but white has a very promising
position the Knight on A5 is such a
thorn in Black side
yeah big threat right now as we've been
talking about and we see that uh Darius
is in a tank he's got to bury that he's
got to find this kind to play Robert
what do you say should we take this
moment as Darius tries to survive this
and jump back to the Magnus game because
I've got my eye out on it and a lot is
happening it is an exciting position big
trouble for Magnus but he's trying to
create his chances he's picked up the B7
Pawn he's down materially right now down
a piece but the E1 Knight is have
hanging The Rook on it is hanging the
bishop on A7 hangs pieces all over the
board or lose the C2 Bishop will be
picked up will black just end up with an
extra piece I
see that you mentioned so many pieces
were under attack I couldn't keep track
and Knight takes C2 looks the simplest
and the reason I say that is if you do
play Bishop C6 and take this Rook on e4
I feel like that does give white some
faint hopes of staying alive but as soon
as you mention the bishop hanging on C2
and just grab that piece why don't you
uh Bishop C6 actually has the secondary
threat of Knight takes E2 as well so
yeah Tanya this is looking like Laurent
should take the W against someone who's
been his boss Magnus Carlson the former
world champion weird to say he has
employed Lauren Francine as a second on
his team if I'm not mistaken and this is
looking like the Frenchman who is
formerly over 2700 has been a super
Grand Master of such a strong player
he's doing everything right with the
black pieces
now he decides to go for the second
option of picking up the Rook so winning
material here and wow that means Robert
we've got Pharma former world champions
Vladimir kramnik Magnus Carlson fighting
it out we've got dingler and in the mix
and we've got the Challenger yeah as
well this is gonna be a fun fun night of
Chess Bishop C6 I think what Magnus is
eyeing is to pick up as many pawns as he
can maybe take the A6 Pawn at this
moment hit that Bishop on C6 you can't
really defend the Rook honey 4 and
you're kind of okay giving it up as long
as you can maintain your own light
squared Bishop as white and don't forget
once that Bishop lands on e4 blacks
Knight on E1 is trapped
it's an essential point and not only
that with the bishop and E4 this a pawn
could be very dangerous down the line so
I'm looking at this position mags
objectively in huge trouble but if he
takes on A6 fresename may have to find
an accurate move or two queen D7
protects the bishop and threads Queen
takes H3 that looks really promising to
my eyes Tanya because the bishop on C2
is still loose so I feel like he's gonna
run out of Tricks is Magnus Carlsen and
he's gonna drop to one out of two
yeah it's not an ideal start but it's a
long long event nine games in the Swiss
we're into the second round Bishop C6
played Magnus down on the clock as well
by a minute and look at that he doesn't
go upon hunting he first falls back with
the bishop to B1 almost seemingly losing
a move here inviting black to pick up
the Rook on e4 but it doesn't feel right
Bishop B1 it just feels as a Magnus is
he doesn't know what to do in this
position and he's just holding and
hoping and praying for black to make a
big mistake here if the clock situation
were reversed maybe he would have some
chances but fresna is also doing well on
time and queen takes C3 that's a pin
piece didn't have to capture it right
away now the Knight you go to F3 and
into D2 because this King has to step
back in this diagonal and now after
Knight D2 this Rook is hanging this
bishop is hanging this queen can go to
F3 with check this is lights out if he
just plays the very nice Knight to D2
and he does he does go for an ID to
clinical stuff here by fresener just
taking all the opportunities and not
rushing picking up material the queen
and the Knight on the attack and it
comes down to that practical decision of
giving up the exchange with Rook F3 and
it all worked out and very often you
kind of ignore what the eval Bar says
you take your practical chances and
that's how you beat well a former world
champion and the world rapid and Blitz
champion
so weird to think of him as the former
world champion but that is what he is
and I'm wondering right now because
there's a rook under attack a bishop
under attack if Knight takes B1 maybe
white has this kind of queen C7 there's
a pin down the C line already there are
some threats in the air so you do have
to be a little bit careful for First
United he just takes on e4 which that
looks like a good move taking some
material we'll see a bunch of exchanges
and I think what Max is relying on Tanya
is his Queen protects F2 and that could
be huge because he won't lose the game
immediately and the black king isn't the
safest you would love to be able to push
this Pawn over to G7 not allowed I'm
sorry
and I like what Lara has done as well
because that pawn is not on G7 he wants
to control the D4 Square you don't want
to get too far from that otherwise white
screen comes and gives a brutal check on
D4 keeping everything in taxol or also
keeping his Queen in the center hitting
that Knight on e4 x-raying that F4 Pawn
white can't fall back with the Knight
anyway Queen F4 would be a big check
he's got to find a way to defend that E4
Knight with the queen queen B7 or come
back Queen E3 black can start pushing
the central pawns yeah it seems like it
doesn't matter you can kick the Knight
out regardless and F4 will in fact drop
so I like the move D5 but there's Queen
B2 check just like Queen D4 was a threat
you have to be very careful Queen P2 was
a nasty threat but he's gonna block with
Queen G7 and threaten the Checkmate of
his own
Queens are off the board it's game over
black has enough bonds and he's up and
exchange so really again clinical
Precision conversion by Laura frassene
and in fact after Queen G7 it's hard to
imagine a white trying to avoid trades
but he's got to do just that he brings
the Knight to the defense F4 you can
pick up you lose the C7 Pawn but the F2
Pawn is hanging as well and this is huge
that because F4 is gone Queen E5 if you
didn't have Queen E5 the game would have
been a draw immediately with Rook G7
back to G8 when the queen was trying to
go back and forth but that square was
available oh my goodness I mean Francine
is doing everything right bringing up
Pawn so that H4 now is a target F2 also
is under Fire so really nicely played so
far by fresenay and he's up on the clock
that remains important
yeah this is a master class on how to
convert a winning position and and
winning a winning position is one of the
hardest things in chess especially when
you're playing against a Magnus Carlsen
here and look at him now he's doubling
up on the f file your knight can't jump
to E4 Queen F3 will be game over it will
be lights at Magnus just Holding On by a
thread I think it's time well it's time
to pick up another pawn and at some
point just start marching down the board
with your central pawns yeah this Pawn
can be captured there was no check on
the diagram no useful one the queen
could always slide back to F6 and after
Queen F4 now the H Pawn it was doubled
and I said early on a potential Target
now it's an asset and it's running up to
age for kicking the night out of there
opening the G file for mating attacks I
really think this has been exemplary
play from pressing a
and Queenie 2 trying to hold on to the
F2 Pawn as you mentioned Robert it's
time to hit that Knight destabilize the
defender and step by step fresenal
gaining on the position on the advantage
this will this looks like it's going to
end in Checkmate you've got to go back
all the way to H1 Queen G4 coming in and
always a check can be blocked with Queen
to G7 threatening amid offering a queen
trade game over lights out from Magnus
Carlsen I mean this really was a master
class I feel like I learned a lot and
that's over this is official fresenay
has won every move he played was the
best move and he played with purpose he
stole a pawn brought his Pawn up the
board kicked the night there threatened
Checkmate block the check with his Queen
and that's going to be made so really
nicely done from fresna let's maybe head
on over to some of our remaining games
like Jeffrey Jean who's in the
competition yeah
now let's do that is of course the
established a lead of the world but also
the youngsters go vying for the spot in
that aim chest rapid and we've got here
Jeffrey Zhang with the black pieces and
wow that's a lot of material up but they
should be just lost for black uh for
white sorry yeah completely lost the uh
game we just tuned into the bar took a
little bit there but now that it's up to
speed it's an extra piece and two pawns
for Jeffrey Zhang by the way vuca
rasulov is playing an over the board
tournament right now so he must have
finished his game and said let me log on
to chess.com and play in the anxious
rapid playing and well he lost this game
His official Jeffrey zong takes it and
goes to two out of two
not just him updates coming in with
Wesley so on two out of two Lavon aronia
and Jeffrey Sean joins
joins and I also
also names who are still fighting some
games are still on or do we have all the
results in Robin well we have Vladimir
Crumley playing and unfortunately for
him losing but Igor kovalenko super
strong player
um you know he has gone through a lot
with what's happening in Ukraine I mean
he has been very vocal about it he
streams as well he's done well title
Tuesdays so Props to Igor kovalenko uh
who is taking down Vladimir kramnik with
the black pieces and yeah it's just a
really clear exchange up when it's over
yeah it's an exchange job and you're
always threatening to pick up that
Bishop going to a winning King Pawn
ending and Vladimir kramnik resigns also
on the clock he has been flagged which
means that he does lose the second round
and Robert we've got a big round three
coming up with some of the big names
looking for a comeback yeah and you know
you start with two out of two you start
to feel pretty good about your chances
to make match play and try to qualify
for division one and as they look at the
standings some familiar faces there
right we have jaspam that's Jose
Martinez uh Wesley so these some of
these players don't need any
introduction introduction excuse me but
Peter Fiddler happy to see him taking
part Tanya usually we've heard him
commentating but he reminds us all that
he's a fantastic player and he's won the
Russian Championship eight times yeah
he's pretty darn good
yeah he's an absolute Legend and uh be
sweetie as we call him well he is
looking for a spot in the aim chess
rapid he's had a fantastic start with
two out of two some and Serana piranha
there as well in the mix this is gonna
be a fun fun ride he's on two out of two
as well as well as Daniel dubo Robert
Everywhere You see there are only big
big names here fighting for those big
top 72 finish in the Swiss and of course
uh wiring for that division one of the
aim chest rapid and we still got some
games on I see here with black Dan Laz
playing on seconds but this looks like
bad news he's down two pawns white so
close to queening once the Knight joins
the party on the queen side this should
be over yeah you can bring the Knight
around to the square D6 this Knight on
A8 is actually quite hard to kick out of
the corner that's the annoying part is
because the pawns are split the way they
are that it's not that simple to run the
pawn through and then last he's trying
his best but that was really well done
as you said Tanya once the Knight joins
the party it's game over and it's a
party for one it's only for Parham
yeah wow Barham having all the fun and
this one he doesn't even want to win a
night he wants to win a queen he wants
to promote that Queen on A8 picking up
that night and I don't see a way for
black to stop it you could pick up the F
upon you could pick up the B4 Pawn but
that's about it that's where the night
ends uh for Dan Laz uh at least in this
game and Parham looks like he's taking
this one and he has Dan Laz resigns wow
that was a nice finish nice couple of
moves sequence of moves leading up to
this Victory and I see we have Thomas
chefsky taking on Min me in a very
popular streamer uh this game is still
going and it would appear that white
with an extra exchange should be better
but Tanya that's a beast of a bishop on
e4
and a beast of a rook on H2 just so much
counter player for black species and
that pawn on G3 one of white struck
always has to be on the defense of that
weakness which kind of slows down the
activity of the two Rooks and I like
that Bishop on e4 that you mentioned
it's not only a great attacker it's such
a brilliant Defender as well just
guarding all of Black's weak pawns here
not just the pawns the king as well from
all the checks and that's why araval Bar
says despite being having the material
deficit black is doing fine because of
the peace activity the bishop really
does it all it protects C6 and is
protected by C6 defends F7 you go to E4
defend F5 and shuts down the fifth rank
so The Rook can't even attack that loose
Pawn on F5 this is really nice defense
from Min and I wonder Tony if at some
point if tomaszewsky tries too hard to
win if black can suddenly try to play
for a win if this King could get over to
H5 and the G4 like get that King in
there somehow maybe black could even
have a chance
wow yeah that would definitely be
something that is on men's mind but I
think we're gonna see a repetition as
it's very difficult for both players to
make any any further progress in the
position and we see this one ends in a
draw
seemed like a fair result and that's a
good result for men drawing with black
against super gems that's what you want
to do but you also want to keep winning
because the competition is very stiff
and Magnus Carlsen doesn't have a
perfect two out of two score but I see
Sam Sevin does
oh yeah so many results are coming in
and going into
round three we are going to have some
players on the perfect scores and some
big names not on a perfect score we've
got a Radha Guard from India he is a
youngster he's playing an exchange up in
this position but a rook and king was
his King and Knight this is a
theoretically drawn position uh it is
the only way for white to lose in this
in these kind of end games is to keep
them is to get the Knight and the King
very far away from each other and then
you end up losing the Knight as long as
the king and the Knight can be best
friends and just stay really close
Robert White's doing good best friends
till the end and when's the end after
the 15 move rule the game will conclude
in a draw so the king of the night are
not going to separate great uh
illustration of how to draw this
position the king does not want to go
away and the Knight is helping out not
even allowing the king to step forward
no long-distance relationship with these
two on the board and that's exactly what
we're seeing white Play at just keeping
the king and the Knight together keeping
everything defended and this will end in
a draw in just a couple of moves of
course white will play a black will play
it out till the end but the 50 move rule
should stop the clock any moment and I
have to say we see the FM title attached
to the player with the black pieces and
it's because he worked his way into the
field qualifying based on those Monday
qualifiers so shout out to not just
qualification but scoring points against
strong Grand Masters like convert Holt
he does really well in title Tuesdays in
fact he won a title Tuesday so uh that's
a great result for a Roger Garg here and
you gotta just tip your hat off to the
guy
yeah absolutely he is a very talented
player from India Radia and Robert as
you mentioned qualifying from the Monday
qualifiers the planes are for Grand
Masters as well as the top three
finishes of the Monday qualifiers which
has other title players and here he's
keeping all his defenses going and Robin
is this the last game remaining for
round two considering where I move 145
yeah no this has to be the last game
going if there's another one I don't
even want to look at it because it's
probably some equally theoretically
drawn ending
um but yeah I believe this is in fact
the last game going on for this round
wow and I this will be ending in a draw
soon and I see we've got Wesley still
out of the heavy hitres Wesley So Daniel
duboff love on aronian are all on two
points and of course Laura fresna as
well after that big win against Magnus
Carlsen and we've got Serana as well on
two points so a lot of players with a
100 score so far and that's a big
confidence boost what you really want is
to have a hot streak once you have a hot
streak then you can't afford to mess up
one of those games in the middle of the
Swiss portion and still be in the mix to
make it in the top uh in the match play
yeah and also when you keep winning your
opponents get a bit more gentle later on
in the tournament but you know if you
have say
six out of seven it might make a couple
draws to make sure you get to match play
but if you have a lower score you need
to start winning so this game is a draw
and that means that Conrad Hall if he
hopes to get into match play he'll have
to get on a winning streak but round
three is beginning
we have so many great matchups like I'm
just gonna click on some Lavon aronian
taking on Lauren fresenay pressy Nate
beat Magnus guess what your reward is
wow you have to play Black against Levon
aronian
but I don't know a little bit and he's
loving it he's still reeling from the
fact and all the jokes he's going to be
cracking with Magnus once the Swiss is
over they're two good friends so he's
gonna have some fun with that but of
course right now it's fun on the
chessboard he's facing Levon and that's
another moment for fresenada shine it
starts with the Italian we saw Magnus
face the brunt of it against Lauren can
Laura do it again in the same opening
I mean that first time was the charm
we'll see if second time will also work
out for him it would happen in that game
was black Castle brought the king to the
corner and eventually this Knight
rerouted to H6 it's a bit of an awkward
sequence but if I'm remembering
correctly levana Roman was one of The
Originators of that plan like I've seen
him in games from well over a decade
maybe two decades ago at this point with
King age eight Knight G8 type of ideas
to push F5 not in this game and there's
no Nike for any way because the Palm
went to H3 but we have a very quiet
start it would seem to this game Tanya
you're totally on point with that Robert
Lebanon has been
ideas in the opening and the fact that
black can get that F Pawn moving to F5
he's played so many brilliant games
employing that himself and I think
that's the reason he put in this little
move H3 to make sure that idea doesn't
come into play and now we see more
thematic Italian Maneuvers where the
white knight is headed to the center
from G3 eyeing that F5 Square the Bishop
from C1 can be offering a trade on E3
because that black Bishop on A7 is a
piece that you really want to get rid of
in this position yeah so exactly as you
were saying following that thematic
Italian plant do not take this Pawn on
B7 I'm just gonna put it on the board so
you can see why because some people say
why'd you bring your queen out here if
you're not going to go and take it well
after Rook to B8 this Rook over here
Queen takes A6 I like to point this out
when they're two pieces in the same line
think what happens when the piece in
between them gets out the way and you're
not going to stop on B6 or C5 or D4 even
E3 but you can take on F2 with check and
it says hello to the queen and also
goodbye because once your king reacts to
the bishop the queen is lost in A6
oh yeah that is going to be a painful
hello for the queen on E6 and that's not
gonna happen as you mentioned the B7
Pawn is a poison Pawn in the position
you never pick it up you just eye it you
just make black feel that that's always
a threat on the board that he needs to
watch out for we see the Bishops have
been traded off the board and now white
has a double bond but that also means
more control in the center and Robert I
like what you're highlighting here
because white will reroute his Rook to
the open F line and we might even see a
potential sacrifice on F6 which is why
it's important for black to play
actively and he immediately strikes in
the center you sent sacrifice in F6 and
wait a second fresna isn't white in this
game because that's what he did in
Magnus that exchange sacrifice and this
is why you learn from the games that you
watch everybody because all you in chat
we just saw fresenade do it uh to Magnus
if that Knight were to sit on F6 just
like Tanya was saying this Rook would
think about sacrificing for it but for
now we have these kind of weird pawns on
D3 and E3 is this one gonna go D4 is
this one going to be for it that's a big
question but if you play E4 the night
May hop into F4 so you have to time
these things well and for Lavon speaking
of time he's barely spent any he has
thrived in this format Tanya
we've seen him do that time and time
again in the Champions Chester he's
always the player with more time on the
clock he has such great control he's
playing intuitively he's playing fast
and he's also playing really well I
think it was Vlad who said big Vlad that
you know in these formats you either
play fast or you play good but Levon
seems to be doing both of them with a
great ease and he goes for the plan with
pushing the E Pawn because then that
also takes control of that F5 square and
now that the Rooks are in the Central
files D4 is not out of the question it's
something that white always has and he
does he goes for it immediately making
sure that the Knight on F4 is not
feeling too easy for too long yeah this
Knight looks good on F4 but it's a lone
piece now you do have to watch out at
some point for a sacrifice on H3 it will
not work out at this moment and the
reason why I just want to put this on
the board doesn't take much analysis
after Queen takes H3 two knights are
hanging in a row but the king acts as
the defender sliding up to F2 protecting
the both of them so that's why Lavon
he's sitting relaxed at home just
focusing on the chest he's not worried
about Knight takes H3 in this position
and it said we did just see the move
Queen to D6 played you do attention to
watch out for Queen G6 Tanya so Laurent
is keeping threats alive with his Knight
being loose on G3
I'm just loving love on speed it's like
he's Speedy Gonzalez today he's down to
like 9 minutes 39 seconds he barely took
time to strike in the center so much
pressure on level in the position on uh
fresen on Laura in the position and on
the clock as well now Rook F1 eyeing
that F4 Knight again black can slide
with the queen to G6 hitting that Knight
on G3 and yes you can't move that Knight
because Queen G2 would be a big threat
but one more time we will see Black's
King a whites King be a great defender
just simply sidestepping to H2 defending
that Knight on G3 making sure there's
nothing on G2 everything holds is there
it takes D4 this is what I'm currently
considering Tanya the Knight is loose on
G3 so if you go Queen G6 that's very
direct I see your plan I'm gonna defend
but if I take on D4 he goes Queen G6 and
said that was a mistake I'm just gonna
take us back a second here because I do
think that that was a missed opportunity
and you see the question mark it shows
that Black's move was not the right one
e takes D4 instead if you play Pawn
takes I was thinking Knight takes H3
check because you say check to the king
and check to the knight at the same time
and somehow it's not an overwhelming
Advantage for black even though it looks
good I guess the king comes to H2 the
Night comes back to F4 and white is
doing okay thanks to the Pawns in the
center but Tonya Black would love to
steal a Pawn off the board
I love this tactic that you're pointing
out and I think this is a big big Miss
by Laurel very uncharacteristic he's a
super aggressive player who finds these
ideas but Queen G6 was a tempting move
and as we were pointing out yes it's got
a great idea but white skin can be a key
defender in the position and very often
we know that Knights are great attackers
but it's also true that in chess the
Knight is also a brilliant Defender a
king and Knight
combination and you've got so many
squares under control and that's exactly
what we're seeing being played out here
now Lorac going on to try to trade one
of those Knights and I think white can
simply accept it no harm done Knight H5
uh Queen H5 and you keep all the
pressure in the center is Levon also
considering jumping with his own Knight
to F5 that looks risky yeah so you're
right it did look a bit risky because
the G3 score would have been loose and
the Knight could jump back to F4 it said
he trades and goes after the Knight on
C6 Queen G6 can be met by move like
Knight H4 because it's not just the
Knight that's hanging F7 is loose and
they're all all sorts of problems in
this position D5 may win the C7 Pawn
Tanya look at levon's clock look at the
eval bar next to the board he seems to
do everything right in these rapid time
controls
look at levon's position and look at
those chessboards at the back of the
screen that we see Levon sitting in
that's a whole lot of Chess books on the
chest shelf and a lot of inspiration in
that move and Lavon aronia playing a lot
of inspired chess yeah and speaking of
books I can't wait until Lavon writes
you know an autobiography or depends his
best Games Collection I will certainly
read that I know Levon very well you
know he is a guy who has uh so many
different interests he loves jazz music
he loves art he just loves creativity
and well maybe he should have been a
little bit more creative rather than
passive because Queen E2 it earned that
question mark I think at Pawn C7 that
could have been grabbed over there but
instead he takes a defensive approach
and it's one of these moments where you
have to question the speed a little bit
we have been praising it but did he move
too quickly there because his Center
looks good but he could have stolen a
pawn and maybe had more of an advantage
Robin is one of life's biggest dilemmas
that your strengths can often at times
become your weaknesses when you've been
playing fast on the clock and that
critical moment is missed but look at
what we're seeing on the board being
played at that Queen moved to E2 it does
expose it to the pain Queen D5 some
creative defensive resource here by
Laura if white picks up the queen you
destroy your Pawn structure black strip
jumps into the activity saying hello to
white screen there but level barely
taking any time jumps in with the Knight
I like that response F7 was hanging but
not anymore because the King on H2 will
Spin and Levon steps out of the PIN
super smart play from LeBron that move
I'm happy with him to play quickly but
some of the previous moves he probably
could have spent a little bit of time
but look at the black king on G8 if
somehow this queen could sneak to the
diagonal we may be talking about
potential mates but the Knight is being
kicked out of here and maybe Levon and
Knight G4 will have to play E5 and break
open the king that way or Tanya I know
it's kind of spicy but Rook takes F6
trying to steal some pawns from the
black king don't be surprised if that
works at some moment
it's always in the air and white could
also think about doing a rook lift with
that Rook on D1 but right now Queen E4
is a Potential Threat on the board will
Levon try to create a counter play or
will he simply defend the pawn on e4
with a move like Rook E1 here
yeah he's holding nothing back he plays
E5 because F5 is met by D5 potentially
let's throw our pawns forward in the
center so Tony if not for F5 F takes e
that's what Laurent quickly plays he's
running a bit lower on the clock I think
after d takes E5 well the reason why
white is so much better this Knight is
offside white has both Rooks unopened
files but I just don't see The Knockout
yet and if you're saddled with his
eyesight Pawn the center then maybe
black has some chances down the road if
you can get to an end game
as the first time first time I've had
slowed
that choice here but look at this it
might be the obvious choice but that one
is anything but obvious he first hits
that Knight on A5 and you can't fall
back to C6 that ends up with D5 coming
in winning a piece knight C4 ends up
with D5 again coming in Robert winning
the piece the only square is Knight on
B7 and that's an ugly one you don't like
to feed and cattle your Knights that's
how the saying goes and that would be
great as a bishop in fact black may be
thrilled if that was a bishop 1b7 but
that's a knight and the pawn on B4 says
No Escape for you the pawn E5 says No
Escape although there is Knight to D6 so
that is an option because the pin along
the e-file and if I'm Laurent I'm really
thinking about it instead he pushes with
A5 whoa a game losing mistake somehow oh
there should be a blow right now you're
pointing out some amazing ideas that
centralize the queen eyeing the king
side but hitting the Knight on the other
side of the board on B7 Queen E4 can you
go Knight D6 hitting that Queen on e4
there are so many tactics across the
board I mean let's take a look because
that's a blunder a critically bad move
and I think it's because of tactics
against the black king as Queen E4 hits
the Knight on B7 you said Knight D6 that
looks to be the only move because if you
just defend passing by the way he went
Queen F3 instead which actually was
given the thumbs up but Queen E4 the
point is you defend Knight F6 check
politics in comes the queen to G6 the
King has to slide the corner and I can
start taking all of your pawns with a
mating attack against the black king but
let's go to the game because it might be
over soon Tanya Queen F3 the Knight was
under attack so C6 was played and there
it is Knight F6 check
wow in the last game Lauren Fraser now
with Rook F3 and in this one the F6
Square Robert you pointed this out about
a hundred years ago that we might be
seeing a sacrifice on F6 and it has
arrived Knight F6 check it's all about
opening up the king if black accepts it
white picks it up with that pawn on E5
and once that pawn arrives on F6 that
pawn is way worse than a piece you're
threatening that pawn to F7 and also
mates on G3 and G7 coming in what a game
by Lavon aroni an absolute Masterpiece
yeah and it's got the double exclamation
point everyone in chat be honest with us
how many realities have you had come on
let us know I want to hear what your
recent success is because I see how
thrilled people are on social media when
they're like I got my first brilliant
move hey keep them coming we'd love to
see it and thanks for being here but
what Lavon is saying to Lauren he's like
well it was good to see you my friend
but bye bye because if you take on F6
not only can you take with the pawn
queen G3 check might be the very direct
way because if the king comes up The
Rook captures Queen G6 Rook D7 this king
is being mated in the open line and wait
a second I was making the moves but
that's actually what's happening so it
wasn't even just me doing it the players
have reached this position and Tanya
this king is just a busted
it's all on the board and queen H5 a
nice move what you want is the roofing
lined up and rub it we see it on the
board it might look obvious but Queen H5
is absolute genius you want to pick up
that 86 Pawn With The Rook giving a maid
and queen it's a H5 is what wraps up the
game Rook 86 there's no stopping the
rook and queen lining up and a blue on
the H line
no this is just crushing the King has
nowhere to go and the reason why Tanya
is correctly calling that a such a
fantastic move is that the queen had
taken on H6 immediately the black queen
can step in there may take a little bit
more time White's still winning but it
would take a little bit more time to
deliver the knockout this is direct
giving Laurent no chance whatsoever he's
down five minutes he's up a piece but
his King is being hunted so this is just
such an excellent display of Chess from
levonne aronian just amazing stuff and
you set up a piece but what piece
from B7 was dominated the entire game
with white spawns and it was all the
player on the king side and a stunning
finish there precise and we see that
Laura fresenet has resigned after this
masterful move the final touch to this
uh Beauty with Queen H5 Rook at Six
coming in fantastic game by left he
moves on to three out of three Robert
we've got more action on where should we
jump to I'm loving the chess
yeah I'm gonna take us to a game between
go Wayne Jones and Jana pamelishi and uh
Jana Palm she played for the world
championship but I just want to you know
say very clearly you know the most
heartfelt condolences to Gawain and his
family I mean it's such a tragedy with
his wife Sue's passing um but you know
he's playing in this event he has the
white pieces against yonda palmishi and
from what I see
I'm telling you no problems at all in
this position for Gwen it looks just
pretty even
yeah it's a great position for white
right now you've got no weaknesses it
looks like this will end in a draw and
Robert just do what you said absolutely
heartbreaking news there and perhaps in
some ways chess can also be therapeutic
for these players
yeah the Chess World and the many other
communities that Sue was a part of came
through big time I saw uh when you know
they're raising funds to help going in
the family and you know it's actually
making me criteria I just thinking about
it talking about it so I mean really I
just want to extend my deepest
sympathies to Gawain and family and the
two young kids it's just I mean there
are no words for these kind of tragedies
and uh you know this game right now you
know it's uh maybe something that brings
him joy in a very difficult time but as
we talk about the chess this looks very
even so uh you know I'm happy to go to
another game uh and we'll come back to
Gwen and Jan later in the tournament
yeah and I think it would be a great
result as well for going to hold this
one and it looks like he's doing it with
quite a bit of ease and activity
targeting those Queen side pawns uh it
will not be enough for black to have a
more active King in this position we
will keep an eye out on this one but
there's a lot of middle game action in
the other games as well Robert what
catches your attention
well there's a former candidate in the
tournament playing against somebody
who's almost 2700 and maybe a future
candidate Sam Seville absolute Beast the
way that he has been playing chess
recently has been just fantastic to
watch look at this oh
Rook E3 just played by Sam double
exclamed take my Rook please because
there's made on G2
wow and if you don't take my Rook Rook
G3 just pursuing that attack was a big
threat so once again we see uh that
white had to step up with the King
trying to defend this very difficult
position with black up material with all
the attack on the king side this is Sam
savian's game
yeah look at the safe King on B7 blacks
up in exchange and a pawn The Rook comes
to see three make sure everything's
defended he just goes after the pawn
look at how direct he is he brought his
work back and then back and says all
right you're pushing your Pawn to where
nowhere all the blacks pieces are oh my
gosh rookies oh look at her speed it's
perfect stuff and he's not going out
after the Ponder but he's going after
White's King once black does pick up the
H5 pawn it will be checkmate with the
queen and the Rook combining Landing up
on H1 so that's not just getting greedy
for a pawn it's getting greedy for the
win and some amazing conversion there
and we see in fact that we're just 0.7
seconds left that girl has resigned in
this position Alexander goes down and
San savian gets the point
he does indeed and well he moves to a
perfect three out of three and let's go
to the game between Peter stidler and
David paravian paravian he's been really
strong in Rapid time controls over the
last few years but if I'm doing a quick
material count Tanya black is up a pawn
and don't forget don't sleep on this
bishop on A7 because I might forget it's
there at some point so remind me that if
this queen never moves from D2 F2 will
be loose
I'm hearing you Robert and I agree with
everything that you've said and I also
really like Black's last move putting
pressure on that E5 Bishop along the E
line but the one Trump for white is that
black has weakened the king side that
8-6 a G5 structure and it can be a
target for white give white a couple of
moves let H4 come in and then suddenly
we'll be singing a different tune so yes
black is looking better here but still
needs Precision to convert it it's far
from over Peter swedler still has job a
job to do with this one oh whoa he just
hung a piece what oh wait was that trick
wait wait wait wait I got tricked I was
tricked I
look at this let's go back because I
have to show everyone what I miss queen
takes F2 check is the sick counter that
Bishop takes F6 you have to take with
your queen and rookie one is mate so I
set myself up for failure I admit it to
the world I had owned my mistakes
everybody but Dave Province did not make
that error but whatever did he make
because Tanya C6 was a big blunder and I
don't know
I think the point is that you can first
hit that Queen on B6 you got Knight A4
stopping Queen F2 and you don't have a
good Square for the queen where are you
gonna move your queen and defend the F6
Knight Queen d8 is it Queen trade
resulting in with Bishop F6 coming in
and this just wins a piece Intermezzo
Knight F4 wow 984 what a good move
Knights on the rim not always dim that
would have dimmed the hopes for black in
the position but said after H3 the
bishop doesn't move the Knight comes D7
and that was a great choice hitting the
bishop 185 and now the Knight comes into
E4 so all of these pieces are hanging
here this bishop on E5 the bishop on G4
we see the bishop G4 cap E5 captain and
then the bishop G4 is capture as well
and Tanya you said just because black
was up a pawn it didn't tell the whole
story I agree with you that the King on
G7 isn't that safe but nor is the King
on G1
and I really wanted to play Knight G3
heading with that Knight to F5 but then
again the trick that you've been
pointing out Queen to F2 give up that
Queen win the game with pinning white
screen on F2 it's always in the air
white doesn't have time to pick up the
Knight on D7 because then a black has
another great idea of picking up the
Knight on e4 and then Queen F2 would be
hanging tricks everywhere King H2 a very
human response stepping out of all these
threats but again a question mark and
now black trades off the queens and is
up a pawn and a Net game that's going to
count
so the only question is will black be
winning there because opposite colored
Bishops that tends to mean that they're
good drawing chances but Queen C1
keeping the queen that can't be good
because the King on G7 is now quite safe
the King on H2 no no no that is not a
safe King it's a knight F6 played and we
see a trade but is there Queen takes F2
because Queen H4 is mate in some of
these positions
wow and instead he does and I think
Robert you were on point because we see
across that Queen after was a deadly
idea but in this position again apita
swindler playing on seconds keeps it
simple he picks up the Knight he's up an
extra Pawn it's an opposite color Bishop
so there might still be something to be
done but not really once you win the F2
pawn queen G3 is Checkmate and with that
we see that white David barabian does
throw in the towel he does resign gets
flagged it is game over Peter swidler on
fire
Petey spins that's what you call him or
is it Peter's Fizz Pete Smitty what was
it peace be sweaty Robin like I P Diddy
I got you I got you my bad I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm not you know hip like
everybody else so uh let's uh keep on
moving so I can move past this moment
and let's go to the game between Daniel
dubov and Parham magsudu maxulu Farm
he's a rap fan so he'll be disappointed
in me when he eventually hears that I
didn't get the reference you're making
but what in the world is happening here
black is down a pawn but apparently
winning because there's a mating attack
Queen H1 is a massive threat on the
board and notice how that Bishop on C6
stops all of white screen activity there
is no Queen E8 on the board but white
has
it has Daniel been flagged already is
this game over
it's over on the clock it's over on the
board he doesn't have a single check so
this queen is coming in and no matter
what and that will be made so Parham
maksudu he takes down Daniel dubov in a
clash of Super GMS I guess we got to
keep on going because uh so many more
games are still in session and what is
happening between Ivan sarich and Maxine
matlakov it's one of these end games
Tanya where I need to dust off the dim
red scheme in-game manual looks like it
should be a draw but White's Pawn is
more advanced
should be could be would be but with 18
seconds on the clock anything can happen
but Robert as you're saying very often
in these positions there are times when
black can actually even think about
advancing his own Jeep on for counter
play White's King will get to be seven
and perhaps it might be time for black
to start thinking about creating play on
the king side combining the King on 87
and the pawn on G5 and eventually
sacrificing The Rook for the B Pawn the
one thing you tend to want to avoid as
Tanya knows very well from experience is
separating the king from the pawn I
always make this reference I shouted out
on his autons to get the top of the show
she got her GM Norm won the Karen's cup
with a round of spare she's doing
awesome but she did have that heartbreak
against you in the Olympian where the
pawn was separated from the King and
Tanya suddenly it's looking a little
dangerous but the king is in the right
place to help the pawn go forward
and that's the plan that I was talking
to you about Robert luckily for me I was
on the right side of that unfortunate
incident but we see here the plan the
defensive resource you give up your Rook
for the past rebound you combine the
Jeep on and the King but make sure the
king isn't too far behind don't get
greedy with just advancing the pawn it's
got to be a combined effort and it just
looks like black skin with shoulder
white skin not allowing the white king
to come into the defense and just assess
the cheap one and this should be a drop
it requires a little bit I think a
couple of more precise moves from Black
yeah I mean there's some potential for
Rook against Knight right we get that in
some endings here and so we see the G3
move but now the king is uh in great
position so I don't think that there's
too much work left if G2 King D3
King F2 and check I'll go this way don't
step in front of your Pawn now you
threaten to promote and your king can
just keep going back and forth
[Music]
draw a nice uh defense uh defensive
resource there uh buy black in this
position this ends in a draw Robert
we've got more action with players
playing on seconds let's jump to one of
our top boards because
yeah there's a lot happening and some
interesting end games
yeah just clicking what games are ending
as soon as I click them but here this
one is interesting because it's opposite
color Bishops with Rooks on the board
white has a healthy past Pawn over here
but it seems like black is block hitting
it nicely until Rook G6 check happens
and that is a threat on the board
attacks keeps pressuring that bishop and
wow and we see the eval bar do a little
jump but it's so difficult for the
players to be precise so I'm expecting a
lot of eval bar jumps here and Robert I
am going to predict to draw here I think
that's what most of us would it's hard
to imagine uh the H Pawn getting any
further with the rook and the King black
skin and The Rook defending well it is
on H6 now and what Clark really wants to
do is get the Rook to H3 black could
have taken the pawn it was hanging from
two different pieces and it wasn't
captured I think black's gonna lose this
game I just have a feeling that oh
I
oh commentators curse
what just happened there D5 and a check
and the bishop hangs oh one more blunder
and white luck as a bishop and London is
The Rook on the next move this is a
complete collapse rabbit what did we
just watch
I'm gonna do an instant replay and it
really hurts because I was just saying I
thought black was going to lose and then
walked right into a discover check hard
to see when you don't have time the
check happens winning the piece then the
king went back and The Rook went to E7
so Drop The Rook as well mistakes
usually come in pairs but mistakes
usually aren't this big in magnitude
okay we can't look at this game anymore
oh my gosh this is absolutely
heartbreaking a far a white in this one
I mean you're kind of dominating being
the one who pushes but this is what
happens Jesse is heartbreaking Robin and
we saw a one more blunder and another
one more blunder and here we are seeing
white trying to defend this position
down two pawns but the good news is is
there a good news for white hair
nope I don't see it
no the black oh wait a second
suddenly there's a chance
why is that not easy to see where
because you've got the Knight jumping in
uh he gives a check King H2 he wants to
give another check but black just goes
to H1
yeah I mean the Knight just went into D2
and so
yeah does he just yeah that's it
that was strange the bar very quickly
went to even I'm not sure if that was uh
you know lack of depth or what but black
won this game I think yamas deserved it
yeah nice conversion there uh with
Knight D2 deflecting White's a Defender
and now there's no stopping the black G2
Pawn from queening and going into round
fall we've got
quite a few players on 100 score nine
players I see on our list Robert
including Sam I Am Sam savian with three
points as well as Wesley Seoul Lavon
aronian and P Diddy as well in the mix
P Diddy well he didn't now you're making
the mistake because of me look what just
happened there wow and that would be
amazing if P Diddy started playing chess
and was able to do a three out of three
in this playing
all right be sweaty in the mix even
better he is with three out of three a
lot of players on two and a half and
Magnus Carlsen did he manage to win his
third game Robert
that's a very good question I'll have to
look for him in the standings
oh okay well that not I shouldn't be
surprised I don't know why I was like oh
wow no it's Magnus Carlson when he wins
that's kind of the norm but uh he will
have to keep up that winning streak
because he needs to catch up to many
players so should we head on into uh
some other games
let's do it as we are about to kick off
a round four and for those of you who
are just joining us these are the plans
for the aim chess rapid it is the Swiss
potion with nine runs and a game four
has started and we're seeing already
players going for blood here uh be
sweetie with the white pieces goes for
H4 I'm loving it already hits the bishop
on G5 is levon's response I mean this
game is gonna be amazing Robert these
two players have been on fire from the
start of the Swiss portion and I can't
believe how much time levana Ronin has
spent and I'm half joking because he
sells nine minutes and 30 seconds but it
seemed like in his previous games he was
blitzing out every single move now with
this H Pawn thrust from smidler Harry
the H Pawn going forward playing that
Alpha zero style now Lavon has a big
decision to make where does that Queen
belong it can go to D6 it can go to A6
it can go to E4 with check but the
bishop will slide back and then Rook H4
may be an idea at some point to kick the
queen out of there tough choice for
Lavon right now
I think you make a great Point Queen E4
is so tempting to give a check but
actually that just walks into why it's a
plan of developing the pieces and then
immediately after that targeting the
queen queen D6 I like it because if we
notice white spawn structure white has
created some dark squared weaknesses
Queen Z6 Bishop falls back C5 was a big
threat black will never allow it what
black wants to do is place his own
pieces on these dark squares so I like
that he's delayed the development of the
bishop instead brings the Knight into
the game controlling the C5 square and
ideas of B6 Knight C5 and then Bishop E7
really holding his own in the center
Long Term because of the pawn structure
white has got some strategic weaknesses
to handle yeah and black has a couple
strategic weakness of his own the F5
Square the pawn on H5 means that G6
won't be easy to play whoa
wait weren't we just talking about how
the Knight cover the square look at
peacefitty he says I'm gonna give you
that pawn and I'm gonna go after the
king look at how much more development
white has I count three minor pieces
developed and only one for black
and Robin it was for development and
initiated but also for some direct
threats with what he's just done he's
basically pinned that Knight on D7 over
the last moves sacrificing a pawn and
now C5 is a massive threat that is
a really cool idea and a very cool way
to handle the position just gives up
upon because he says that extra C4 Pawn
was actually Black's friend and he just
gets it out of the way
ah this is cool like I'm learning a lot
from this game and he says you can check
me but maybe even just King F1 you can
just block it with Bishop B2 so that
just wastes time for black and a moment
ago after Bishop B5 check Bishop D7
looks more natural a way to defend but
after Bishop takes C5 Queen C5 Bishop D7
check you're not gonna be very happy
with your king stuck in the center and
White's King will castle and this is
just devastating so there's no way you
could block with the bishop and that's
why I hit a block with the Knight but
he's wasting time very precious time I
loved I'm gonna study this game I'm
actually gonna make a note to myself
right now so you take it away Tanya
while I write to myself look at this
game
very direct stuff I mean just two moves
ago there were two pawns on the C file
to give it away and then the C3 Pawn
goes to C4 be sweetie saying that I want
more and now a plaque's position uh he's
in trouble I see the valbar says that
Levon should be fine but look at this
Levon can feel the heat it's the first
time in the Swiss Plains and he's the
one who's behind on the clock he moves
the queen to F6 still behind in
development white with full control on
the center but it's all about time white
has sacrificed upon he's got to keep the
initiative the energy going and where
does Peter bring that in now does he
continue the advance with C5
really tempting I'm wondering if black
is some kind of E4 at the right moment
it takes a lot of time to figure all
this out there's also C6 potentially to
try and block this bishop and uh the
queen on D6 was under attack so if C6
and played before there would have been
a queen trade and C6 would have dropped
so Peter could I mean so many options C5
looks good Queen A4 just trying to
increase the Firepower on the queen side
looks pretty good castling King side I
don't think we're gonna complain about
getting our King out of the center and
opening up the e-file for a rook kind of
too many choices for me which of these
moves do you think Peter will play
oh tough call you know I think if it's
one of those Blitzer bullet games you go
C5 without thinking but there are a lot
of tempting options you mentioned Queen
A4 I really like it as well it does
build up the pressure on D7 but I think
we're gonna see C5 on the board I think
it's direct it does take more control of
the center
really go C5 will you go shark Castle
let's do one thing uh Robert let's leave
Peter to tell us what he decides let's
use this moment to jump into some of the
other games as we've got more players on
100 score and we will of course jump
straight back into this one as this
heats up I just want to point out that
Sam 7 and Wesley so just drew their game
against each other so they moved to
three and a half out of four some early
draws it would seem in this round I see
Alexi drev and Yvonne sarich abhimanyu
Mitra made a draw against Maxine
matlikov so some quick results near the
top but I don't think they can keep
drawing their way at least they won't be
able to play for division one let's go
to the game between somebody who has
been in division one Ralph momentov and
someone else was taken part in the top
division in Liam lay and well it looks
like it's all the way up for moment of
at the moment
but it looks like Black's King is in a
big big trouble who cares about Pawns in
this position but right now the A7 Pawn
is off the board luckily for black the
A8 square is defended and I see our eval
bar it seems to say that black is
completely lost even though it's Liam's
move here
it's as though anything he plays he's in
trouble but my first question is what
actually happens Robert if black picks
up the C3 Pawn because I see a rook on
d8 I'm that Queen on D1
what does Ralph have in mind for dtec C3
one of the things that people can forget
at times and I'm not talking
specifically to you chat but I am
talking to you is that when you lose
pawns you open files so if we just go
back a turn and Tanya was kind of
leading me to this point that her D
takes C3 let's see oh I'm gonna keep
taking all your pawns I'm up material
what you've really just done is open up
the C file so I can just take here and
play Rook C1 or Rook A1 I can play
Bishop E3 I don't even have to care
about that pawn and go after your queen
I'm take this Pawn on B2 with my queen
to play Rook C1 next so you're just
opening too much of the area in front of
your own King while the white king is
happily situated behind the fort of
Pawns the moat in front of it so instead
we saw E5 played and Ralph says why
don't I open up this position maybe
there's Bishop F4 if I get a rook to C1
the game will be over
that's a great concept that you pointed
out Robert that when you're going for
your opponent's king when you're going
for attacks you're looking for ways to
open up files and diagonal sphere pieces
even if it comes at the cost of material
and of course black had no time to get
greedy with that Rook on h8 the bishop
on f8 the King open could not have gone
for those extra pawns so tries to keep
the center closed but there's only so
much that he can keep close and under
control the C file is open takes on D4
white is eyeing ideas of bringing out
the bishop but I'm just wondering
can black also start threatening to
trade off with Bishop f for Bishop D6
and that's why perhaps he chooses a more
sober approach with Bishop D2 also
threatening B4 at some point
destabilizing the queen on C5 and
opening up his own Queen's route to B3
I love what you just said there though
because I think my impulse in addition
to many people who would look at this
position Bishop F4 was the active
diagonal but sometimes that allows more
trades and when you're the attacking
side you don't want to trade pieces
White's not going to trade Queens here
unless you get some kind of material
Edge for it so really instructed Bishop
D2 well spotted by you Tanya Here Comes
Rook C1 as an option and this queen also
is like in a bit of trouble doesn't have
too many squares whether we're coming to
C1 and we're coming to A5 has just been
played the queen has to take a step back
on the c-line and white is gaining
precious time
well he steps up with the queen so
trying to create some chaos goes Queen
to C2 I don't think white really cares
about the B3 Pawn you could start
considering Rook C1 you could also
defend the B Pawn with the move Rook B5
I love it because I say it defends to be
Pawn but what it actually does is attack
the B6 Knight if the Knight falls back
suddenly the queen from A1 can jump to
A6 all the way down the board using the
pin and targeting the B7 Pawn there's no
way that black can allow that falls back
with the bishop and now your move Rook
C1 is begging to be played sacrifices on
C7 I think it's time Rook C7 Bishop F4
but King C6 the kind of on B5 is hanging
as well maybe it's not time just yet oh
it looks like time if that doesn't work
I don't want to play chess anymore it
looks so promising uh because of all the
discoveries so I'm I like that uh
actually Rook takes B6 might just be a
free piece based on what you're saying
because of Bishop F4 so your your idea
just in a different move order and it
looks like Rook B6 just steals a free
piece
that's much stronger Robert I love it
rugby did he go for Rook C7 instead yeah
because it's winning and it looks cooler
while the bar approves Robert approves
so we've got nothing to fight that Rook
C7 the point is King C7 Bishop F4 King
C6 walks into a fork on E5 Knight E5 the
Knight joins the party and that's game
over and Robert as you're pointing out
if black goes for the other Rook on B5
Bishop F4 with a million discover checks
and that's game over as well
okay so he just goes Rook C5 because the
King has to go the a file and he wins
the queen so it'll be up a queen
and a bishop for two Rooks too much
material too big of an attack that is a
nice game from Ralph mahmetov and he
would love just like he did the air
things Masters to make his way to the
top division
yes uh Robert this one looks like Ralph
is taking it I think we've gotta head
back to P sweetie's game against uh
Lavon aronian because there's Madness
happening there as well take a look at
this where did the g-pawn go what is
happening the Bishops have been traded
off do you want to do a quick action
replay to even see how we got here
because this is madness
you asked me what happened and I'm
looking at this board are we looking at
the same game like is this the game that
we were looking at before because
suddenly White's missing all of the
promising pieces that look good so we
left here just to quickly run through
this
black move the queen castled great C5
and this move C6 was really nice for
black and E4 to follow kicking this
Knight trying to get the D5 pawn and
this is where it got really hectic
Bishop came to D4 which apparently was
not correct and then e takes F3 because
the bishop is in the Queen's path
otherwise you'd be able to take on D7
successfully and that's why it didn't
work out where I take on G2 The Rook was
under attack and we see the trades and
Tanya I mean
had a good start can you have a decent
finish to this game can he somehow hold
this position he is only down one Pawn
on one Pawn but all of
all are liberated from each other and it
just
across the board the H5 bond that was
such a such a strong point in the
opening and the middle game is now a
glaring weakness in White's positions
and uh Robert a big question does black
want to trade or take advantage of
White's open King right now the trades
are still on offer but if white does
accept it the H5 Pawn immediately Falls
otherwise Queen G5 always in the air I
think for Peter to hold this against
level and it's going to take a lot
but just great demonstration of
restraint from Lavon because so many
people would say my coach taught me when
I'm up material I trade pieces and that
often is true when you're up you trade
but A2 is loose H5 is a problem this
King wants to be off the G file because
if a couple moves ago or even now you
take there's suddenly all this pressure
down on G7 and on H6 so I really like
what Lavon is doing he's making
improving moves because if the queen
trade happens on D5 that's best case
scenario for black
yeah and both players playing with
tension here keeping the tension alive
uh
we see Peter sweet love with his last
move Rook C7 is the F7 Pawn the A7 pawn
and it might be time now for black to
take a decision but Levon doesn't want
it he's still it's it's just insane to
see how they're just keeping the tension
from both sides not trading the Queens I
do feel that he can pick up the A2 Pawn
at some point and it might be now Queen
A2 why not just get greedy with it
because maybe he's worried I thought a
move ago he could have done it but now
if you take this Rook A1 takes A5 and I
think we should talk about bigger
picture where we know this but maybe
some in the audience know that if these
pawns are gone that actually helps
White's defensive tasks because instead
of having your
um Focus split across the board when
you're down upon your pawns are split as
you mentioned that if these pawns are
gone now you just have to worry about
defending this Pawn so you can even take
a passive defense with a rook on H1 so I
like what has happened here where Lavon
brought the Rook up to B5 to take on H5
and
um that Bishop is defended for now I
thought it was a free piece but I forgot
the Rook defends it
yeah and easy to miss that kind of stuff
in these positions there are tactics
everywhere loose pieces drop off can he
take on F4 Bishop D6 lose bases drop off
and
off you were just saying it and it
happened so you called it that's called
prophecy I had a commentator's curse you
were just noting and that's game over
it's another win for Lavon aronian
wow Levon moves on to four out of four
and a nice display there by him with the
black pieces again keeping the clock
under control in a tensed opening
finding those defensive resources let's
take a look at the other action uh
that's on right now a lot of results are
coming in but a lot of players who are
still on 100 scorers still playing
Robert where do you want to jump to well
I saw that para maksudu was playing as
Jeffrey Zhang and I'm thinking what is
this like the 2020 Junior speeches
Championship because uh these two even
though at this point it seems like
they're veterans they're still quite
young and they're very talented players
so what's happening in this position
white has a pair of Bishops but look at
this really nice blockade and all these
dark Square pieces for black seem to be
holding everything together
yeah I think it's one of those positions
where White's D5 bond is actually
Black's best friend right now what white
really wants is that D5 Pawn off the
board and open up that bishop and C4 and
then we'd be praising the double bishop
and all the attacks that can be set up
along the diagonal that you're
mentioning but as long as that D5 Pawn
remains it's a weakness but one that
black never really wants to recapture
but just keep on forever make sure D6
doesn't come in the bishop and C4
remains blocked so the bishop pair yes
it's there but it's only for the name of
it it's really not doing anything
meanwhile White's King also slightly
unsafe I think for Jeffrey with the
black pieces it shouldn't be that hard
to hold the queen can be centralized to
E5 now also targeting to come in with
the queen 2h2 everything nicely defended
I think it's looking pretty even
yeah I think black can pass forever and
White's not making progress uh I think
one thing that I just want to point out
is that both players oh wow Knight 88 is
that night coming to B6 where does this
Knight go that's the big question but
what does it say quickly is white with
love a Pawn on A4 to open up the bishop
and outside pass Pawn but black also has
a two-on-one majority that's completely
stopped by uh the light Square Bishop so
there's no progress at least immediately
for black but suddenly Knight B6 and
white has some things to think about
where is this Knight going it's going to
take the bishop is it going to keep
running around somewhere a G5 Knight G6
this side of the board that's the
problem when you're facing a knight it's
a very jumpy piece and I am not sure
what the future holds for it
I love that plan that you're pointing
out it takes a couple of moves but once
the Knight gets to those dark squares
like F4 and H4 it could be big trouble
for white and I think sensing sensing
that Parham decides to offer a queen
trade and I'm just wondering will a
Jeffrey trade and go Knight B6 but he
doesn't he's playing for more he comes
in with the queen it's kind of
interesting to see how Black's Knight is
one end of the universe and the queen is
the other end this can get tricky for
black as well wow and queen E6 giving up
a pawn with check but this bishop on D6
is loose and as you point out the Knight
over in the corner it's a loose piece
and loose pieces drop off so Queen takes
H3 check is available I'm not sure you
really want to go for that you can
actually just bring the Knight back to
C7 don't forget the queen does defend
this bishop on D6 there's that long
range connection there but the queen
could sneak into D7 as well so this is
anybody's game
this is anybody's game there are threats
all over and now black has to spend
another move defending D6 he picks up
the pawn and he says that he doesn't see
a direct way the G6 Pawn can be targeted
Queen E4 runs into Queen E5 so there's
always the option for black to actually
trade the queens and end up with an
extra Pawn in the position even end
games with the two Bishops I do think
that white should be able to hold that
is I'm wondering if there's like a draw
over here can I have because a queen G8
check afterwards
but maybe I this King can try to escape
like I'm trying to invite the king
forward check it but King H6 the king
may try to run at some moment and that's
what I'm a little bit nervous about but
okay because the F6 spawn will fall with
check as well
now
Parham does Bishop G6 work he goes for
another aggressive try starts with the
move G5 I'm expecting Queen E5 a trade
of queens and white will recapture black
will have to recapture with the pawn
wow and that end game black has an extra
Pawn but white has a nice hold in the
position after Bishop E4
it's one of those positions where black
is up a pawn but could lose more easily
than white because the white king is
very active the bishop seems very
promising on D3 I don't think that black
will lose that game I'm just noting that
if you play for a win that's how you
sometimes lose those types of positions
but I think Queen E5 is the best choice
I think he'll play it and I'm looking
the clock I haven't noticed it just
until now white is under a minute
remaining so I think that Jeffrey is
trying to pounce he's trying to get this
Victory he wants to keep going up the
scoreboard
and I think uh for Jeffrey he's trying
to think of ways exactly to keep his
Ambitions alive maybe give a check on H5
maybe fall back with the queen to F4
there are options other than Queen E5
Queen E5 is simply a bailout a joffer
and he goes for it I don't see this end
game giving a lot to black white can
pick up the C5 Pawn after trading on F6
with a check black wins the D5 Pawn
white attacks the Knight on D5
picks up the B4 pawn and I think this
will end in a draw Bishop C5 Knight D5
Bishop C4 it has it looks like they
agreed to a draw I'm okay with you know
I don't like draw first here I'm more or
less okay with it because it was a easy
simplification but yeah this is a well
fought game by these two they earn the
split point and I'm there's a name that
I haven't looked at in a while by the
way gotta komsky gotta win so he is up
to three and a half points that's an FFL
for those of you who are at home
watching the legendary comps key what's
going on in this game isn't that
Black's move
so it's it's good news that it's
Blackstone because white is threatening
to promote so you've got to either give
a check first throw in a check and then
pick up that power on it A7 which I
think could be the way to go because
Robert if you immediately pick up the
part on A7 white gives a check and picks
up the pawn on H3
oh we're seeing a narrow H3 what
what that this is an easily winning King
opponent game right
but how do you
how's it winning
okay three two three two yeah King E4
and King E3 you have to go king of one
because kingy two is a threat and go
King F3 yes
what just happened you're saying that
rookie 3 is just lost for white yeah
this was surprising me Bogan Dental days
did not have much time so that's
probably what caused it but just to show
an instant replay here the king had to
step backwards this King needed to go
the first Rank and this would be a draw
if the Rook stays in the third rank over
here I believe uh not necessarily the
easiest draw but one nonetheless instead
he goes up and he immediately loses
because after this trade whites moves
her fourth they're King E3 if you push
your Pawn Here Comes King E2 check push
push thank you for the queen I get there
first and in the game instead we saw the
king go back but when the black king
steps here if you go this way the black
king goes in and it's all about pushing
the pawn and that's exactly what
happened is white tried to push this one
and then you're gonna lose a pawn no
matter what but this would be a draw the
white king would step up instead the
black king step forward and that's win
around exoduani wow that was insane all
he had to do was step back with the King
and avoid The Rook trade for a moment I
thought that Rook H3 happened with Rook
A3 check and it was just a complete
chaos and with seconds on the clock
white did bungle that one up and this
ends but we've still got action on on
the other boards Robert very instructive
stuff in that end game and our buddy
pranav Ananda with the black pieces up
in exchange with that a pawn is brutal
if black moves The Rook to E3 attacking
with the idea of going rookie one check
white can simply pick up the pawn on G2
and the pawn on A7 is Unstoppable and it
looks like pranavanan is going down in
this one just four seconds on the clock
yeah and a equals Queen also defends the
bishop in case you thought there's any
checking business so it's a win for Jose
Martinez Jocelyn gets the w
few more games still going on it looks
like
oh
yeah a lot of time travel vugar against
you Yankee and this is madness on the
board what is happening black has two
extra pawns the Knight on C2 is pinned
and is going to be picked up and it's a
rook Pawn ending with all the Rook comes
to F2 hits the pawn on F3
If you defend the F3 Pawn C Pawn
advances to C2 I think this is a winning
group Pawn ending for Black
looks pretty straightforward too because
uh the black king is where it needs to
be active and all these pawns are going
forward so this looks actually pretty
straightforward
oh nice move there not only defending
the C3 Pawn but also hitting the G3 Pawn
can simply pick it up and after a check
on H1 You've Got King coming back to G7
and you're about a million bonds up
should be game over and in fact it is
game over as avugar resigns in this
position oh no he's still fighting this
out
are the clocks Frozen the game is gone
I'm not sure no no the game is I was
like oh I'm surprised what's happening
here but it looks like no this one is
officially done oh my gosh there's a a
game going on look at this one this
could last three days
it's a game
we're in this together yeah Benjamin
Bach and uh paklesa
yeah there's a
we'll see if we can bring that one up
we'll try and bring that one up
meanwhile this is over with you Yankee
taking the point on this one I've also
took results and draw but only three
players with a hundred percent score
will move on to around five and it is
a player we haven't had a chance to look
at yet but we'll definitely be focusing
on to round five in round five and love
on our onion
Ralph with four points a hundred percent
score Robert what are your thoughts
going into the second half of the Swiss
yeah there's some players we haven't
even checked in on yet That's How Strong
this tournament is Magnus Carlson we
haven't mentioned his name in a while
not among the leaders but Lavon of
ronian he continues to impress me so
much in these rapid time controls I
think they really suit his style the way
he plays I mean creatively but also
quickly and accurately I think it's
really perfect for him so I'll I would
like to see if he can keep up the pace
but time does so many strong players in
the field
fantastic
and we've got five more grounds coming
up in the Swiss we will be back with
more playing chess action after this
break
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
shout out to meet up we are over 20 000
members and a growing strong head over
to meetup.com just to find a local group
to grow your own community and Robert
while we were on a break I was having a
look at the chat and I have to say that
you me and Chad today are our own
Community because they were updating me
with a lot of fun stuff currently Anish
giri going into round five is at one and
a half out of four Magnus Carlson has
won three games a lost one game is in
position 35 there's Madness all around
let's jump straight into the round five
action
as soon as we start looking at chess
there is a mistake from Ralph Mama this
is one of those Sicilian lines it's been
played for so many years honestly Tanya
you know I don't like these positions
for black I know some people swear by
these lines but I look at the structure
isolated pawns on the queen side I look
at the king side this King on G8 looks
pretty vulnerable and the white king at
least for now is sitting very happily on
C1 so I don't know do you have
experience in these lines at all and do
you share my opinion or maybe you
completely disagree
I have to say I'm really glad that with
the black pieces I don't have experience
in this line because it looks so
dangerous what we're seeing with the G
Line open and a potential a rook slide
onto G1 maybe the Knight jumps to D6 but
these lines you have to calculate I was
super attracted to the move Knight D6
until I realized Robert that if black
slides in with the Rook to d8 you have
to be sure that that Knight on D6 does
something because it's kind of trapped
there it looks like a monster but it
might end up being a body there that
falls down after Rook D6 Rook d8 Rook D6
yeah he says Tanya you've got some great
ideas up your sleeve and the reason why
is the black king is Just In Harm's Way
if we go over T8 just to show the
sequence that may happen and I play Rook
G1 and you take this Knight on D6 and I
take and you take another queen takes H6
you have a problem on the G file and a
loose Bishop on E6 so you can defend on
G7 but then when I take here and your
queen takes down go E6 down goes C6 down
goes D5 you're losing all your pieces I
mean all of them are hanging
yeah that's a lot of downtime for black
in this position so Rook d8 doesn't work
Knight D6 indeed not a pony but quite a
monster on D6 there a dragon right now
asking a big question where do you slide
with the Rook Rook G1 coming in Queen at
six I think the defense resource after
Rook G1 for black will be to sidestep
with the King come up the board to eight
seven step away from the pin and also
got the 8-6 pawn but I completely agree
with you that Ralph mamadov is uh facing
a lot of heat in this position Robert
should we take this moment to zoom out
and jump into some of the other openings
that we're seeing let's do it because we
might come back and I think it could be
a swift victory for Lavon aronian why
don't we go to the game between Wesley
so he's playing taking on Amin type of
Dubai and we haven't checked out amines
games today but I look at this one and
I'm a little bit surprised that Wesley
is not white this feels like the most
Wesley so position ever if he had the
white pieces
I know exactly what you mean but I think
even
black
lean these kind of end games he's just
so strong and it's hard to imagine the
penetration here with white uh the good
news for white is that black spawn
structure is hideous that black bishop
and C8 will take time to come into the
game but what are the trumps that Wesley
has complete control of the d-line where
he will be looking to create counter
play I I think amen he's got time he
can't jump in with that Knight to E5 to
A5 start putting pressure that's
something that Wesley needs to think
about while he makes a decision of where
he wants to develop with the bishop but
Robert I think this one will end in a
draw I mean it's Wesley so that guy you
just can't beat him
I don't like his position at all but I
do like the player who has the position
you're absolutely you know spot on that
Wesley defends positions like these all
the time where most players be like Oh
I'm gonna lose he's just like yeah
whatever I'm slightly worse but I'll be
accurate so one piece of good news for
black is if this knight ever leaves C4 a
rook can come down to D2 and start
pestering White's Pawn so look at how I
mean is playing this F3 King F2 he's
slow playing this and I like it
yeah you're right if anyone can push
yeah it's got to be white you just
compare that Knight to the bishop to
pawn structure and you know that this is
going to be a long long crime and
because we know it's going to be a long
grind rabbit I think it's time to head
to some more exciting Waters as I'm
seeing some uh fascinating opening and
middle game outcomes all around and you
mentioned a famous fun Legend karakamski
he's got a famous fun position going on
with ronix spawn down the board on G5
okay I mean product said one he knows a
thing or two about beating Legends of
the game because he just played a match
and defeated Nigel short quite handily
in fact it was a mix of classical rapid
and Blitz time patrols this is only
rapid no classical for you sorry gotta I
know sometimes you wish the time
controls were a bit longer but here with
the black pieces what do we like about
Black's position I think it's a stable
uh type of Sicilian where you have the
E6 and D6 pawns taking away key squares
from White's pieces and my big question
is this Pawn on G5 is white really even
want it there because if you take with
the bishop and you gave up G5 you open
up the G file
hmm
and that's a question that can be very
relevant now that black has decided to
trade on D4 does he pick up with the
bishop sacrificing the g-pawn or simply
recapture with the Rook keeping the
material balanced and also eyeing
doubling up on the D file he does decide
ronak decides to keep the pawn on G5
alive takes it with the Rope The Rook
from H1 can slide into D1 the D6 Pawn is
a long-term weakness and right now for
garakamski it's not easy to decide to go
castling on the king side with the H
Pawn marching down the board things
could start getting tricky for the
blacking very quickly
yeah no this could be tricky for both
sides because uh the black king still in
the center the white king is about to
face a bunch of pieces staring down
towards it so
um this is a situation where akomsky you
need to be careful about his clock
management because he's down nearly a
minute Tanya and that's what would worry
me for him
yeah and things are just starting to
heat up and the players have got about
half the amount of time on the clock and
this position with so with pretty much
all the pawns on the board
probably potentially an opposite side
gasoline both players going for each
other's King this is going to heat up in
just a few moves Robert should we just
use this time to zoom out and take a
look at some of the other games is there
something that catches your attention
okay let's look at the game between
Magnus Carlson man he might be a little
bit famous and taking on the youngest
Grand Master in chess history in ABI
Manu Mishra and uh if I look at the eval
bar it tells me that white is slightly
better but I look at the position and I
note that black has a pair of Bishops
and I think that tends to give some good
long-term chances especially because
Tanya it's a fiend Kettle structure but
there is no Bishop on G2 so you have to
be very very careful here
yeah we're going to try to bring that
game up so we can show all these points
that you're mentioning uh Robert and
indeed a Magnus Carlson playing the
youngest Grand Master in the history of
Chess ABI Manya Mishra
it is a tough intense fight
and we see that Magnus playing with the
with the glasses on in his bedroom
what's going on with that map what's
going on with that Robert hey look it
looks like a sunny day behind him uh he
just wants to focus on the chest and
because the players are on Zoom calls
maybe Magnus is like I don't want
players to be reading my expression so
uh in a matter of the late night there's
also that possibility yeah I like the I
like this pillow behind him you look all
the way towards the back wall that's a
good pillow oh
and a very messy room I have to say but
we're all used to seeing that in a
magnus's stream you mentioned it's a
sunny day it could be that but I think
there are bigger chances of this hiding
signs of perhaps uh a late night outing
there with Magnus Carlsen currently on
three out of four he is playing
abhimanyu Mishra and we see the bishop
pair that you were talking about he has
traded that off for the night on C3 but
that means one of the key Defenders for
the D5 Pawn is gone so white has to
perhaps throw in the move D6 hitting
that Queen before he picks up the bishop
on C3 yeah D6 allows Queen F6 and the
queen takes Pawn on C3 I've heard that
Knight on C4 is about to be kicked out
of there which means D6 will likely Fall
in the near future I I don't like the
way this is going for Mishra he's down
four minutes on the clock suddenly it
went from a position where he's up a
pawn with uh those Knights against the
Bishops so one where I think material be
even but white just doesn't have the
stability that you would prefer and if
this bishop does get to C6 Tanya and the
it goes back to A8 and the queen goes to
B7 at some moment there could be
Devastation down the diagonal
yeah when you've got a light squared
Bishop as black does in this position
and for abhimanya Mishra the G2 Bishop
is missing from the board you've always
got to eye threats along this diagonal
but he does slow down right now Magnus
he's definitely thinking about your move
Queen F6 and perhaps
I'm not sure what which other move
catches his attention because Queen F6
picking up the C3 Pawn is just so
tempting but Matt is there on the screen
completely focused I wish I could say
that with complete Assurance but I can't
really see his eyes so I'm not really
sure what he's thinking or where he's
looking at right now I think he is just
trying to figure out how to properly
take this game but I mean Magnus he did
lose a lot for cine he has three out of
four going to four to five would be big
for his chances and part of this comes
down to the tie break Tanya we've seen
this in uh previous tournaments previous
plans where there's a big tie and some
people get left out so you actually do
want to score early victories to help
your tie breaks down the line
yeah it's a very important factor as you
mentioned that we've seen players at the
same point being left behind and not
being able to make it into the mix
because of a poor tie break resulting
from early losses and it's important for
Magnus with a second round defeat to
make up for all of that wow this is a
long thing by him but he's still up on
the clock with almost double the amount
of time Robert I'm just trying to think
what is the alternative what do you
think he's thinking about apart from
Queen F6 the move Queen B7 comes to mind
to try to activate that Queen let's say
the idea that you mentioned if you take
on C3 Queen E4 Bishop C6 lining up that
Queen is that what he's uh going to go
for
Queen goes to B7 A6 so you called it and
he might want to line the bishop up on
B5 Barrel through the Knight to the pawn
on E2 so D6 is loose E2 is loose A3 is
hanging I just feel like this is the
position and it's not just because
Magnus is playing I think that this
really is a position where it feels like
white is falling apart of the seams
everything is kind of loose black has
this bishop that's going to be powerful
uh down the line and white has no time
so I really fear for abhimanyu Mishra
here but it's good experience for him to
play against the former world champion
is Magnus really sangria like what was
that
yeah he's he's having a lot of fun he's
definitely in party mode right now as we
can see and his position looks like a
lot of fun now Queen A6 uh what are
magnus's biggest trend
at least from whatever games that we've
studied of his or at least I've looked
at it feels like his activity with the
queen he just knows where to place it
now Queen to E4 was the idea that came
to my mind centralized the queen between
A6 is such a nice Square it hits that
Knight on C4 hits that A3 Pawn picks up
that Rook on the pawn on D6 a strong
point and with that uh all the
weaknesses for white hair the A3 Pawn is
about to fall an extra Pawn for Magnus
and this one looks like it's going to be
a tough task what abhimanyu really wants
is get that Rook to B1 get that Rook to
B8 and try and create some counter play
so Magnus takes its low first pushing
out that knight from E5 because of your
point that Rook coming to B8 was
worrisome for him or even a B7 just get
out of here where's the Knight going you
go back to D3 but the Knight will lose
its Square I mean this bishop can come
to G6 for example the pawn to come to C4
I feel like hobby money is being kicked
around here Tanya and something is going
to fall Knight G6 I could consider
taking it and then taking on E2 at the
end because I won't get back ranked
checkmated I will have enough counter
play as black so I think Magnus is
successfully going to go up a pawn
yes it's just going to be
going to be Bon he ends up
with that abhimanyu decides he goes with
that Knight to F3 two very tempting
options for Magnus pick up the A3 Pawn
immediately or start lining up pressure
against the other weakness the E-2 Pawn
uh with the move Bishop B5 activating
the bishop but first he goes for Queen
A3 and I think white has got to play
Rook B1 here you have to try to find
your own counter play and now look at
this just again clinical stuff here by
Magnus offering a queen trade your upper
Pawn you want an end game take away all
the counter player from your opponent
and very important is that the queen or
a bishop on A4 protects the D1 Square
because you may think oh Rook A1 here
but Rook D1 check would trade off the
Rooks and then the a pawn will run up
the board and that's gonna be a losing
end game for white so it goes Rook to ba
check the king will escape I would go to
H7 just avoid any sort of checks over
here even though Rook D7 is still
available and that's the power of a
bishop is it just defends all across the
board keeps everything defended and
Rook here and Bishop C6 comes to mind
oh nice idea and then you can always
move your rook and start advancing down
the pawn with the a pawn down the board
but I also like to move Rook D7 and you
keep your Bishop coming to B5 you can
take it slow look at the way notice how
the White Knight has been cut off from
the queen side the default Square isn't
there the D2 Square isn't there it's got
a long way to go before it can join the
defense on to on over to the other side
of the board gives the check falls back
with the king the bishop will come and
Target the E2 pawn bishop B5 now comes
to mind he fast spins The Rook the
Knight and now Bishop B5 Rook D2 coming
in and another Pawn is about to fall
just a one-sided game at this point from
Magnus and when Magnus is you know in
his best shape playing his best chess
this is what happens and he puts C4 that
is Extreme whoa why would he do that
to defend the pawn but that looks super
committal he could have easily gone for
the E2 Bond but instead blocks the
bishop but he's he knows what he's doing
this is Magnus Carlsen this is an end
game the Magnus touch he knows the C3
Pawn was going to fall he does it he's
up to pawns are playing on 10 seconds
down in the end game can't pick up the
E6 Pawn rookie 2 is a big threat on the
board picking up that Knight tries to
bring the king into the game
but this is just over G7 you can win it
nobody cares about that the C Pawn will
decide the game Bishop A4 check oh
Bishop A4 check loses The Rook so that's
a bad idea pick up the pawn on H2 or
give a check on C2 yeah go C2 if you
take it we swap everything off and
that's a winning ending with Bishop E2
at the end winning F3 and the Knights
trapped over here so that's another
issue to add to the many uh but I didn't
actually look at the clock for a while
and my money's down to his final seconds
which is why Magnus was playing quickly
and probably mind you if he had a
defense he wasn't going to find it so
Magnus Carlsen moves the four to five
wow and that was a nice win with the
black pieces picking up all of white
spawns uh he moves to Four Points as you
mentioned let's go back to the other
games as action is on all around and
Robert what catches your attention we're
getting in results we're getting in
fiery positions and a lot of fun which
board do you want to jump to well I
pulled up the game between I'm in Tampa
Dubai and Wesley so just because I want
to show that Wesley it looks like his
technique is fantastic as per usual he's
worse he's the one defending but what's
happened is he's cemented White's Pawns
in place so even if he loses A6 he'll
get counter play against the H2 Pawn or
against the E3 and E4 pawns so Wesley's
gonna make a draw I think we could head
on elsewhere levonne Rowan did in fact
win his game he's a perfect five out of
5.
wow yes and this is what we're talking
about right Wesley just so difficult one
of the most difficult players on the
circuit to beat he just keeps everything
so solid uh let's head back to this game
and I see a lot of development here
garakamski has an extra exchange I'm
trying to do the math here Robert he's
an exchange up but the eval bar still
says white is fine because again doing
the math you see that white has got six
pawns materially it's quite balanced uh
bishop and two pawns for a rook and
white pieces are quite active Mobility
we see the black Bishop being tied down
with that pawn on e4 but it's still
anyone's game regardless of what the
eval Bar says okay so oh Rook takes D1
if Queen takes Queen takes G3 look at
how quickly gotta play the double x
square move because of Knight D1 this
bishop takes E4 and this Knight gets to
D4 and it's the white king that's in
some danger over here
yeah big danger after that because the
Knight is jumping in the C2 Pawn is
super tender this is such a great
awareness by Agata kamski here
immediately blitzing out the move and
now the players are down to under a
minute on the clock ronak savani with 25
seconds it's all coming in Robert you
pointed it out great call Bishop C2 is a
threat you can't go Queen to D2 stopping
Knight D Focus the bishop on G3 hangs
only move Knight jumps in you called all
of the night is coming to F3 the C2 Pawn
is hanging the queen has to go to F2 to
try and keep everything under control
and then you could still take on C2 if
you want because once the queen takes
back at the end G3 Bishop is loose maybe
there's a improving move here forgotta
to work with first but I have to say
that Rook takes D1 shot came out of
nowhere from from me I wasn't looking at
that he was A5 he just wants the attack
he's just putting the pressure on
because it's so difficult for white to
make moves in this position with
everything tied down and especially when
you have to do it in just 10 seconds on
the clock Radix advani desperately
trying to get the pieces off the board
and he does it and Robert that is great
defensive technique in an opposite color
Bishop position that's exactly what he
needed to do queen G3 is always in the
air offering a queen trade and the pawn
on G7 watch out for that pawn on C2 but
anytime the Queens get traded off this
will end in a draw he first forces black
to fix the pawn structure on the queen
side he can even give up the C2 Pawn at
some moment now and it will still be a
draw yeah if you want Queen now as I say
if the Queen's come off the board Queen
Jordan was like an excellent call
because it forces the Queens off so Tony
I'm with you give up C2 trade the queens
that makes your life as easy as possible
wow and the Bears are still playing on
second
but to be traded the only the only
problem in White's position is that the
king is super far away from the King
side so I think that's what probably uh
ronak is a little worried about not
going for the queen trade he finally
decides to do it and this is essentially
a draw for the bishop will come to C3
okay he defends it from E1 and now the
king comes up the board
C3 King B4 and eventually the white
Bishop will sacrifice itself for the H
Pawn yeah and you can play B3 at some
moment because once these pawns are gone
you just give up your Bishop for this
Pawn so King C4 Bishop C2 that gets a
little tricky that's why he plays B3
making sure that all pawns are gone and
now it's a four-stroke Well Done by
roundock
yeah nicely defunded precise player
there and of course the players are just
making moves right now the pawn will be
given up and that is it this one ends in
a draw quite an exciting fight that was
and a really nice save in a tricky
position byronix advani rabbit more
action is on
yes still games Go including Wesley so
against amitab to buy and this looks
like it should be a drop but barely
barely barely at this point we're on F5
white wins the game the king needs to
stay on G7 and H7 and this King wants to
go up to B7 A7 but unfortunately this
Pawn will be used as a decoy so nice
hold here by Wesley so
and that's a fantastic point that you
make Robert that this Pawn on F5 would
change the game completely because it
would force the black king onto the f
file with its own advance but with none
of that possible even if black did not
have the F4 Pawn actually this position
in many uh in many cases is still a draw
it becomes trickier because you have to
be precise with the defense but
theoretically even that's a draw with
the side defense but we see right now
that's not required at all and even
though Amin tabatabai has an extra pawn
it is easily holdable with the f-bond
not allowing white skin to match up the
board F3 um
and the King has to come back you can
play F2 the King goes back and then Rook
A2 the King has some F1 and then white
is frozen so black just goes back and
forth
if I would have stepped up with the King
you might have
might have just got to come back to the
defense blackface King it's six King
goes back to G7 and yes don't pick up
that pawn on H5 Robert yeah after the
game I will show that because that is
one of those tricks that people miss all
the time oh it's a free Pawn I'm making
progress and you take it and you regret
it this is why the king needs to be here
if the king ever steps up rook AJ check
allows white to Queen so that's why
Wesley knows this is a draw like you
said you know even without the F Pawn
yeah and uh we're gonna see that being
played out it's easier now that white
spawn is on A7 and the white King has
got nowhere to hide anymore the king
can't go over to A7 and really
interestingly there's another game
that's on velocity and Andre versus
Daniel diach and that is the exact same
Rook Pawn ending Robert with white
having a cheap on in this position so
really instructive stuff that is I'm
hovering it over to my screen it is the
same ending with genes of H1 and still a
draw so that is a crazy coincidence the
timing of all this uh but the one thing
is as soon as the king gets the B file
check it away from there because the
king protects the pawn so he tries a
little sneaky thing take the pawn A7 and
force everything off
you gotta check it like it's
like it's one ends in a draw
ing endings actually even with two extra
pawns there is no way to improve them
and this is the position in the other
game the exact same end game that we saw
but upon on the G file yeah good call by
you good you know good job scouting out
the other games it's a same draw because
you need to get the king to B7 to free
up your Rook but as soon as the King
goes that way you check it away so
there's no way to make progress and just
one last thing to note this is what I
was talking about don't take this Pawn
don't be fooled because it's not free
rook G8 check frees up the pawn to push
to A8 and then when all is said and done
you're up a full Rook as white and you
win the game so don't go taking the
pawns you need to stay on these G7 H7
squares
just amazing stuff and the players
showing incredible defense Robert this
one ends in a draw as well and uh
exactly the point that you made with the
King stepping up on G6 is the problem
that if instead of the H and the g Pawn
white has a bond on F5 and Chad if you
visualize that once the F5 Pawn advances
to the F6 Square there is no way for
black to actually avoid it the king's
stopping stepping on to F7 would mean
maybe with arrows we can show it Robert
seven ideas and that's how you win this
end game and with this draw I think that
is the end of round five Robert I think
we've got all the results in
yeah I think so and that means we're
starting the next route
we're starting the next round with just
one player on 100 score it is Levon
aronian in Pole Position going into
round six at five out of five he's on
fire and Robert the best part in levon's
play today has been how quickly he's
been playing just keeping it up on the
clock and the pressure on the board yeah
in the meantime to buy he's looking at
this game as one where he does not want
to see Levon that we keep seeing round
after round I think that Amin would be
happy with a draw LeBron's a higher
rated player uh he's playing Super well
but you look at top to buy score four
and a half out of five clearly no slouch
either so it's
amino's thinking first and I guess he's
worried about C3 in some of these
positions iffy castles
yeah well we see the Bishops have been
traded off now and uh
so Bishop D2 played for black very often
it is about whether you want to get a C5
break in or not is that something that
you want to play for Queen E7 Rook date
C5 ideas right now he's in a tank tank
A5 so stopping Bishop B4 I love it yes
we I was looking at C5 about to make a
comment just trying to wrap my head
around the position he plays A5 instead
and when you play A5 sometimes you do a
follow-up with B6 and you get the A6
Square for your Bishop uh something also
A4 will keep two Pawns in place with
just one that could be good but can this
Pawn be defended on C or the move B5
that's one of those big questions
yes it can and that's what love does
Robert he goes with the move B5 and
that's why A5 is important because it
opens up more squares for the Rook as
well as the bishop very often a blacks
Rook can jump onto A6 Black's Bishop can
come to A6 to guard that B5 Pawn so A5
was preemptive Levon always wanted to
not give away the C4 Pawn he still keeps
it intact white meanwhile starts playing
on the king side H4 h586 with not having
castled on the king side it gives an
additional option to Amin I'm getting
flashbacks to dubov against was it Mama
Jarvis again somebody uh they play these
lines they give up a pawn the C4 pawn
and just play on the flank and it's some
wild stuff it's really exciting chess uh
but difficult to play for both sides and
it's actually Lavon Who's down on the
time so what happens in these positions
the Knight on F6 is a critical Defender
if then I ever were to move Knight G5
type of ideas would be really nasty so
for example it just to move ago if you
play some backwards move like Knight to
D7 you're gonna see the eval bar react
because your politics B5 politics before
Knight G5 threatens Checkmate in one
over here and the bishop is loose on B7
so the Knight needs to stay on F6 in
these positions it's a critical thing
and actually just while we have the
analysis board up I'm going to show your
point why A5 was so critical that back
here is let's say you played I don't
know I'm just gonna waste time for black
uh I guess this wasn't a good way of
doing it but I'm gonna castle and then
play B5 these moves don't work in these
positions because after A4 C6 this is
the critical point is Knight comes to G5
and your Rook is trapped in the corner
and you normally would block with Knight
to D5 but you can't do that when
Checkmate in one is hanging on H7 so
just to show how important the Knight on
F6 is in many of these positions
including what we have in the game
really nicely shown there Robert all
these subtleties that exist in these uh
Catalan kind of sacrifices and speaking
of sacrifices there's another one on the
board look at the way the players have
handled
goes for G4 after eight six gives up the
cheap on you mentioned this in another
game that when you're going for the king
it's all about opening up the files and
the diagonal at the cost of the G Pawn
white has opened up the G file and taken
more time from black than Knight on G4
now can be attacked Rook G1 in the air
there's also atig's B5 and Knight G5
type of ideas if you want this light
Square Bishop so things are really crazy
here but Lavon suddenly is speeding up
and it's I mean to have to buy who's
slowing down I think it's a bad sign for
him because you're the one who's playing
a sacrificial line Tanya and when your
opponent says okay I'll bite let me take
that pawn that you just gave me and then
you start to think and probably
indicates you don't know the line very
well
yeah and it's amazing that Lev did not
really take that much time but
immediately grabbed the G4 Pawn just
taking on the challenge there and now
white has to prove the compensation it's
clear yes you've got the G line but you
still got to make the moves you still
got to build that attack and Robert once
again this line that you're pointing out
right take on B5 take on B5 Knight jumps
to G5 black has to capture the Knight
the bishop on B7 Falls thank God for
Love on our onion for that move A5
because otherwise The Rook on 8 would be
trapped yeah no it's a really good point
I mean these I'm just trying to wrap my
head around everything going on here and
I still can't get over it Tanya like all
the variations that we're going to come
up with but also the fact that he gave
up the pawn and now is thinking I just
that that somehow gets to me I don't
know because I feel like when you play a
line you really have to know it not just
from a memorization standpoint but from
the play Queen did come to E4 so I think
that's a move we can get behind but I
have to say I like levon's chances
absolutely lavon's got two extra pawns
white has got just a few moves to try to
create that attack to try and get that
initiative in goes for Queenie for
attacking the Knight Lev has the option
to fall back with the Knight with a
Tempo defends the Knight attacks that
Queen on e4 the idea was to slide all
the way to H4 and we see the eval bar
dipping it is an inaccuracy and these
are the downfalls of these positions
Robert that you have to be so precise
after sacrificing those two pawns you
immediately have to play All the Right
Moves to get the counter play and we're
just minutes on the clock that's that's
a big ask it is and look at Black's
moves by the way took a pawn brought his
Knight back to safety developed this
Knight so all of blacks move had clear
purpose I think what happened to buy is
relying on is some kind of Rook G1 and
an attack and he does play Rook G1 so
he's going for that I think that black
would be wise to step off the G file
because Bishop takes H6 with discoveries
would be there so this Knight can come
back to G8 at some moment the queen
trade would be offered and you're just
trying to protect your king at all costs
yeah tricky tricky position here and
once again of course for white it is
about getting that attack onto the black
king Knight E5 if black was to trade on
E5 that means the knight from F6 gets
displaced and it is a key defender in
Black's position so white really trying
to create a chaos here trying to make
things messy Robert do you want to use
this opportunity I've got my eye out on
the other bird and I see some really uh
exciting stuff on the Magnus board as
well he had he is currently on four out
of five should we use this opportunity
to jump into that one I mean you say
let's go to watch Magnus I'll say
absolutely let's do it so let's go to
Magnus Carlson against Jose Martinez
that's Jasper and if my eyes
are correct isn't he up a pawn and just
dominating because black has this bishop
that can't move
yeah he's up upon
black spawn structure is absolutely
terrible on the king side no Shield
there the seventh rank absolutely naked
and Magnus already has a rook there this
looks like bad news for Jasper male uh
the Apon advancing down the board I
don't see how black will survive this
White's Queen jumping into C7 to create
more pressure Queen C7 coming in next
that's going to be pretty deadly to
handle I think you have to find a way to
stop that
um rugby four doesn't exactly give me
much comments but I love moves like this
King H2 right you're just saying I'm not
going to give you any kind of Rook takes
D4 with checks if you're gonna sacrifice
in exchange you're just gonna have to do
it and hope that it works out but it
shouldn't so objectively a Magnus is
just crushing this game and look at him
with those sunglasses on I mean he is
just looking cool
he's crushing it in style today
that pillow that's I want to know what
that pillow is in the background
yeah I wonder what it is it's
yeah we will get an update from it if
you have him join us afterwards and we
can always ask him because it's it's the
bright Corner in his room right now but
also his position looks pretty bright
maybe Chad can tell us what's really
going on with that pillow over there if
they can read what is written on it it
looks like some kind of uh I don't know
like a superhero pillow no
well maybe he's the villain you know
there's a superhero pillow but he's air
things uh device is on and his air
quality is good so it seems a bit human
but otherwise the air quality is good
yeah the windows are open the fresh air
is coming in and it looks like Magnus is
in driver's seat in this one Robert
let's pull out from here and take a look
at some other games what catches your
attention it's so difficult to pick a
game with the names that we have and the
positions that we have
it's difficult for sure but you know we
know who the top of the leaderboard is I
see Ralph moment of Drew against Jeffrey
Zhang a peacefitty uh Peter Fiddler Drew
against Alan P show uh by the way a
lumpy show was amazing in division three
of the chess kid cup I was covering that
he just cruised to victory in that one
so that was cool we have Liam lay taking
on gotta compsky a little bit further
down so we've got some Legends no matter
where I gotta look at the FFL what's
going on in compsey's game over here and
it looks like white should be in a
promising position on the long diagonal
I mean break all of a game because you
got both kings in the center well one of
them remains in the center white spawn
is on G5 which means a king side
castling by white would result in a lot
of weakness he goes on to pin that
Bishop on C5 black can simply sidestep
the pin with giving a check on E7 right
now Queen E7 on the board and he says
you know what my king is not safe with a
castle but I'm gonna put it on F1 start
marching down the board with the H Pawn
and do a rook lift finish my development
I have to be honest this game I wouldn't
expect either of these two to be playing
it for Liam lay he's a D4 player that
started in the D4 opening but it doesn't
look like it came from the Queen's Pawn
game and for komsky I mean he's usually
this end game Maestro that's what I'm
used to seeing from him and Bishop H3
wait a second why is that a mistake it
looks like it just wins a piece yeah it
looks like a winning move right because
you're threatening the Knight which is
defending the C5 Bishop
is it that you go Rook E8 and start
threatening Queenie too but black Scott
rookie won as well you just simply
defend that threat
maybe you play Rook d8 and then when the
bishop takes you move your Bishop away
because that Bishop on D7 is pinned so
maybe komsky has this ridiculous defense
where you temporarily give up a piece
and I think it is Rook to d8 and once
this bishop takes then Bishop 1 C5 is
loose but you can actually play B6 there
as well because that Bishop on D7 cannot
move it is pinned that's not an easy
defense to find Robert that you're
pointing out you simply give up a piece
but don't recapture it immediately
defend that Bishop on C5 because it's
pinned on D7 and the fact that
the famous fan Legend has slowed down
he's trying to find it as well it's not
an easy task Rook d8 is that the only
way to keep the balance in the position
I would imagine so just because that
Knight is loose over there uh your idea
with getting a queen to E2 that
definitely strikes me as being an
interesting plan I just don't see it how
it works it may work but I might not
find the way forward but as you said
rookie 8 can be met by rookie one the
whole point of Queen E2 is the bishop is
loose on D2 as well so I think that Rook
d8 is the move that needs to be played
and we've got a bit of a thing this is a
big critical moment so let's hang in
here to see if camsky finds it plays
Rook deer otherwise black could be in a
bit of a trouble I'm also trying to look
for other ways the fact that he hasn't
made a move right now if there are other
ways to counter this threat the idea of
Queen E2 you can also play D3 it's a
pawn sacrifice but my problem with D3
rabbit is that white can still go rookie
one and I'm kind of struggling to find a
response to rookie one has he played D3
he has and you know what it is I think
it's fancy footwork Knight B6 after Rook
to E1 because your Knight's under attack
as is your queen but he plays it Knight
B6 attacking the White Queen and his
Pawn on D3 that could be a huge asset
going forward if white can't go and win
that pawn that's a passer in what will
be a queenless position with some
chances for black
wow and if white does decide to win that
pawn immediately with Queen D3 you're
just opening up a lot of lines black
simply sidesteps with the queen to C7
and after that The Rook is coming on to
d8 the queen is jumping on to C6 there
are all these attacks and with no
coordination in White's Rook the King on
F1 can be super weak in this position so
the end game might be the way to go you
might have to pick up the queen on E7
but then drop it with that pawn on D3 as
you pointed at everything to play for
it's a big strength in Black's position
I like compsky's position I don't like
his clock so much it's a very
complicated battle here and there isn't
that much time remaining but three
minutes is plenty for somebody who
streams who plays lots of Blitz online
and there's the increment compsky would
be mad if we took that increment from
him
absolutely and it is a position that he
needs all the increment and in fact
finally Liam decides that the D3 Pawn
cannot be allowed to stay in the game
picks it up and this means it's going to
be a fiery a festy middle game with
black instead of starting with stepping
up with the queen he keeps the pressure
and it's perhaps because if black white
does pick up the queen on E7 the bishop
on D2 will hang eventually The Rook on
E7 will hang the bishop on H3 too many
pieces to defend I don't see a way to do
that
so oh Queen F3 side steps apparently
that was some kind of mistake uh it
looks like a pretty natural move to me
but the queen comes up to D6 Tanya look
at Black's pieces all of them are
connected here white has this rook in
the corner the King on F1 the F2 Pawn
will be a Target Queen D4 going after B2
as well so I like complicated position
but maybe there are also other games
that we should get back to but you
should we go back to Lavon versus I'm in
to see what's going on there let's do it
it is our top board lebanaroni and with
five out of five another update Magnus
Carlson did win his game against josphem
in a convincing mana and this end game
that we do have we see levon's the one
with all the pawns and a lot to play for
it is opposite color bishop and white
has got the idea of planting his own
Bishop on D4 stopping at least
momentarily the pawn Advance on the
queen side and targeting G7 with Robert
if anyone's pushing for a win it's got
to be love on here look at him look how
relaxed he is and look at his clock he
is nearly four minutes ahead on time and
Bishop B6 good idea here but I mean
Tabitha Dubai he needs to start getting
some counter play he's going after this
Pawn A5 and you know this a pawn could
be a nuisance a distraction because what
black wants to do is just this just
throw this Pawn up the board all the way
to the other side and white needs to be
very careful because it's an obvious
looking plan but one that's kind of hard
to stop
yeah but right now the big question is
uh you've got to give up that A5 Bond
the big question was for me how do you
defend it and the answer is simple
there's no way to defend it the only way
is to go D4 but that gives up the d-pawn
and that's not a happy option you kind
of really reduce your winning chances
after that with Bishop A5 it's
definitely becoming messy the B4 Pawn
hangs the a pawn starts advancing down
the board Bishop B6 a nice resource
there and it might be time for black to
actually shift The Rook perhaps the
tempo you can start eyeing the F2 Pawn
maybe a move like Rook F5 clearing the
way for the H Pawn if white takes on A5
you can think about picking up the F2
Pawn or already with the idea of
queening with that h-con
yeah I like Rooker 5 a lot because if
this Pawn goes to F3 my new idea is if a
D4 D3 at the right moment and try to
just chisel down your pawns what black
ideally wants is a two on none right now
it's two on one because upon F3 shuts
down the diagonal and stops the g-pawn
so I really really like Rook F5 it also
allows you to defend the F7 Pawn if need
be but he goes Bishop C6 and apparently
the entire Advantage is gone
yeah the bar creeps up it is stabilizing
of course black still has all the edge
in the position the problem with the
move like B3 which might for a lot of
people feel that you know it's a move
you just save your save your B4 Pawn but
it allows Bishop to come to C3 with a
Tempo on G7 and the a pawn to March down
the board so with no time for that the a
pawns have been traded and now they move
Rook F5 and it all comes down to this H
Pawn Robert can Levon get it coming down
the board in time to create threats and
will it be enough
hey can and I think what he just did was
eliminate all losing chances by playing
in this way he didn't want to leave
white with an outside pass Pawn as you
were saying before so really a good
highlight by you there and I think that
he's just saying look I'm up a pawn if I
mean plays perfectly we'll just make a
draw that's fine but I do have this
outside pass pod and that's a long-term
nuisance I mean what is White gonna do
you put a bishop on D4 I play G5 so what
it was a one move threat I still like
levon's winning chances because he's
ahead on the clock but I do think that
time of Dubai is likely to draw the game
just the way he's played the last bunch
of moves indicates that he is uh
comfortable with the pawn deficit he can
hold this game
I think a lot of it will come down to
the clock uh right now I'm in Tabata by
reaching the one minute Mark Levon are
only with almost three minutes he's
going to push this one out till the end
a good strategy there just getting a
position where Lev will be playing for
two results will it be enough or not a
Time scramble is going to answer and
that's when we'll find out F3 played
defending that F2 Pawn freeing up that
Bishop from C5 and it's time for black
to start marching down the board with
the H Pawn to try and create some
winning chances
yeah the spot on G7 that's where white
is going to attack and black is going to
try to bring this one Rook F7 that's a
good move to cause confusion it's like
well what's the real plan does it
threaten anything the answer is no it
doesn't thread anything uh but he's
trying to organize his pieces put them
on the best Square as possible what
those squares are I'm not entirely sure
but he goes over to B7 just to keep an
eye on B2 and I'm expecting at some
point he has to push the pawns if he
wants to win
there's no other plan right with this
bishop on D4 it's a very cool blockade
here uh black Central pawns have no way
to go down the board rookie one so
shifting White's Rook to the other side
to try and penetrate down to the A8
Square for all the counter player Rook a
seven is also an idea that with the
Rooks on the off the board it should end
in a draw would be a lot easier when he
comes back Rook G1 it might even be a
repetition with the bishop moving to
defend G7
or it might be time to go G5 if you want
to try something in this position
I think that I mean didn't have enough
time to calculate Rook A7 you really
need to think to it's concrete right you
give a rook trade then are you making a
draw if the answer is maybe then you
don't do it because you know that this
should be a draw you're much more
comfortable with the Dynamics here and
if G5 maybe there's F4 because you can't
take on that four of those lands on G7
so I feel like I mean did the right
thing playing quickly not overthinking
not trying to get yourself in time
trouble so good job by him
G5 so he's still playing for the win I
still think Robert that with the Rooks
off the board this should be holdable
but like you said unless you're 100 sure
you don't want to rush into it but
intuitively it just feels that opposite
color Bishop with white skin in command
over to the king side to stop the black
pawns and he might be heading there we
might see Rook A7 coming up
yeah Rook a six check you might lock
with the rook in which case we get that
trade and here we'll see big decision
from him in is he sure that this is the
draw
wow critical moment here does Amin
believe that he can hold
this position without the Rooks on the
board and as long as the Rooks stay of
course Lev will keep on trying and such
a tricky point for love because with
Armin just having 30 seconds he's asking
a big question right now
and that can that's never Pleasant to
answer with just 30 seconds on the clock
so Levon choosing a very appropriate
moment finally amid decides that this is
a confident hold
okay but the evil bar did I mean when
it's only at -1 or minus 0.5 you kind of
expect it should be a draw uh with best
play but I'm wondering if there's any
chance whatsoever you play H3 the white
king will just go here can this black
king this is my question is can this
black king somehow just run around the
board and get somewhere active oh okay
and the big question is that what is the
pawn structure that you want with why do
you want to play E4 and trade no you
don't because that allows two Parcels on
the king side after the pawn trade so E3
and I think this is the perfect
defensive structure for white robin you
keep the pawns on E3 and F3 the king
shuffles around uh you don't allow black
to go D4 yes the black king can match
all the way down to the board all the
way to B3 and C2 but there is no
improvement after that do what you want
but what next your king comes to C2 your
king comes to E2 get your king to even
E2 and then what
yeah no I'm not seeing any progress the
bishop and the pawns that I've
highlighted they're all protected which
means that black will not be able to
make progress if these pawns get traded
yeah you're not winning the game the the
good news about opposite colored Bishops
means your king can sit on a dark Square
you can't kick the king out of there and
that you just lead the bishop and pawns
where they are
and that's what he's going to do he's
just going to move around with the King
now and there's really nothing to be
done here black can put his King on F1
take away the G2 Square
or like this after King H2 you go King
F1 and
still don't see it white not even moving
the king anymore
yeah this is just a draw so I think uh
we can let these two players finish the
game uh that looks very even so why
don't we go to perhaps the game between
um Wesley so and Yvonne Sarris that one
looks
like it's in the late stage of the game
and it's actually sarich who is up in
exchange against Wesley
but the knights are so tricky you've got
to watch out I think for white the big
problem is the King on H5 it's almost a
mating net if the other Rook lands on H2
it's game over and that's where it's
headed Rook D2 mate in one threatened
you've got to come back with the Knight
to G4 I think to stop that
and then maybe there's Rook G2 and
you're just chasing down this Knight
over here and looks like it's going to
be a Checkmate whether you like it or
not
I really don't see a way for white to
fight this Rook H2 is a big big threat
you don't have a check you've got one
check on B6 but Rook B6 just runs into
King A5 or King C King A5 I think hit
that rook and no good Square
this is game over and that's it Wesley
saw has resigned wow Ivan sarich takes a
big Point here
yeah he does and it goes to show that in
these fields even players that don't
start with 2700 though Yvonne Sarge has
been over 2700 in his career they can
take down the superstars and look at
this game it says that batius blue bomb
is better with the black pieces thanks
to the Past pawns this is anyone's game
at this point it might just be a draw
index reviews they don't know who's
better it's a bishop and queen versus a
queen a bunch of Pawns over here is the
black king safe enough that's a big
question are these pawns quick enough
that's another but they have repeated
moves
to draw yeah yeah wow the only way to
perhaps stop that is to try to trade the
Queens but the players are still
probably feeling that that does end in a
draw we see a repetition and this one
ends it's always tricky on seconds and
Robert do we have more games that are on
we do we have Vladimir kramnik in this
ending looks kind of tricky to me but
white should be winning thanks to being
up oh
oh you see that last move Rook H7 check
the deflection
that's amazing
that's such a nice finish Rook 87
picking up giving up the Rook to pick up
your own Queen and now that Queen from
Aid also defends that H1 square that was
a good touch by big Vlad there
yeah really nicely done by him and he's
gonna put his Knight on H1 the queen
protects it all the way from the other
side and he should be able to quickly
mop up the pawns and win this game big
win for krumnick
yeah
yeah wow and I was thinking you could
also start thinking about checkmates on
G2 start with the move on G4 Queen G2
comes to mind uh but instead he falls
back with the Knight the plan that you
mentioned and the H2 Pawn Falls one by
one both the pawns will fall and this
will be game over the player is playing
on seconds but it should be enough
there's no moral degradation here
kramnik he receives his increment so he
doesn't have to worry his Queen is about
to deliver a Checkmate and he is going
to get this Victory he's gonna move up
the scoreboard and that gives him a
chance to fight for division one
yeah it does so with just four rounds
remaining it is everything to play for
and there we see Vlad he's done it he
wins the game with a mate coming in that
is a game over and with that Robert I
think it's a wrap for round five
well we're that was around six actually
I was about to say like yeah I'm losing
track it's been already a long day and
still so much chess left we're already
in round seven and Tanya I think you'll
like this matchup it's levonne aronian
versus Magnus Carlson
that is gonna be a fun one chat chat
level
Jenny starts with the white pieces we
want to get chat predictions in for this
one what do you guys think will happen
here 11 starting with the King spawn
opening this is a big one
yeah but Magnus he might need to make a
move at some point I'm not sure if
that'll help him but I I do believe so a
Magnus may not be at the board I'm not
sure what's going on but the round
starts as soon as the previous one ends
so there's Magnus oh he's running back
and now he's without the crosses
that's the first time we're seeing
Magnus today without his glasses on and
he comes back to the board E4 played and
he starts with the King spawn opening E5
are we gonna see a Spanish or an Italian
Spanish on the board
thankfully I had enough to answer the
question because I wasn't sure and we do
get a Spanish from Lavon and I think the
big question Tanya is does Lavon just
want to make a draw he doesn't want to
lose that's obvious no one ever wants to
lose but you're playing Magnus Carlson
you take any risk or do you force a draw
or getting a marshall I think he may
Force the draw
wow we often see white go into an
anti-martial when they want a game and
with so much theory that has advanced in
the martial black has sacrificed upon
that many lines just end in a draw or an
end game where white has an extra Pawn
but black has got a bishop pair and it's
enough to keep the balance in the
position Robert we don't get a marshall
seeing we don't see a martial being
played out too often like we're seeing
right now
yeah I think that
Magnus and icaru have made a draw in the
marshals several times very quickly and
you know these kind of lines where black
has given up a pawn but has a lot of
activity and play you see the
coordination of Black's pieces with the
miners doing really good job here and
white lacks development now there are
some positions where white even tries to
steal a second Pawn on D5 but it's not
about the material you need to catch up
in development and that's why you see
the Knight quickly come to E4
it's gonna be a draw this is the exact
variation
yeah this is all Theory this is all uh
lines that have happened a hundred times
before and both players are fully aware
of it which is why they're just blitzing
at their moves and I think for Lavon and
for Magnus it's not a result to be
unhappy about there's still so many
games left a Magnus has already had a
defeat Levon undefeated so far and I
think he wants to keep that going and I
think a draw with Magnus is not a bad
result given the tournament situation at
all yeah they get a breather now the one
downside of getting the Breather now is
they were gonna get one anyway because
there's a break after round seven so
like you didn't really need the rest
because you're gonna get it but I think
it's a great result for Lavon for sure
he's already now played Magnus he keeps
his lead uh in the tournament and then
for Magnus well I had the black pieces
what do you want from me against someone
as strong as Levon Ronin so I think it
works for both
and this is the exact same game between
uh Hikaru and aronian from the from
Norwich s right now we're just being
updated with that so a big shout out to
our producer big for letting us know
that uh that they just played out the
same game as in Norway chess
yeah no Magnus zakara played this
multiple times they've also played this
in the Champions chest or event so this
is like their draw like hikar and Wesley
have the Berlin draw Hikaru and Magnus
have this draw but lavon's like hey I
want to be invited too I'm gonna make
the draw it's gonna be good for my
Tournament results so let's move on well
there is no more Magnus Lavon for this
round by the way other games that finish
quickly Alexi drev and Peter Sidler what
is this the Russian champion from
Championship from 2000 like drayv and
Spindler they make a draw and then you
have picho and mametov making a pretty
quick draw so let's go to how about the
legendary gotta komsky he's still on the
top boards
yeah wow he's fighting for his uh big
spot in the in the divisions of the aim
chess rapid and he keeps the fight on he
starts with the white pieces while the
Queens are off the board but it looks
like a queenless middle game with all
the minor pieces still on but it's all
about comparing the pieces I really like
White's Bishop on edge to the bishop on
B5 feels more active you've got the a
pawn advancing down the board but Robert
is this enough well it's far from enough
but is it something to push for in the
game
so for people who think the London
system was created by like Eric Rosen or
somebody during uh the last few years
during the pandemic the answer is no it
wasn't and gotta komsky has been
somebody who's essayed the London for
many many years he is very crisp in his
technique he knows how to milk little
advantages you see the eval bar saying
0.3 for white nothing major but then we
start talking about ideas white wants to
play Knight C4 and pawned A5 start
creating some problems on the queen side
for black A6 is not available
yeah it's a tough one you're just uh on
the wrong end here and you've got to be
passive you've got to stay defensive for
the whole game and we'll see if Yvonne
sarch is up for it and also I just want
to correct myself to draw that we just
saw between a Magnus and laugh I think I
said it was the game between Hikaru and
lava was the game from Norwich ass
between Hikaru and Magnus and they've
played that uh a couple of times but uh
Levon and Magnus following that exact
same draw and that one ended quickly I
was looking forward to a big fight there
Robert I've got to admit that I'm a
little disappointed make sense from the
player's perspective but damn I wish
that was uh that lasted longer
yeah I mean we want to see a fight
between all the players but I get it
especially with the tournament standing
I think we both do so uh magazine no
choice right he played into a variation
where if he doesn't make that draw he's
just worse so I think we can forgive uh
the players for doing what's best for
their tournaments a nine round event and
what's going on here we see the pawn
structure being ruined for black and I'm
telling you komsky's so good in these
variations maybe Sarge knows his way out
but I'm already looking at split pawns
and thinking white has an edge
[Music]
um
oh I can't immediately pick up the A5
pawn and start targeting the A7 Pawn so
this is going to be a long grind by uh
FFL Gata camski Rook A5 on the board the
first big question is I don't think you
want to make the move rookie defending
that A7 part but you know what Robert I
think A6 is possible here because you
hit the bishop on B5 and if white
captures on A6 there's a pin along the
airline Bishop A6 runs into Rook 8 so
you guard your Pawn on A7 by making an
offensive move and win some time
yeah it's a pretty huge move so good
call good find by you there A6 available
the bishop should probably just slide
back to C4 and black does get a quick
initiative with his Nikon into E4 so I
starting to see it for black a little
bit but I think if black isn't quick you
really need to get that momentum going
because this is a long-term weakness the
C5 Pawn is a long-term weakness so I'm
looking at 94 and if Castle's Knight to
D2 you desperately need the activity of
a rook try to slam on D2 otherwise white
will legitimately be better
active in this in
this and leave Evans to it he does start
with the accurate move Knight E4 as you
were pointing out Robert let's take this
moment to zoom out and take a look at
some of the other action as we're
inching closer towards at the final
stages of the Swiss part of the play-ins
what catches your attention
so many great games Laurent pressing
days taking on Vladimir krumnik not at
the highest bit of the standings but
considering that fresenet already beat
Magnus Carlson why not take down a
second former world champion and in this
position I have to say
um I don't really love fresenada's
position in fact I really dislike it
because black is even a material but
whose King is safer is definitely Chrome
next and why this position just feels a
bit loose
yeah it's the kind of position that you
really need to look deep into to
understand and what you're saying right
blacks peace activity and even though
it's a position without Queens White's
King has got all these checks to answer
rookie three check the other Rook coming
on to d8 there could be a knight D3
check and I think it was very important
for uh Vlad to actually get rid of one
of the for fresna to get rid of one of
the Rooks Rook F3 nicely played there to
dilute the pressure and with this the
Knight can jump onto D3 and the other
night can find itself onto that spot of
B4 and let's not forget F4 is a big
Target in the position actually how are
you defending it you've got to go F5
create more weaknesses
I mean there's so many holes in this
position if these Bishops were off the
board I think black's already
strategically winning so maybe bishop B4
is an option because as you said the
Knight does want to get to B4 and
prominent plays it but let's trade the
Bishops B2 will be loose E5 check and
let's we usually say The Bishop's
advantage against a knight is this
bishop really having any sort of
advantage against this Knight the answer
is absolutely not the Knight because of
the way it moves can jump from color
complex to color complex the bishop is
stuck on the light squares and you're
staring at your own pawns no matter
which diagonal you go to
now that's a great point and I love this
call by you Robert very strategic
important decision with the move F5
White created so many a dark squared
weaknesses so you want to get rid of
those Bishops Bishop C3 trade that off
the other night looking to jump to C5
but watch out for that A7 Pawn it's a
bit tender so you've got to time it well
and now with the Bishops off blacks
Knight can also jump over to E5 and even
think about immediately winning some
material
yeah I think that President will give up
C4 to open a diagonal for his Bishop
that's his plan in the event of 95 check
taking on C4 so I like your plan I think
Knight C5 is good A7 that's a pawn you
would love to keep but maybe it's not
possible if it is Rook A8 comes to mind
but it looks oddly passive though it's
only for a turn then Knight C5 A5 A4 now
that I think about it Tanya and you've
mentioned you know this a pawn maybe
Rook A8 is the precise move necessary
but it's such a difficult move to make
okay and even if you know while you're
playing that this is the best move in
the position because you want to defend
that A7 Pawn your hand doesn't allow it
or in this case your mouse won't allow
it the move Rook ahead it's going to be
interesting to see if Vlad actually goes
for that the idea is clear you want your
other Knight into the game the only way
to defend A7 is with rookie but Robert
I'd be surprised to see that on the
board I think I'm expecting either
either remove like Knight E5 or maybe
get the Rook to eat it or D it but Rook
it what a move
yeah rookie 8's actually quite a clever
move because then you have Knight C5
next putting pressure on e4 there's so
many ideas G6 is a move we can't
discount he does give up the A7 Pawn so
Tanya Vlad is saying have fun with that
pawn is his response rookie E8 and just
going for the E4 Pawn like you're
mentioning I think that could work out
for black
it's very interesting that you just
combine it switch to move water and
after The Rook is on A7 it's going to
take some time to come back into the
game a rook D1 rookie 8 follows up the
white Rook will have a long way to come
to D1 or to E1 and after Rook E8 the
only way to defend the E4 would be with
a move like King to E3 but Robert even
that could potentially run into some
tactics though I'm not sure they work I
wanted to go for 94 Bishop E4 Knight C5
but you can take on D3
there are all sorts of tactics as your
indicating Knights are such tricky
pieces and I think what what chronic is
suggesting is that it's not just about
the material you could take on A7 and be
up a pawn but once that happens you have
these double pawns these pawns aren't
going anywhere because black controls
the dark squares what you really need is
somehow to punch through like an E King
F4 and E5 but you're not getting there
anything 95 check rookie 8 next E4 is a
clear Target I really really am
impressed by the way the chronic handles
these positions it's amazing right he
frustrates off the dark Squad Bishops
and now places both nights on the dark
squares and rookie 8 targeting the E4
Point Robert exciting end game but let's
pull out from here because I've got my
eye out on the other boards and there's
so much action uh I'm looking at the
Parham Sam Savion board it's absolute
Madness I feel the black king is about
to get checkmated any moment there or
potentially an attack look at that Rook
on 86 it's the one that's defending and
keeping things together but my question
is how did that even get there did Black
even Castle in this game but there's no
time to backtrack and do an action
replay because the players are down on
the clock
so black castle and move forward I can
see that I can't answer the question of
how the Rook got over there it went on
some kind of crazy Rook lift at some
moment but now the Rook is here it does
defend a G6 it also makes sure that h8
won't be a problem with his Bishop on C3
and at the right moment if black can get
Bishop D6 in Suddenly It's seven on the
attack so my first instinct time if I'm
honest is okay black has to be in bad
shape because your pieces are scrambled
but the more that we sit here and I see
the evil bar still suggesting that white
is slightly better the more I kind of
like Black's position because you're the
bishop pair this bishop dominates The
Rook on D1 and I just don't see how
White's pieces jump forward anymore
jumping forward I've got to move Knight
F5 I don't know good or bad but it's
definitely jumping forward taking
advantage of the pins that we're talking
about I'm hitting that Rook on 86 Robin
asking questions where do you want to
move to it's an awkward piece but I see
you can probably go Rook H5 but what I
really want to do after that is trade
the Rooks it's my dream maybe Rook H4
comes to mind and I'm really eyeing
ideas off a mate on h8 if you're kind
enough to cooperate
normally I am kind enough where Co
commentators I should cooperate but at
that position I don't think I would
allow you to deliver a Checkmate but
Rook D2 was played apparently that's a
mistake uh looked like a pretty normal
move trying to get the Rook over to F2
and if there's no Checkmate if there's
no mating attack does black have time to
start pushing these pawns for that's one
of those big questions who's first he
goes Rook H7 a defensive move comes to
F2 and I am I mean I have to kick this
bishop out here I think that there's a
threat of Checkmate down on C1 so at the
right moment I'm pushing this part of
the board trying to pry open the c-line
wow and we see crosses after crosses for
the Moose Robert which looks so human
and so tempting to make to keep things
together Bishop G7 will be the first
move that comes to your mind to stop any
activity on the diagonal and now Sam
Savion trying to trade out the Rooks but
again an inaccuracy there and that's
kind of strange because these are
exactly the kind of moves that you want
to make to dilute White's pressure here
take that Rook destabilize the Knight it
looks like things are in control for
black now but it's that Rook on H7 it's
such an eyesore and Black's position
yeah it's not where it needs to be Rook
H5 at some moment but A5 is loose but I
think that with the shattered Pawn
structure on the queen side even if
white goes up a pawn this kind of
reminds me in a way of that Magnus win
over abhimanyu Mishra whereas that light
Square Bishop kind of dominating the
opponent's Knight so even if black loses
a Pawn on the queen side I don't think
that's the end of the story C4 will be
played the 9985 will be loose this
bishop is just
so strong they're on D3
hmm
yeah and white is targeting the weak
bonds that you are mentioning Queen
jumps into C7 there's still some
defensive work and a task required for
Sam saviano Robert again I've got my eye
out on the other games as well and with
a Magnus Carlson levonaronian ending in
a draw I'm in Tabitha buys just half a
point we started the round seven with
half a point less than 11 arunian he's
playing against italyzaga and it's
another game that's got my attention do
you want to just quickly take a look at
that
okay here we are uturizaga name we
haven't mentioned a single time I
believe and for I mean top of Dubai he
started off well but this game does not
look good at all for black now you may
say haven't they talked to me about this
with the bishop on the light squares an
opponent's king maybe vulnerable but
there's a pawn in the way Black's best
move is E4 throw it off the board open
up the diagonal and go try to Checkmate
the white king but that Pawn's not going
anywhere because there was a knight that
is firmly entrenched on the E3 Square
protected by a Pawn on F2 exerting
pressure on the C4 Pawn so Tanya isn't
the next idea to play B5 for white and
just take on C4 a bunch of times
I love it and you never want to take the
C4 Pawn with the Knight allowing E3
which is why you want to put in B5 move
the queen come in the way of the defense
and take it with the heavy pieces as
long as you keep that Bishop on B7 and
trapped there as long as it doesn't have
activity on the long diagonal the Knight
indeed is stronger than the bishop
Robert after B5 it just looks like an
extra Pawn but white Fest makes the
simple move King G1 falling back on any
diagonal checks and C4 can still be
picked up in fact Rook C4 I think now
with no E3 you can actually play it
immediately there are some pins that we
need to work out here and I'm trying to
figure I think actually Rook C4 you can
take it I'm just going to show this very
quickly and after oop that's a mouse
slip sorry Rook 64 versus Bishop D5 and
I'm exerting full pressure on this pin
and once you take take now your Rook is
pin you take my rookie lose your queen
so you drop it back but because the
king's on G1 there's Queen D1 check
picking up this Rook at long last so you
have to be very very carefully if you're
a terzaga and yeah he's careful he
slides the queen on over to E2 he says
that pawn on C4 is not going anywhere
but I like this little back and forth
that yeah is doing
it's like a little Dancing Queen I'm
gonna do a little replay of what just
happened Queen E6 Queenie do we started
with this position and the Queens are
jumping around and finally we see a
white falling back to D1 this time not
heading to A2 defense the A4 Pawn again
also eyeing that D4 Square Queen from D4
uh attacking Black's weaknesses B5
always in the air it just feels as if
black has all these long-term weaknesses
with the pawn structure and he keeps
dancing with the queen
yeah but F5 is a nice move wait turizaga
if you take with a pawn you drop the
pawn H5 that's like what the queen on D1
did I wasn't looking in that direction
but he opened up F5 and now if Pawn
takes G6 here I think it's time for Rook
takes C4 and the black king will also be
exposed
this is amazing I was so easy to miss
that the queen from D1 not only defends
A4 but is the H5 Bond that's full board
awareness uh there by iterizaga some
really cool stuff wow King G6 that's
desperation not bravery
yeah that's not what you want your king
not at all we will see the Rooks get
traded on C4 and I think black will try
E3 you know it's just hoping that white
goes wrong there but I don't think white
will blunder sometimes so a Checkmate on
the long diagonal you just trade and if
E3 your knight just goes back and takes
so the queen can't join the party as the
queen 91 that heroic piece has been
protecting all the key squares
and with that idea not working he
decides to keep the Rooks on the board
but that means that the bishop on B7 is
still in active Rook d8 hitting the
queen he wants to perhaps jump in with
the Rook to D3 trying to create some
illusion of play hair but Rook C5 that
H5 weakness still in the air Robert
White's got his own ideas Rook C5 Rook
H5 I really like it and black might be
forced to offer a queen trade with Queen
F3
but if you trade the Queens you probably
just lose uh but maybe that's Black's
best hope at this point because there's
not going to be a Checkmate against the
white king and there's also Rook C7
getting the bishop and the pawn over
here the bishop actually just completely
stuck that's really bad news and Rook G5
check I might add it might win the H5
Pawn anyway
yeah because King if you come up to the
f file there's Rook F5 coming in you
might be forced to go King at six but
then there's Knight F5 jumping in with
the idea of at least winning the H5 Pawn
I love throwing in Rook G5 nice spot
there
yeah but 17 seconds for tablet to buy
bad position I do think it's Arizona is
gonna take this one and if he wins this
game he'll move into a tie for first
place with Levon aronen so it's I don't
want to be harsh about any players but
when you think about being at the top of
the scoreboard you think okay I'll play
Magnus oh I just drew Magnus I'll play
Yana palmistry I'll play dingley ran
I'll play Hikaru Fabi but if you get to
play iterizaga that's one of those
tricky pairings where you're like okay
that is a favorable pairing at least on
paper when he turns August six out of
seven like he's about to be I don't know
if you really want to face him he's been
in the Pro chest league for a long time
many successes to his name
that would be an amazing run for it to
rizaga and you mentioned janapamnushy I
quickly sneaked a look at his game and
Robert he just got checkmated on the
board with the white pieces against
Pavel Smirnoff and that's the point that
these formats everything is so
unpredictable it looked like it was a
brutal brutal game that won
but it's over already and we still have
action on
it's just a really good you know shout
out by you there because I was just
pulling out names and saying how you may
think in a pairing is favorable it is
but then you just note that spear not
beat uh Mr napometershy and Ava Smyrna
by the way has some big and victims on
his list including Vichy Anand from the
uh chess.com Global championship last
year so this one he tarzaga is pushing
his pawns he's clearly winning the
Knight on E3 has dominated the opposing
bishop and so just a matter of time
before he goes Knight g2-4 for example
wow just some incredible incredible
results as we focus on this game right
now players playing on second the knight
in Queen is a deadly combination of all
the attack and that's why we see white
rerouting the night again that H5
weakness just staring down the board
black does give up that E4 Pawn but it's
too little too late there's no way for
black to actually uh strike up a
combination between the queen and the
bishop on the long diagonal the queen
comes back to C2 the D1 square is
completely defended now you can just
trade off the Queens nice play there
good good technique by durizaga in this
one yeah it was never up for debate
there was no doubt whatsoever and he's
just gonna play G4 I think and he's
gonna have an outside pass Pawn so the
black king will have to deal with the B6
Pawn
but there's another pass Pawn about to
rumble up the board
uh we see that happen and eventually
white skin will join the party as well
uh not to forget that the White Knight
can stop targeting the black Bishop if
the black king goes too close to the
h-bawn and expecting a resignation there
and that does happen iterizaga does take
the point
loses with the black pieces Robert is
that the end of round seven
it looks like there are a few games
going on actually quite a number of them
surprising amount but minlay is still
going out what in the world this has to
be good anyone
I mean It's gotta be good for black look
at those connected boss spawns White's
got a Pawn on C7 but that's one past one
black meanwhile has got D4 D the D4 Pawn
advancing straight down assisted by the
other Pawn the F4 Pawn is falling this
is game over and I think the players
have resigned we should because I don't
see the clocks moving anymore yeah that
one is over this one's still going and
Dimitri kolars who was in division one
of the chess kid cup he's on board 34
right now that's how strong these events
are where KOA is just making division
one was a huge success for him and he
performed well there and then now you're
looking at this and he's board 34 and
he's losing so this is how strong the
Champion's chest door is
yeah and White's idea is clear you just
want to match up the board with the King
black and give a couple more checks from
H1 H2 but the King goes B2 A3 B4 C5 and
absolutely save them meanwhile the G
Pawn is going to be a nuisance
for black to defend
okay but black down a few seconds and
with a losing position Rook fa check is
about to end the game Bishop H7 there's
Rook h8 chasing the bishop away the
bishop on D4 defends the G7 Pawn
nice one there Robert if the bishop
comes into the defensive first
destabilize it and then continue to
Queen your own pawn and that is it
Dimitri colas resigns and with that I am
looking at our scoreboard going into the
final two games of the Swiss portion of
the planes and indeed it's Levon aronian
and iterizaga we're at six out of seven
and hot on Heels Magnus also an after
losing game due to Laura at five and a
half with a bunch of other players there
including FFL
karakamski
komsky doing great in this event
kovalenko we saw him earlier in the show
very briefly at five and a half as well
this is the moment we start calculating
or my tie breaks great can I make a
couple draws you can't rely on that
because part of the tie breaks are the
opponents you played along the way what
if your opponent loses the last two
rounds what if one drops out uh what if
your opponent from round two plays one
of your other competitors opponent from
round three and now you are relying on
other people you want to have control of
your result and we see with two players
at six out of seven it seems like
Destiny is in their hands and I think we
could see a bunch of draws but for the
players in the trailing pack Tanya oh no
you got to play especially for maggus
Carlson
yeah it's just two more games right and
once again it's gonna come down to how
many players are tied on those equal
number of points and who's got the
better tie break so it's everything uh
to fight for in the coming two rounds
and Robin I believe you've got one more
game still going and here it is the
players playing on seconds not
theoretically this is a draw and Black's
done everything right the way to do this
is to get your king into the opposite
color corner of your Bishop so that when
there's a check either from the last
rank or from the side you can block it
with the bishop and as we're talking at
it plays at Robert and there we have it
this one ends in a draw yeah normally
you'd waste the move here but it's still
made no illegal moves or blacks that
game was a draw Fair result between Igor
The Siege and advancing dragnev so so
many Grand Masters no matter what board
if it's board one or board 41 all these
GMS taking part
wow and it's a stacked feel and it's
packed at the top which is two players
on Six Points a bunch of players
including Magnus Carlson at five and a
half and of course also extremely strong
ground Masters at five the next two
rounds are going to be fire on the board
everything to play for nothing is
certain for anyone we will be back with
more play in action in just a few
[Music]
thank you
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
play against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
my inspiration with reading about great
players from the past great great
performers from the past Arthur Ashe
reading his life uh his legacy Jackie
Robinson who was even earlier after
reading about people like that Malcolm X
and Dr King their Journey James Baldwin
those are people who made me feel as I
was pursuing this this history making
moment if you will that
I wasn't really going through stuff that
was that hard I mean I know we were
still and still are in the middle of a
deeply divided uh Society in this way
where the struggle is still real for
African Americans where equality of
treatment is is something you thought
should have happened a century ago but
or at least in the last century but it's
still happening today
but it's not like it was and I
understood that I'm standing on the
shoulder of the Giants and they were
absolutely my inspiration in dark
moments difficult times
[Music]
chess Grandmasters can then lose 10
pounds and burn 6 000 calories just by
sitting yeah so I've actually been
spending a lot of time getting in shape
wow that's great what are you doing
mostly like Rook lifts oh I've never
heard of that it's a thing don't look it
up
thank you
foreign
alongside me Grandmaster Robert has
calling all the action Robert it's been
exciting it's been fighting chess and
now it comes down to this final final
two games
yeah it's been down to the wire in many
of these contests we've seen blunders in
time trouble we've seen Stellar
sacrifices we've seen just excellent
play all around but all that hard work
could be for naught if you don't have a
good finish only two games are left in
the Swiss stage and Tanya for being real
all these players they want to get to
the top eight so they can play or
division one
yeah that's the big price that's the big
enchilada you want to get into that top
eight and not just that you want to try
to finish in top four so you can choose
your opponents in the match play but
we'll get to that we'll talk more about
that right now we've got two big big
games coming up and Robert action is on
Lavon aronian on the top what takes on
iterizaga
wow and we we're seeing a Catalan This
Time by iterizaga
I think that iterzaga wants a draw and
there he has it it's over the game is
already over you know how I feel about
the draw for ban the draw offer I don't
blame it I don't blame Lavon this was
smart because they're trying to make the
top eight great ban the draw offer
please
oh my gosh I feel your pain right now
this game with these two players could
have been a
minute and a tournament situation of
course for them they've already won so
many games they're at the top they're
looking at qualifying for that topic uh
with just one more game remaining it
makes sense for them but the fans and us
as commentators do not like it I support
this band The draw offer but we've got
action on the other games Robert where
are you jumping to I see you pulled up
magnus's game I know I thought you'd be
disappointed if I went to magnus's game
so I aim to disappoint but in this
position right now are the opening
Magnus he has pawns established in the
center of the board that looks pretty
good to me black has not completely
development only now just played Bishop
to E7 and you see the Evo bar saying
white is slightly better and I agree
I've played these positions from the
white side since childhood and this
Knight that's on B1 it is about to get
out to C3 and the change in Pawn
structure I think is generally favorable
for white where white gets a pawn
advantage on the queen side the four on
three that becomes a three on two and
black has a four on three in the center
but the E Pawn is very hard to move
yeah and it's playing really fast there
and I'm not just
not just about his clock
stacking a piece hitting that Knight not
now hitting the bishop with the trade
will come on with the Knight to C3 The
Rook will come to D1 pinning the Knight
so by the time black manages to get his
King to safety Magnus will have a lot of
Peace play going on and materially it's
balanced but it just feels like a very
pleasant position the tempos will
continue with 94 Bishop G5 Rook D1 and
there are still problems for black to be
solved yeah so many easy moves for white
and kovaleco he's taking a thing so
while he does that maybe we can keep
going to see how some other games are
beginning in this round I see so many
draws I'm looking it wasn't just lavoni
teresaga it was sarich and maxudlu it
was blue bomb and komsky it was his show
and Jeffrey Zhang why did they make a
draw that's what I'm curious about maybe
Jeffrey had black so he was okay making
a good draw but that's the Berlin draw
for Jeffrey John with the black pieces
he's now in eighth place he can't just
keep making draws other people will win
their games
that comes down to the last round and
then they'll just have to go for the
kill in that final round uh but Robert
there are players who are fighting it
out and I see some great action on P
sweetie's board against Aram hakobian
and I think that's the one we want to go
to because there's no quick draw on that
one I see Harry the Jeep Harry the H
Bond Gary the g-pawn and what was it for
the e-pawn
um
okay well Simon Williams must be happy
that we're giving all the pawns their
names that we should call them by what
their names are eat this Pawn on e4 is a
bit vulnerable there might be a rook
take C3 at some moments we have to keep
our eyes out for that but Bishop takes
F6 voluntarily giving up the bishop pair
the point is to play G5 to keep kicking
Black's Pieces away and so Bishop takes
F6 was the choice at peacefitty as you
call them throws in the pawn G5 push and
Tyler what do you think are we getting
F4 as well or we just can see all the
pawns run up the board
I would love to see that pawn star down
the board especially with black king
still in the center but right now a big
decision for uh black hair does he want
to fall back with the bishop giving that
extra move to white or instead trade off
to try and he's out the pressure
speaking of pressure we see a big move
there sacrificing in exchange Robert
it's a thematic idea but black still not
having Castle the other Rook far away
from C8 do you think this is enough
compensation
such a tough question to answer and I
see the eval bar struggling with as well
it's going up and then back towards the
center uh King B2 is automatic for me
but this Knight is trying to go to B6
and it's A4 or C4 depending on how white
responds so I'm looking at this position
and I'm thinking that this Rook on D4
will likely have to sacrifice for a
knight once it gets over to B6 so now
the question is what's the correct
sequence of moves how do I uh you know
maybe get an attack on the king side
with H5 and G6 will that be in time and
speed Sidler how's it called speedler
for a second but Fiddler there he's in
the darkness he's playing in the shadows
but he's also just behind the leader and
he can jump out of the Shadows into the
spotlight if he can take down a coping
in this game
yeah wow
wow how you just explain that well he's
playing out of Darkness
but they're definitely the chess is full
of light with the edgebon and the g Bond
down the board fire on the queen side as
well King B2 played Knight B6 is what
you're mentioning uh black also has the
option to Simply play for a strategic
sacrifice he can already go maybe shark
Castle bring the Rook into the game he
starts with the move Knight C5 a ram
Jacobian is a very tactically gifted
player a very creative player I don't
think he's gonna Rush with Knight A4 I
don't think he's gonna Rush with giving
swiddler the opportunity to neutralize
with giving back the exchange
so but he puts that on C5 so there's
pressure on e4 I'm just wondering is
that something to worry about I don't
think so just yet I'm playing H5 because
Tanya as you indicated black has yet to
Castle and if you do Castle I'm quickly
playing G6 and trying to Checkmate you
so Rook H3 I really like that move as
well I think in a way he's kind of
forcing Black's hand somewhat uh because
now that the Rook protects C3 you have
to be careful that Knight for a check
may not have actual that much power at
some moment the king can think about
slinking away I don't think so here
because uh whoa these policy goes up to
B3 the pawns are they gonna repeat
Knight C5 and then you go back to A2
because C3 again is defended so maybe
after Knight C5 the king doesn't indeed
return to B2 wow King B3 is a brave
brave move and black does exactly what
we were talking about brings The Rook to
the party now after shot Castle Rook C8
is a threat on the board white probably
has to put this Rook on beef four at
some point Robert to cut off the queen
from attacking the C3 Pawn
yeah very likely
um there might be some repetition at
some point as you were asking about also
D5 is something that black can consider
if you move the Rook away because you'd
love to get your Bishop into the attack
as well and you know look out Bishop E4
Knight C5 some sort of forks will be in
the air depending on the position so
Fiddler can think about H5 but I
actually don't think there's a
checkmating attack in which case I like
his decision making just defending
everything this bishop on F1 will
eventually develop Tanya I really like
how calm spiders been given the Dynamics
here
and it's an important move to stay calm
and to defend that E4 Pawn because Rook
A4 was not possible Robert with the
queen taking that Rook on a for the E4
Pawn would fall now after Rook E3 if
black does play Rook C8 uh swindler also
has the option to bail out Simply pick
up that Knight on A4 and everything is
under control because of the last move
Rook E3 so just preempting all these
ideas
yeah and you can just play Queen to D2
Queen E1 I'm not sure what the right
squares are at this stage but he could
just defend the C3 Pawn so I think that
swedler's counting on his extra material
and suggesting that black has an
initiative but is it enough because
initiatives do fizzle out and when that
happens you look at the board and you're
like oh gosh I held one rook in my
opponent is two so Spiller has good
chances I would say
wow and and because you mentioned Queen
D2 Queen E1 and you don't want to give
back your exchange then the other idea
comes to mind you want to bring the doc
the bishop the light squared Bishop that
black has into the game you want to play
D5 and I really don't believe that white
can allow black to trade on e4 give up
that D5 Square the only way that I see
for white is actually to go E5 in that
position to just make sure that Black's
Bishop remains out of the attack
yeah it's a really instructive point the
bishop is a bad piece behind a good Pawn
so I'm with you there I think that black
will struggle a little bit and while
this game is ongoing I want to check out
the Magnus Carlsen game because we
haven't tuned in in a while so I'm gonna
see how Magnus the former world champion
it's really I'm saying it so strongly
because I forget half the time that he's
no longer the world champion and D5 has
happened in this game let's go over to
Magnus Carlson's game against Igor
kavalenko and wait what isn't white just
crushing is white is crushing he's up in
exchange and he's going to be
threatening a Checkmate into after G4
Rook H5 black skin is in the Kill Zone
trapped there it's on the board you can
give a check the King goes to after you
have to pick up the H2 Pawn Rook F6 is
the second Checkmate on the board game
over nice nice end gameplay there by
Magnus Carlsen I don't even remember
this game so I'm just gonna go oh this
is this is actually where we left off
and then right after this moment oh
um that's an exchange so oh that's a
blunder yeah the position wasn't good
for black I think we can see that
White's pieces are very active there
could be a take on C5 and Knight D6
things like that but it's better for
white not immediately winning this is
now an extra exchange and he went on to
convert it probably without too much
difficulty so Magnus Carlson moves into
a tie for first place maybe he will make
a last round draw if it means the top
finish uh he doesn't need to risk
anything but let's look at some players
who may need to risk a little bit I
don't see Wesley so's name on the
standings right now but that's because
he entered around five out of seven and
here he is with the white pieces in this
game against Jose Martinez
so it's almost a must win game for
Wesley at 5 out of seven if he wants to
keep to keep chances alive for division
one who try to get a spot in
spot this one and Robin it's exactly the
kind of position you want when you're in
a must-win situation right it's a
position for all three results I love
that Wesley's got these two Bishops on
the king side a bishop there uh Black's
got a strong Center but these pawns can
be very quickly weaknesses in a Black's
camp but again trumps for Jose Martinez
as well the Knight jumping into the game
the D3 Square being weak again it's a
game a position for all three results
but I do like white a little bit here it
is a fascinating position and what I
love about this game thus far is that
Wesley is playing in the style that he
grew up playing he was such an
aggressive tactical player where he
would create his chances and he is
trying to make it happen in this aim
chess rapid play and he wants to win get
to the matches for division one uh you
know it's weird seeing Wesley in any
other division but he's a great player
and even great players struggle against
other fantastic players but Tanya you
like the queen with the Bishops over
here but black at some point will get
the Knight to E5
seems like a very difficult position to
assess and even the eval bar is saying
like slightly better for black about
equal which color would you take
yeah that's a tough one says it's equal
this is an
economic balance position it's it's a
position where draw is the least likely
result a queen G4 it hits the Rook you
said which color I would like I think
white hair I do like the bishop pair I
like the chances of trying to create
play on the G line and uh Robert right
now there is an immediate threat if you
fall back with the queen queen D6
defending the Rook I can't play Rook G3
still delaying your knight E5 uh
meanwhile you don't have such a great
Square for your Rook if you decide to
you can't fall back with the rook and if
you go Rook to E5 then I'm just glad
that your knight isn't jumping into that
square because what you really want is
95 next yeah you want to share the
square and sharing is caring but it's
also not legal in the game of chess a
queen did go back to D6 The Rook did
come to G3 and what's the problem is
Bishop E5 met by like a bishop F7
what a position whoa
that was Madness Bishop G3 there so I'm
going to go back to analyze quickly that
bit excuse me Bishop E5 Bishop F7 you
can't take the bishop because there's
back rank problems and Bishop G3 I
thought I could just take back on G3
hitting your queen and hitting your Rook
on E6 and somehow this is still like
good for black maybe there's like a
rookie five ah it's wild stuff
this is madness this is madness the
bishop F7 what an idea there Robert love
it and that's probably what was a
scaring Martinez Jose Martinez so much
that he plays the move Queen D7 so
controlling that F7 Square defending
that Bishop on G7 again just trying to
get that Knight to E5 black is one move
away from really finding his own counter
play but he's also one move away I'd say
95 Rook takes D5 will be the response
the queen on D7 overloaded defending the
bishop and the pawn on D5 so suddenly
I'd like Wesley's position his pieces
though the Bishops are kind of awkward
on the H file they're all protecting
each other well positioned and going for
an attack so I think that Wesley has the
upper hand on the clock on the board and
of course by rating he is the higher
player between the two
what a tricky move right Rook D1
just the idea of Knight E5 so easy to
fall for because it's definitely what
black wants and as long as white doesn't
allow black to play Knight E5 he's got
the edge in the position now because
you're mentioning that Rook D5 is a
threat
I'm still trying to find a way for black
to get in 95.
can Jose Martinez stop thinking about
Rook G8 but it's I really don't want to
make this move because I want my record
if he does it the other way Robert I
like this as well he goes Rook D6
defending the D5 pawn and Knight E5
still coming in also offering a queen
trade yeah I'm looking at this position
a queen trade happens it feels like
black is starting to get closer to
stabilization but this Pawn on B5 at
some point could be a Target giving
white a Tempo move this Rook can go up
to G6 and start patrolling the sixth
rank once the Knight gets kicked out of
there so I feel like Wesley has
something here I see the Eva bar saying
he has something but he goes for Bishop
E2 first I'll go Rook G6 next and maybe
this Rook will slide over to A6 and go
after some of these Pawns
yeah this is getting tricky and the
Bishops are getting more powerful now
the Knight even if it does get to E5 you
don't see as much counter play Black has
to find a way to activate that bishop
and G7 a break with B4 a break with D4
these are the two ideas that come to
mind but he needs to time them well
right now Bishop B5 is a big threat on
the board and Robert I'm not really
seeing a good way to fight against it
you just go Rook B8 trying to get B4 in
next yeah Rook B8 makes sense but after
Rook to B8 I'm already looking at Rook
G6 as an idea and it just seems like
white is kicking Black's pieces around a
bit and now White's coordination looks
nice this Knight will probably try to
work its way to C4 but even when it gets
there white can just played B3 to kick
it out so I really am liking Wesley's
position I'm liking his lead on the
clock and I think that he's got great
chances to take this game
see it happen on the board Rook be it
Rook G6 blade I've also just sneaked in
a look at the results of the players who
have finished the game and Robert there
are only three players at six and a half
going into the final game and one of
them is Magnus Carlson so he is back in
the lead alongside Lavon aronian and in
three Saga it's gonna be a fierce round
nine with a lot of action and this one
is so important for Wesley to stay in
the mix he needs to convert this
position and we see he did get that Rook
to G6 the bishop falls back attacking
The Rook on B8 and always there are
these ideas of the B2 Pawn hanging and
B6 coming in Robert you're pointing some
check mating ideas oh yeah Bishop G4
hits The Rook runs Bishop F5 Checkmate
that's game I think that's just over
because you're winning
and if you go Rook F7 you just win the
D5 pawn and then you're again hitting
the bishop F5 idea in the air so Jose
says all right I'm gonna lose material
can you take D7 and take E4 that's what
I'm wondering right now there is Knight
takes B2 so things are a little bit
tricky still there is some Precision
required because if you give up B2 and
C3 suddenly black has some past Pawns of
his own but Wesley has done everything
right thus far
yeah I love it just take the Rook pick
up the exchange but Wesley's slowing
down because the Bishops are also so
powerful in The Possession and Black's
Rook right it can't really move you
can't give up the D5 Pawn but to me
Robert the simpler seems pick up the
Rook on D7 kick that knight from C4 B3
comes to mind Knight B2 rookie four on
the board Knight B2
and now does he want to give a check on
G4 and pick up the bishop and pick up
the D5 Pawn oh that that is great
simplification so King F5 tiniest points
Rook takes G7 distracting The Rook Rook
takes D5 check Rook takes B5 white is up
the healthy two bones I think that's a
practical choice that I would get behind
and that's why I went King H7 he's
saying I'm gonna lose that game at least
now there's this weakness here my knight
can start jumping around causing some
problems good practical choices by both
players
yeah I love it uh Wesley deciding to
give back some material to go into a
simpler winning end game Knight A4 it's
very important for black to keep the
pressure C3 Pawn is hanging there's
still some work that needs to be done I
don't see a way to actually defend the
C3 Pawn but Robert the big question is
is it really hanging imagine the bishop
takes on C3 white picks up the Knight on
A4 with the Rook the Knight takes on C3
white picks up the bishop on G7 so I
think it's a bit of a mirage and an
illusion C3 is not really hanging
brilliant point I actually was looking
at I can't defend it but it's already
defended tactically so Tanya's Vision
right now is giving us a free turn what
can we do with that move can this bishop
go somewhere useful can we've triplet F3
and Bishop E1 it's a bit passive don't
love the thought of that but even though
we have a turn Tanya I just know what we
do with it like what should white do
here
yeah that's a great question like yes C3
cannot be picked up but what's to move
you want to get your king into the game
one plan that comes to mind is develop
your king goes with your idea of F3 and
the bar it falls straight back rub it oh
The Bishop's loose Knight C3 Rook G7
Rook takes G7 and the bishop is now
hanging on G3 and suddenly black does
not lose material
and that's the difference in the
position Bond moves are always so tricky
you've got to watch out for what you
leave behind when you move forward with
F3 the bishop on G3 is now undefended
and look at that Jose Martinez jumps on
that opportunity picks up that pawn on
C3 and after the tactic that we
discovered that Bishop on G3 hangs it
was a blunt it was a blunder there by
Wesley and there's no you know beating
around the bush that was what it was but
let's see Rook C5 he still probably has
better chances just because all of
Black's pawns are hanging so Tanya we
know how precise Wesley is for the most
part he just did make a mistake there
but do you think he has legitimate
winning Chances with white pieces
it's always tricky with Wesley and he
will pick up one of the two pawns now
the first big question for black is
which Pawn to give because this is
always so tricky to answer and he's
under a minute does he go D4 or does he
go B4 and it's not an easy question to
answer Robert I I do not envy uh Jose
Martinez situation and he's confident
that the kingpun ending is a hold for
black wow that's a brave decision there
if white is not winning with Rook G5
then black is fine here now and
apparently it wasn't winning just a very
very quickly show that the idea that
looks winning for white is that if the
black king is just in time to stop and
you're just trying to play F4 but the
problem is a pawns remain so you will
play F4 the white king will venture over
when the a pawn but unfortunately The
Rook Pawn just King and pawn will not be
a winning end game and Jose deserves a
lot of credit for calculating that long
line and he did just play Rook G7 wait
wait wait this is a bit different
but the king comes to E5 anywhere and
white will get G3 F4 black will put a
Pawn on H5 and Robert there's no way to
make Improvement so after King E5 King
D3 black puts up born on H5 and I think
it still draws I feel like black could
lose this game though like this is those
positions where you make one little
mistake it looks everything should draw
right but you make one little error and
then you lose but for now everything is
written the big problem for White is you
don't have G4 because of H4 so I just
don't see it if King D3 King D5 G4 and
you start taking and the King's far away
maybe you have some outside chance but
G4 never works because H4
I think even in that case you're
actually coming back with the King on
time but as you mentioned H4 is there
which is good enough and now white can
get F4 in but after F4 black
simply I think steps with the King to C5
will catch the It's Tricky Robert I'm
not sure yeah no it's it's not easy it's
oh it should be wait a second that looks
difficult on both players now down so
they're not too many seconds remaining
uh there is two second increment that
will be important here but if I'm Wesley
A4 King E5 there's King C4 and I win the
pawn so after A4 kind of by process of
elimination you have to go King C5 F4
King D5 F he starts with F4 but similar
idea
yeah and I like this because this forces
the black king further away A4 A3 you've
got to go King C5 and now F5
yes after King E4 King C4 black should
not lose that and like you mentioned
that black is perhaps winning because in
the end you actually win the queen on f8
Robert do you want to show that line
yeah maybe after the game just because
they're moving so quick and the game I
actually just conclude relatively soon
the king could take on D4 take on A4 the
black king is just in time I guess to
get G3 but this is a race of Pawns oh
what's this it's a race oh wow he comes
back and this is definitely a draw now
and now black can come forward with the
King trade off the H Bond if black tries
to head towards the queen side white
will be in time with his own Pawn
so instead we're just going to see a
drawer black is not going to give up any
ground and this is just a complete draw
no matter if you lose the pawn your king
will get back here so they have drawn
the game but you uh you know want me to
show this line so let's just do that
very quickly that if you've tried to
play for a win sometimes you're playing
for a loss the black king comes up and
after F5 D3 Oh yay we Queen at the same
time maybe I have chances to win the
game you really don't have a chance to
lose because of the opposition of the
Kings the King has said the f file and
once the check happens The Queen Is Lost
on f8 behind it
oh yeah it's brutal it's King Pawn
endings you've got to be so precise and
calculate and that's what the players
did on playing on seconds ends in a draw
Robert more exciting end game app action
I'm looking at the Amin Tabitha by Levon
pantesulia game and even that one
is that just to draw What's Happening
Here Black's Rook on 18 is trapped for
the rest of the game so black probably
should keep in line with this Pawn
because I feel like like's in huge
danger right now if this white king gets
active I think black will be in trouble
but maybe there's no way in because even
if you get your kingdom G7 the bishop
will always come to C3 or this diagonal
and check you away
yeah
and it's not easy to find a way in as
well Rook D1 played so White's idea and
black always has Rook 87 in the air uh
you've gotta time it really well of
course and gives a check doesn't allow
it can white make progress here King H5
comes to mind because F3 isn't a
possibility
so here's repeating I mean just
shuffling around but he should bring his
key go back check do Nala vertex H7 okay
so he allows it
and and he picks it up the king's in the
wrong side so that's the good news for
uh white but this should be a draw
because you're gonna have to eventually
go after this pawn it would see him
but he's got to be careful so we were
talking about this a couple of rounds
ago that the technique here for black is
to get the King on the corner that is
the opposite color of the bishop in this
case that would be eight or H1 here so
that the bishop can actually block a
check on either the file or the rank but
right now Black's King is far away from
there which gives white some chances the
players playing on seconds right now
does he just keep continuing does he
continue to advance with the King not
right now King H5 would run into a
Checkmate yeah don't touch that King you
get mated and thankfully for black the
king can run back to G7 so that's not
Checkmate and good difference from
ponzalea seems like he'd understand
these positions very well and I think
that I mean Tablets by will be
regretting the fact that he allowed Rook
takes H7 he could have stopped that and
brought his King in himself
yeah and now he just continues to
advance with his own King the G1 square
is defended and I think white is just
going to give up The Rook does it and
this one ends in a draw and Robert I
think that was our final game of round
eight
wow okay well it feels like this round
was shorter than some of the previous
nope I see some games but they're all
the way down on board 62 and 67 so let's
go why not we have oh my gosh rook and
Bishop versus Rook
Robin I'm telling you these are so hard
to defend and now white has to be
careful he steps back to A4 it almost
looks like white should be getting
checkmated Rook B2 Rook A2 is always
Rook V6 Rook B6 is game over yep and
that's it Rook A6 Checkmate coming in
wait what just happened oh
there is a defense
there was it was winning for black and
then it seems that
well both sides are making mistakes but
they have no time but this King will
probably work its way back here the
bishop will come to D5 in the king to C5
these end games are very very tricky
there is a way to defend when you only
have The Rook but when you don't have
time up he's in the losing Zone again uh
Rook B7 check this is the way to do it
King A6 now Rook to B8
oh okay this also works I guess because
the Rook yeah The Rook doesn't have the
distance
yep go here wow she won but he doesn't
do it
she won sorry Rook G8 and rookie rookie
ate this game over he still has it open
that was Rook G7
and then Rook H1 so the thing is The
Rook now can't get in front front to
defend yeah they're struggling right now
but they have no time
whoa and now you can go Rook H1
I mean these positions are so difficult
he needs to bring his Rook down to the
other side
because the Rook is lost that's the key
oh it's a draw so the game is officially
a draw but I want to show everybody why
this is winning The Rook on the seventh
ring and it's getting question marks is
because when the King goes up to A7 the
only way to avoid Checkmate The Rook
comes to A1 the King goes here you give
this check and when the king comes to C7
you Rook A7 check picking up the Rook on
the other side of the board so that's
hard to see when you don't have much
time but these are the ideas you need to
keep in mind and way back here in this
position King C5 was great that was a
good start but around uh where was it
there was like a missed opportunity
somewhere oh here it was in this
position this is very instructive as
well that it looks like you know his
Rook B6 move was the wrong direction
because this Rook can't get in front of
the king to block this way so that's
what you need to keep in mind is that
these Rooks struggle that if you go Rook
here there's a check and a mating threat
and now after the work comes to A8 to
stop the mate over here I think that you
can
um so some my memory's not serving me
well here there's like some kind of a
rook H5 does that work
no I blundered it I was trying I
blundered it they're too difficult let's
go the next round I'll work on my broken
fisherman games later
wow I've been really nicely pointed out
that last position Robert and this is
how tricky they are and playing on
seconds we saw that end in a draw and
now it is liftoff for the final round of
the Swiss Robert this is going to decide
the players who will fight for division
one of the aim chess a rapid and we've
got Magnus Carlson taking on iterizaga
and this uh was this a sicilian Dragon
it looks like it and we saved ourselves
from seeing the quick draws that took
place levada Ronin Yvonne sarage made a
quick draw para maksudu and Matthias
bluebaum made a quick draw Jeffrey Zhang
and Alexander grishek also made a quick
draw but that's very surprising to me
because they had a chance to play for
division one so I don't think they will
have that chance anymore so Jeffrey and
grishek drawing so quickly I think that
wasn't the best call but Jeffrey had the
white pieces and probably just he
offered to draw a move one
whoa yeah just E4 and that was game over
yeah ban the draft uh Robert we're all
signing that petition after this one but
this is still on the action's still on
here and we see iterizaga he is going
for the player on the queen side A5
played and given an opportunity that
Bond will further March down the board
with A4 A3 and I'm just thinking that it
looks like black should be pleased with
the way the opening is gone
yeah this is exactly how you play these
positions as black you take control of
some of the key dark squares in the
position I get the sense that Magnus
doesn't really care about the opening
advantage that he just planned to get a
position is going to try to outplay
iterizago but every move that iterizago
has played has a clear purpose now B2
isn't threatened because Rook to B1 will
trap the queen we've seen an idea like
this earlier in the day but just keep an
eye out on B2 and so he keeps that eye
out immediately and slides his work to
B1
what do you think do you think in the
magnifica game either of the players
offer to draw and the other refused do
you think there was a draw offer that
was made considering given the
tournament situation Robert I don't
think Magnus offered him a draw I think
if I'm just being completely honest I
think that Magnus says I'm the better
player I have the white pieces if I want
to make a draw I'll do it at some point
oh what
Rook B1 oh
and love it no
so did you ask me that question knowing
that a draw just been offered
did you just completely set me up we're
teammates we're friends I
you just you just it might look like
that I'm that person who was at the
wrong place at the wrong time I did not
set you up for this but it was hilarious
the timing of it on
that hurts but you know who's still
playing right now someone who's actually
competing and trying to get to that uh
division one get those matches is aroma
Cobian and gotta compsky the legendary
gotta compsky and aramokobian very
strong player from Armenia he's a
student in the states and plays many
tournaments in the US now what in the
world is this
wow it's crazy is what in the world this
is white has voluntarily put the King on
F2 so no more castling for white
meanwhile black wants to trade off
continued development I look at the eval
bar it says that white is better and I
understand that it's because of the
control of the dark squares even if the
bishop comes bishops come off the board
The Rook can come to C1 C6 Pawn is a
backward Bond it's a weakness the Knight
jumps onto C5 and it's a lot under
control but white is still far away from
finishing development you still have to
get your E3 in develop the Bishop Robert
I think
I think long term White's doing well as
long as you can get your pieces out yeah
you have time for that in quicker time
Patrols in with Queen if we just throw
the Queens off the board white wins this
game in rapping and Blitz all the time
but black is not going to trade Queen so
if Queen D2 is played that you can't
take the Knight on A4 because you lose
the bishop on D6 then you're really
hurting on the dark squares after Queen
D2 I think Queen B8 could be the
response let's keep those Queens on the
board uh it gives you some counter play
opportunities with the Queens on and
black does look to strike with E5 at
some moment especially with a king
sitting out in the open on F2 the good
news for white is the F3 Pawn completely
limits the scope of the Knight on F6 it
dominates it from three squares away uh
but Tanya I really like the opening for
hakobian I think that komsky has a
wealth of experience which should serve
him well but I would definitely take
white in this position
hmm yeah I I agree with you a hundred
percent on this so the more pieces that
come off white has got a long-term
advantage and uh forami is going to try
and convert that one it's not a pleasant
defense but Bishop D6 and we do see that
Rama kobian is taking his time here
considering the move whether to trade or
to immediately go for Queen D2 I like
your idea of trying to trade off the
Queens yeah and it's on the board Queen
D2 played yeah this is a great choice
and I think that comp key you know he
could take and then you know try to get
his King safe and sound but I don't
think you want the queenless any because
what compsi is really thinking is can I
get the white pieces in this game I'll
beat my opponent doesn't matter if I'm
playing Magnus give me the white pieces
but for komsky it's not gonna happen
play Queen to be a reinforce the bishop
on D6 try to trade there on your own
terms and then get your king out of the
center
yeah this is going to be a long fight
and uh Robert there are some other
players as well who are fighting for
those top spots let's zoom out from this
one for a moment Wesley is one of them
but he's playing against David Anton the
Spanish Grandmaster he's super strong as
well and I see this position David Anton
has managed to create some play has
managed to create some edge here with
the Knights jumping the queen coming to
G3 a potential night jump to F5 I'm not
a liking Wesley's position uh the eval
Bar says he's just losing so Knight to
B4 apparently a mistake going after this
C2 Pawn so you mentioned Knight F6 is an
idea so Queen G3 comes to my mind I'm
trying to make it work
does look pretty scary but he trades on
E6 instead and maybe he will just play
some kind of Knight F5 Queen G3 but the
C2 Pawn is loose so you need to
calculate this very well
yeah Queen G3 is very tempting you want
to get that Knight to F5 but Queen G6
always in the air but Robert there are
so many tactics if you pick up C2
because I can always put in Rook C1 Rook
C6 can we just show these ideas like
Queen G3 and let's say black was to
start with Knight C2 and maybe before
you go Knight F5 you throw in a rook C1
okay or maybe I'm not sure okay night
before yeah
I really wanted to get Rook C6 and my
point was I know you can capture back
with the Knight but just to show the
idea that after Knight F5 now if you go
Queen G6 there's Knight E7 on the board
nasty so you get that fork because the
Knight on C6 was guarding the square and
I think that you know in these positions
with the Queen Under This Rook F6 as
well with Knight F5 to follow I think
it's just a Brute Force attack so I
really like Queen G3 now that we're
talking about it who cares about one
measly Pawn over on the queen side let's
get that Queen up the board and go for
threats
I love it but Queen treat 3 after F5
how are you continuing your attack do
you jump in with your knight to C5
what's going on Queen G3 F5 is critical
here
I like Knight C5 let's go for the other
side of the board
um what other ideas I guess I don't
really see anything else but I actually
wasn't looking at F5 but that's a good
thing to point out that sometimes the
best defense isn't getting into your
shell and hiding from the rest of the
world is by getting some activity for
yourself and kicking pieces out but I do
think that there likely will be some
issues that black has to deal with with
this Pawn on F5 but yeah maybe you're
right F5 as an option that definitely
looks interesting to me whoa but look at
the ball
it seems to say that F5
8 now and white has got something I'm
struggling a bit to find Knight F5
doesn't seem to work Rook F5 you've got
Rook F5
is there anything there Robert after
Rook F5 Rook F5 what what I don't see it
Queen G4 that's Rook F1 how are you
finishing this off
is it just this is ridiculous I mean I
would never assume this position was
plus three but yeah you just give up a
piece and then look at this look at this
the queen comes back check the King goes
Corner Queen in you have to stop me from
mating you so you take on F6 and I guess
right around here I can just start
taking pawns and I have at least a draw
by force over here but Rook takes F6
looks to be a big Advantage for white
because the king is in trouble
yeah but this is just insane stuff and
unless you play it out it's so hard to
see and we've got the eval bar guiding
us but you cannot blame uh David Anton
for not finding this idea of just
sacrificing a piece just simply playing
Rook F1 he makes the car move Queen to
F2 Robert defending the C2 Pawn still
keeping the trumps in the position but
it feels like the big pressure is over
for Wesley right now he's managed to
trade off the Bishops and things are
more in control for him wow but G4 play
Move yeah David Anton really wants
Knight F5 it'll take back with the pawn
the Knight on e4 is a monster the night
on B4 is also a monster you can't really
kick the Knight out from B4 because you
dropped D3 and you can't kick the Knight
out from E4 because you don't have
control over the F5 Square so both sides
have monster Knights but I'm looking at
this position Tanya and A4 is hanging
can black get away with it that's a big
question it's greedy it's risky
weren't we just saying that Wesley needs
to win this game to get into the top
eight
he should take and he does
he does he does Wesley seizes the
opportunity to win an extra pawn and he
says prove the compensation and it's not
that easy Knight F5 and I'm just
wondering after Knight F5 does David
Anton have in mind to actually recapture
with the Jeep on not only threatening F6
on the next move but opening up the G5
for further counter play yeah and I
think that Knight F5 GF F6 is kind of
forced but there's so much pressure
that's about to be Unleashed to the
black king black will get a rook to F7
maybe move the king try to defend this
way but there is this extra Pawn that
black has and white also is tied down to
the C2 Pawn which may slow his attacking
chances by just a hair but it may be
just long enough to keep black not just
in the game but also maybe with an
advantage
and not liking the concept of allowing a
white to have the open G line and
weakening the king's side Wesley falls
back with the Knight to D5 and I'm just
wondering if white has got the time to
start pushing this Knight go C4 and
Force black to take a decision
yeah what an interesting moment here
because after C4 we can just show you
have to take on F5 because you can't
move your knight as this 97 is loose and
Knight F5 gf5 is the Knight going to F6
is it going to E7 like where is this
Knight go I think you got F6
oh wow
and King H2 you just hide on H7 as well
let's run away
wow that's huge is this just some
incredible defense a knight D5 on the
board
David Anton having a think
I'm just amazed like look at the
position look at the Knights that are
there the pressure the tension that's
there in the center and either of the
players not blinking what a nice find
there by Wesley Knight D5 Knight F6
ruining the his own Pawn structure but
keeping the position intact Queen H4 no
C4 not allowing the Knight to fall back
to F6 Robert now if you take on F5 after
Knight F5 she takes F5 again F6 is a big
threat and you don't have the
opportunity
you do to go Knight F6 because the queen
on A4 is hanging can we just show that
you know what's funny is I watched your
eyes light up because Knight F5 gf5 wait
Knight takes E3 or Pawn F6 to stop F6
Knight takes F6 is Tanya's entire point
that this is checked to the king the
Eagle bar slow to react but there it
goes the queen on A4 is loose so amazing
geometry fantastic full board awareness
from David Anton here and Tanya I saw it
like I saw you but whoa wait a second
yeah I watched it happen
because
a while to understand that and Robin
and full play in Geometry how we light
up with it because it took me a while to
understand that Knight F6 the queen on
A4 is suddenly hanging and David Anton
this is what makes these top players so
strong because they see all these ideas
that exist that are so easy to miss
Knight F5 played has Wesley missed it
Knight F6 is a big threat on the board
okay he falls back with the queen
does he want Rook A6 is he gonna use a
rook lift not to attack but to defend
his King maybe he's banking on that but
this looks oh wait rookie Sixers Knight
C5
and you can't move the Jeep on the h-man
is hanging Queen H4 was a brilliant move
by David Anton yeah and wessie just fell
right into the Trap brings the queen
back to D7 but the geometry is still
good for David attan here and Knight C5
picks up an exchange but you see the Evo
bar not react that was the best move and
that is one of the many things that
makes Wesley so strong is he may have
made some mistakes his position maybe
he's living on the edge a little bit but
Tanya he finds the tough moves even if
it gives material it's the correct one
and I'm struggling to understand what's
so correct about this it's the only move
Robert I get that white was threatening
to set up a mid on the G line and it's
too many weaknesses but after Knight C5
how are you still in the game first
did he decide not to go Knight C5 did he
just go King H2 he went King wait Knight
C5 what is Black's response here
I mean that's a great question
yeah you win an exchange and you still
have an attack on the king side but
Robert King H2
oh he goes Queen d8 and maybe this is
what he wanted after Knight C5 as well
and that was the point of Wesley's
defense Robert we have to show that we
have to show it because after Knight C5
just quickly Queen d8 and yes you pick
up the Rook on A6 but you will lose that
pawn on F6 Knight F6 is coming up next
regardless of what white plays because
the queen on H4 hangs
wow okay that's now more geometry in
this position white is so clearly better
but I I'm with you that this keeps black
in the game White's King isn't perfectly
safe either so that was a good defensive
try from Wesley but he doesn't even need
to play defense anymore after King H2
Queen comes at d8 Suddenly It's black
who has the upper hand and what do you
even do here because Knight takes F6 is
a move you can pretty much pre-move
and let's just point out king H2 was not
without idea given one more move Rook G1
and it's busted for black black would
lose the position on the spot Queen d8
very well could have been the only
resource that Wesley had because now
Rook G1 is met with black picking up
that F6 Pawn with three pieces attacking
it it doesn't matter that the G7 Pawn is
pinned Rook G1 is not an option Knight
F6 is coming up next and Robin how the
tables have turned we were talking about
white screen on H4 targeting The Black
Queen on A4 and now with the White Queen
on H4 The Black Queen on d8 it's black
targeting white screen
yeah chess is beautiful like that and
I'm wondering so I'm gonna cheat I mean
usually we just have the evil bar I'm
gonna see what the move is how is white
staying in this game you're not gonna
believe it but it's actually that's this
is not it it's not Queen G3 you're gonna
see the evil bar go down but the move
that was necessary this is actually so
awesome Rook A1 move that no human would
ever consider here but the point is that
when F6 is captured a bunch of times you
need to take back with everything and
then once these Queens are traded Rook
takes A5 at the end and this is one of
Black's extra pawns it's not gonna be
enough objectively speaking to win the
game so Rook a one the only move to keep
white in the game but Queen G3 taking on
E5 that seems pretty normal to my eyes
but you see the eval bar saying now
black is winning
unbelievable we're okay one good luck
five that even classical game it's the
kind of move that's not even on your
radar to bring the Rook to the other
line the edge of the board when all the
action is on the king side and we see
that moves have been blitzed at and
after all of that Wesley ends up with an
extra pawn and a safer King
and Wesley can decide what pieces he
wants to trade does he want to trade
Rooks does he want to trade Queens he
has some choices here on what pieces are
coming off the board but I love this
bring the second Rook to the party with
Rook E6 so Wesley looks he's going to
win are there any other players that
need a result to try to jump into the
top eight
well we do have amitaba to buy against
Laura fresenet and I think the players
there also in a must-win situation to
get their chance to go into the playoff
and we're seeing an end game in that one
do you want to do a quick look at that
because there's been a big mistake
by Laura
okay King is the king could have gone
this way and dropped F2 but the king is
on F1 but black is up a pawn and this
bishop is trapped so B2 next looks like
it is quite nasty and devastating and I
think White's completely Frozen Tonya
there's just no move to make don't play
Rook C1 because the bishop does stop
that square and does not allow you to
promote that would be bad but can't
black just move the king and just run
this way
wow so you're saying that now black has
all the Time in the World to get the
king to the party because white can't
move the Bishop from A3 Rook C1 comes in
uh The Rook from B1 can't really go
anywhere because white black gets Bishop
D2 bishop c1n and the King can go to F3
but that's about it there's no more
progress you can't move the E Pawn you
can maybe trade the Jeep on but you lose
F2 basically whites in a practical Zug
Swang here every move is just worsening
the position you've got to you've got to
just keep waiting
and Black's got all the plans in the
position does he want to even go E5
Maybe
yeah probably and the game is over it
was resignation because white has no
moves and so let's get away from here I
see that Lavon panzulia is taking on Yu
Yang Yi and this looks wow just
completely
winning for white it's even material but
all the pawns are weak and that's a Pawn
on B6 it's hanging maybe winning is a
strong term at this point but it does
look like black can hardly do a thing
it's a good night versus a bad Bishop
end game this is a proper example of
that a white knight is dominating the
black Bishop all of black spawns are
hindering The Bishop's activity and with
that he does win the B6 pawn and will
have a free hand of creating a passer at
the right moment on the queen side
you've got to make sure with white you
don't give too much counter play play A3
here make sure that the black rope
doesn't have much activity but Robert it
still requires work to be done because
Rook C1 Rook B1 and wow look at that
Knight E6 and the eval bar doesn't
approve
I'm wondering why that was a mistake and
this bishop get out and this bishop gets
the F3 black suddenly is winning so F6
G5 at some moment might be an idea I
just think it takes a long time because
E6 is loose as well
but it might be in the air and Knight C7
he targets the bishop Now The Rook can
pursue the bishop where where are you
hiding after Rook D6 Rook d8 you've got
Bishop B7
yeah but then there's 98 check I
actually think that this is the winning
on the spot for uh White the geometry we
keep using that word but that's what it
is is very favorable for white because
when The Rook gets the oh whoa that's an
unexpected choice but to quickly show
you because they're in time trouble Rook
D6 forces Bishop C Rook d8 forces Bishop
B7 98 you think you might run with your
king but after King E7 there's Knight
takes B7 and the Knight protects the
Rook which means that to begin with the
king would have to run the other
direction to H6 but that also loses
because Knight D6 hits the bishop hits
F7 with check and the black King's in
trouble so this would have been a very
good decision for ponzola instead we see
a trade and he's better but winning this
will take a lot of effort
and it is
it is white who's going to be pushing
that and Robert this is
the only game for the fight for the top
eight that remains there are some other
boards that are still in action but very
difficult for those players to try to
fight for division one
and players playing on second should we
stick to this one yeah let's do it
Wesley so did win his game and you see
the current standings he's in ninth
place by the tie breaks but that will
change when the round ends so you know
the top three are safe Lavon iterzaga
Magnus they will play in matches to get
into division one but the others who
knows what's gonna happen and this game
could change the standings as well
but now this looks like it's easier for
white with the King going all the way
down the board I don't know if white
wants to commit to B7 because very often
the white king hides on B7 so perhaps
just thought with King E5 a rook F5 yes
you can win the G5 Pawn but it's super
slow after King D6 the white gang is so
close to the pawn from queening you can
just go B7 The Rook will have to go to
B5 you hit the Rook from King C6 and
then free your rook and queen the pawn
and win the game and ponzola does win
the game such an experienced Grandmaster
and there he slides into number 10 so
the standings are not final we will keep
everybody updated on that front but he
has pretty good tie breaks before all
the games conclude
and there are games that are still on
and a lot of exciting ends that are
happening Robert as we speak let's jump
to one of the live games while we wait
for the results to pour in to determine
the players who will be fighting for
division one
okay I don't see games towards the top
there's one as you've received
durability taking on Dennis lazovic and
it looks like lazovic has a queen and
their Rebellion does not so I think
black should be healthily nursing this
advantage to a victory
and as long as that doesn't happen oh
but the F3 Pawn is so weak right now
yeah the king can even walk into F4 and
try to deliver a Checkmate so uh it
seemed like when we first looked at the
position that it was suggesting that oh
it's made it was not made sorry I
thought it was Checkmate but the king
can go back to G3 but at first it said
that it was only Plus or so minus 2.8
which means that there was a potential
Fortress somewhere
that's the feeling that I got was Rook
on D5 but it quickly collapsed with the
F3 weakness that we saw and Robert even
this requires a little bit of work
yeah it's a position where the black
king needs to help the queen and main
one queen queen H2
uh no work
the white Rook was a big help there
walking into self-made Queen H2 and with
that this one is over as well rabbit and
here we see black has an exchange but
that's three extra pawns for exchange if
anyone's pushing it's white and this is
chess.com very good friend the director
of Portuguese content quicker mkhitaryan
you've probably seen him stream and play
in all these events and he is looking to
hold this game now Tanya one thing I'm
looking at A8 Square wrong Bishop so if
this Rook can sacrifice stuff for these
two pawns then the game will end in a
drop easier said than done but I'll keep
it in the back of my mind
and I think everyone should that's such
an important defensive resource in these
positions to know that you can give up
The Rook as long as the a pawn is the
only one alive and that is a draw even
if white has the extra Bishop because
it's the wrong colored Square Robert I
see that eval Bar says this is even but
I would be I wouldn't be so sure of
being able to hold this position with
white with the bishop and the King
assisting the two pawns on the queen
side to March up the board I wonder how
easy of a hold this really is you can't
play A5 because the Rook takes B5 the
pawn dropped earlier and it seems that
actually if this the game is uh
happening very quickly but as uh we're
gonna see a rook is gonna sacrifice
itself for a pawn and then it's going to
be a draw
and that's the idea that you mentioned
Robert that's exactly what you were
talking about that the a pawn is of
wrong color and we see this one has
ended Robert the prophet
so this happened and wow this means that
around
eight round nine has come to an end I
don't think we've got any more live
games
okay so I mean we'll listen to word from
our team behind the scenes but we'll
wait for the exact final standings
because they sometimes shake up at the
last minute with some results on board
55 but if all games are done I'm
wondering if these are our final
standings and we know our top eight
yeah we're gonna find that but there are
three players who are on Seven Points
Robert and they are definitely in into
the top eight and that's levonaroni and
Magnus Carlsen and itri Saga now there
are a bunch of players on six and a half
points and a lot of them in fact
starting from fourth up till 16 they all
have six and a half points but only five
of them will be fighting it out for
division one
you know it's one of those moments where
I don't want to say I told you so but
for the people who are making quick
draws maybe you should have tried to
play because you would have had a good
chance to try to make your way to
division one instead for those people
who took quick draws and don't make the
top eight they'll be fighting to make it
into division two
and with the match play coming up this
is what the players are fighting for the
top 72 will go through into match play
20 will be eliminated at the end it will
be four players at after match play who
will advance to division one 16 players
will fight it out in division two of the
aim chess rapid and 32 players will make
it to division three all these three
divisions there's big prize money at
stake there's also tour points on the
line the four players who make it to
division one will play alongside not a
backup to satro Fabiano caruana Jordan
van forest and Vladimir Fellowship AKA
The Big Fish aka the guy who's been
winning everything that he plays on uh
lion chess here Robert it's so much to
fight for in the match play yeah Federal
save is the pro chess League MVP he led
the Gotham Knights of the protest league
title he is super strong he won division
two at the Jessica cup so you gotta give
a shout out to our friend of chess.com
Vladimir ferrosev who has been a star in
on the online format but I want to say
one thing I know we don't know everybody
in just yet we'll announce that shortly
I think the player that that'll say of
Abdus atar of Jordan Von forest and 500
do not want to see in division one is
Magnus Carlson so they're hoping that no
matter who Magnus picks they can rise
the occasion and knock him out and send
him a division two
I think secretly they're also pleased
that Hikaru did not show up to this
party today because definitely having
Hikaru and Magnus make it through to
division one it gets super tricky for
the other guys and Robert we are about
to reveal our top eight players who have
made it into the match play to fight for
division one and here they are
lebanaroni and Marcus Carlson
etorizaga and Amitabha tabai The Finnish
top four and then we see Ivan sarich on
the left side alongside FFL garakamski
Parham Max sudlu and Wesley so Robert is
not just about finishing and top eight
but there is a big Advantage for the
players who finish on the left side of
this ranking system that's the top four
yeah I'll give one player from the left
a disadvantage because the top four get
to choose their opponents for amitaba to
buy we know who he's playing he's gonna
play Wesley so I would I think bet
everything on that pairing but then the
question Tanya is is Lavon going to pick
Yvonne sarich because Yvonne I think is
the lowest rated player along with gotta
komski from the bunch on the right hand
side but I think Lavon he was you know
he knows got it very well they played
many games does he respect the FFL the
legend or to say you know rapid chess
online isn't so much his thing sometimes
if I can get him to time travel I could
take him down so Tanya I don't know what
matchups will see besides I mean tablet
to buy against Wesley so
such a tough one for the players to pick
and I'm gonna make a prediction I think
Levon will pick Parham and then Magnus
uh will pick Yvonne sarit and it will be
between kamski and Wesley so for the
other two players it's a toss-up who
picks who in this upcoming match play
and of course we've got our topic we've
got the top 72 who made it into the
fight but that's just the job half done
we are about to start the match play for
the planes of the aim chess rapid we
will be back with all the action on the
other side of this break
[Music]
thank you
seriously
[Music]
check me
angels is an intelligent system that
analyzes your game prevents mistakes and
helps recommendations for improving your
skill
laughs
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we are about to lift off the match
player for the planes of the M chess a
rapid it is going to be a big big fights
for that division one rabbit exciting
chess in the Swiss we saw Magnus lose in
round two he eventually finished second
a lot of turnarounds and some new names
in the mix as well yeah we are going to
have some exciting matches the top four
got to pick their choice opponent
between numbers five and eight and those
are not the only matches taking place
there will be matches to see who gets in
division two and division three so it's
a super exciting time and stressful time
for many of these chess players
yes especially those who are waiting to
be picked to play at our opposition in
that fight with division one but first
let's talk about the format of the match
play that we are going to be witnessing
now it is completely different from the
Swiss as the players play a best of two
match they're gonna have 10 minutes on
the clock with a two second increment
it's the best of two match so you win
the match if you score one and a half
points or two points in case of a tire
in case of one one we will have an
Armageddon between the players and uh of
course the big twist in this season is
that the top four select their opponent
from uh the bottom four who finished in
the Swiss uh planes Robert those who
finish from five to eight and what are
you expecting there we were discussing
this
It's tricky to decide because you pick a
player Robert and then what if you lose
to them we've seen that happen and that
can get so tricky yeah that probably
crushes your you know feelings in
addition to your hopes and dreams of
making it into division one but it's
difficult because every player who
finishes in the top eight is super
strong now some players are super Grand
Masters and you probably don't want to
pick them as your opponent and well
others you're just like uh you close
your eyes and you just say I point my
finger to that person that's who I'm
playing
yeah it's a lot of pressure for the
players who do pick their opponents for
uh the match play and of course the
pressure comes along with having to
prove your decision of picking them and
let's take a look as we reveal the match
play pairings for division one and this
is what the top four went with Levon
aronian
decides to play against gatakamski he's
the one who got the first pick left he
goes with kamski Magnus picks Ivan
sarich as his opponent meanwhile
iterizaga left with Parham maksudlu and
Wesley Seoul decides to go with farham
and Amanda by left to play Wesley so
Robert two different storylines here for
Amin tabatabai he finished in top four
but it's kind of heartbreaking for him
that he's got to play the strongest
player in the mix he's up against Wesley
and for Parham what do you think about
his match against Eduardo yeah I think
that Parham is probably the happiest of
the people who finished five to eight
Edward charizaga is a beast in the
protest League he won nine games Drew
four lost zero against very strong
opposition so eternizaga he is not just
an underdog that you can count out he
has good chances but I have to say it
was fun to see godakovski laughing when
Levon aronian chose him so he was the
first pick you know when you're back in
recess as a kid and you're picking teams
and you're like oh that's the person I
want to face or that's the last person
that's going to be picked for a team
kopsky is a monster but when Lavon aroni
has the choice of komsky sarich maksudu
so you just have to pick a very strong
opponent and he had limited Choice he
chose gotta and gotta is gonna give him
everything that he can handle
yeah and Lavon did not lose a single
game in the Swiss potion his chest today
has been from another planet he picks
kamsky as his opponent in the match play
and it's gonna be a fun one and Robin
what do you think is the strategy here
when you decide to play against an
opponent is it based on past results is
it based on Styles how do you think the
players come to this conclusion
I think it's based on Styles when you
take away the rating differential like
you're not gonna pick Wesley so he's the
best player of the bunch there's no
that's not a debate everybody knows that
that's okay but when you look at the
others you're kind of like who do I
match up well against I think Magnus
wanted to play komsky I mentioned this
to you during the break but people
aren't familiar with you know the chess
history may not know that godakonsi
delivered a very painful loss to Magnus
Carlson in 2007 we're dialing back the
clock well before Magnus world champion
this was the World Cup semi-finals where
Magnus he was having a breakout
tournament he was very successful and
then got it comes he says hold hold up
slow down Young fella it's my time to
shine and Gutta compsey came out of
retirement not long before that won the
World Cup beating Alexi shirov in the
final there so I think that Magus wanted
to play komsky he doesn't get his wish
instead he'll play Yvonne sarage oof and
that is because lemon picked kamski to
fight against and those of you were just
joining us and wondering why I do at the
top four get their pick it is because
they finish in the top four of uh in the
fight for division one and that's the
big Edge that's the big Advantage where
they get to choose their opponent from
those who finish from fifth to eighth in
the ranking and Robert I believe
we are about to lift off the games
should be starting any moment and once
again a completely different format it
will be your best of two it is a match
play
this is gonna be fun get ready chat
and I think that you know on the topic
of Revenge there's plenty of it uh at
stake here and I mentioned how Carlson
probably wanted to beat compsky in a
match I think he would like to take down
Sarge as well if my memory serves me
correctly Sarge beat him in the grand
Chester and I also think that Sarge beat
him at the Olympiad many years ago so
Magnus and he's going to want to take
down Sarge for sure
absolutely and that's what they need to
do to book their spot into division one
of the aim chess rapid and Robert I
think we've got action
okay well we're talking about magnets
we're talking about revenge uh he's
taking on Yvonne sarich but we also have
uh Lavon aronian taking on gotta komsky
so which match would you like to start
with I guess Magnus is hard to pass up
on so let's let's go there
let's do it let's bring that up and look
at that that looks like a a rosalimar in
a sicilian but white has already got a
pawn down to A5 it's not a very familiar
position for me Robert what can you tell
us about this opening yeah I actually
have played the white side of this since
childhood uh you played Bishop B5 check
on move three and black block with the
Knight but you see this Pawn on B6 uh so
that pawn is going to be recaptured by
one of Black's pieces not going anywhere
so there's no rush to take it but this
opponent A6 is what Magnus is claiming
is a disadvantage for black it's a
long-term weakness it's isolated so
Magnus has the healthier Pawn structure
because he has one Pawn Island where
black has this I said Pawn on the a-file
Robin we're seeing that the players are
blitzing out their moves which means
that they too are familiar with this
opening now black has delayed the
recapture of the b-pawn first develops
the bishop to B7 because the B Pawn is
not going anywhere and eventually we'll
decide whether you want to pick it up
with a knight or the queen both options
tempting I like this approach I like
Bishop B7 targeting that E4 Pawn Robert
but even from Black's perspective it
looks like things will be under control
you will be able to get play along the B
file Queen B6 Rook B8 some ideas to
fight for on the queen side
yeah no I mean black is trying gonna try
to stabilize on the queen side uh White
is just gonna keep putting pressure and
I like the way Magnus is handling this
you see that Rook on A2 what a clever
little move where he wants to push his
Pawn to B3 but doesn't want to have a
problem Down The Long diagonal so Magnus
you know he does it that's his thing he
comes up with these clever little moves
in the opening stage but I think it's
principal chess it's good chess and yeah
I like magnus's position and he's also
the number one rated player on the
planet
foreign
yeah not the world champion currently
but he is at the number one rated player
in the world and right now he is up
against Evan sarich in the fight for
division one of the game chess rapid as
are the other players let's take a look
on some of the other action that we're
seeing uh just a quick look that I had
in the Levon kamsky match the Queens are
off the board in that one already but
it's still everything to play for and
Robert which game catches your attention
where do you want to jump to First well
you just brought up this Lavon game
against komsky so now I'm looking at
anything okay the Queens are gone black
has these three Pawn Islands white only
has two White's also missing I don't I'm
not missing like sacrifice but traded
off an H Pawn for an f-pawn for black so
it's interesting to note these Dynamics
telling you that we just don't have a
symmetrical structure uh it's not easy
to wrap my head around this position and
in addition the position I haven't seen
Lavon aronia down almost it on clock all
day
oh we're gonna get the board
Oscar game but right now let's take a
look at wow we're back to Magnus and
Ivan sarich as we wait for that
Robert B3 has been played making
intentions clear what white wants is to
franch out of the bishop on the queen
side Bishop B2 coming in next The Rook
on A2 looks odd but it's nicely placed
to plan some kind of doubling up on the
a file we had a look at that one we will
jump back to it
soon but let's get an update on the Love
on board
okay so we're jumping around a bit there
are four games underway at the same time
so
uh you see that this game is not the one
between Magnus and stars it's still the
Levon game against komsky interesting
Dynamic there
um you know all four matches at the same
time Tanya it's a lot to juggle and the
players they can't care about anybody
else their focused strictly on their own
games their own positions
exactly what they need to do
is it
here as well
as well at this Bond structure which
really it does impact blacks Bishops
activity on B7 the H file is open blacks
Rook defending the 87 Pawn the king's
still in the center I do like a White's
position it might not be much but it
feels with just two Pawn islands versus
black strip on Islands less weaknesses
for white in more general terms white
has got a slight Advantage a slight pull
here yes in the game between aronian and
compsy slight Edge for white but it's
going to be a long game so we'll have to
see how this one continues and I mean
whose style do you think it fits more
commsky or Lavon that's a great question
I mean what we know of Levon is his
creativity right his originality in
openings and middle games and I think
kamski can't be too displeased that the
Queens are off the board and it's
simplified but the work isn't over it's
still an end game with pressure and
we've seen Levon create masterpieces in
the end games as well we will come back
to that one let's jump
back into the Magnus board I believe
this is not the left board
yeah we are having technical
difficulties everyone's are just to be
transparent some things are going awry
but we will try to catch everybody up on
what's Happening as soon as we can so
akovsky and Lavon they're still playing
not this game this is not their game
this is the one between Magnus Carlson
and Yvonne sarich
we're having a lot
Robert
o got my eyes on the other
to match-ups as well
and fun stuff going on in that one but I
think
we are facing some technical
difficulties we will come back with the
chess action wow
Robert just two games which also means
there's no margin for error for the
players no there isn't uh unfortunately
for the players if you lose a game it's
gonna be hard to bounce back some people
do win on demand so it is possible but
if you are someone like Yvonne Suraj you
don't want to lose game one to Magnus
Carlsen very few people defeat Magnus
now I know A lot's been said how Magnus
didn't win a classical game in Norway
chess this and that I mean let's be real
you lose a game to Magnus the two-game
match chances are not very high so uh
yeah we'll see these matches and when we
have everything restarted just being
transparent with everybody there are
some issues that we are working through
but as soon as everything is back up
we'll gladly Dive Right Back in the
chest
and before that happens Robert you know
I love putting you on a spot so I'm
gonna do it we've often seen in these
planes that the players who finish in
top four sometimes they're the ones who
qualify and make it to division one but
we've also seen a couple of times that
there have been switch-ups and the
players who they've been paired against
are the ones who actually win the match
play and go on to fight in division one
what are you expecting from today do you
think we're gonna see some turnarounds
or do you see the top four making it to
division one oh well Wesley so is one of
the people who were not in the top four
so I feel like we will not see the top
four just make it through uh you know
you do well in the Swiss doesn't mean
that you're gonna have the easiest
matchup you do get to choose that's the
good thing but for a mean tablet to buy
for example he was forced to play Wesley
that was the last person remaining and
it wasn't happy to see that he was like
couldn't you please leave Robert Hess
there so I could play that guy no you're
gonna play Wesley so one of the best
players on the planet someone has won
the grand chess tour the Fisher random
world championship and speaking of world
champions he may no longer be officially
the world champion in classical chess uh
Magnus Carlson he has nearly a three
minute lead in The Clock he's brought
his Bishop to B2 he's still staring down
at the A6 Pawn at some point but for now
his Rook went to B2 it can slide back to
A2 another Rook to A1 I don't know I
just hate these positions on the black
side
yeah it's a long-term A6 weakness that
black has to fight which is gonna tie
down the pieces and meanwhile you look
at White's Camp right it's such an
intact Pawn structure there are no
weaknesses here in magnus's position for
a black to strike at so he's got to
start looking for counter measures for
counter play not going to be easy to
find Robert we were talking about Amanda
by his tough task against Wesley so it
was unfortunate that he finished fourth
did not have an option did not have a
chance of course the none of the other
three wanted to pick Wesley as an
opponent um had to face Wesley but I'm
looking at that position and right out
of the opening it looks like Wesley is
in trouble in their first game okay so
let's try to check that one out between
Wesley so and I mean table Dubai we keep
talking about how Wesley I mean he is a
beast we know how strong he is and this
is the game between taba tabai and
Wesley so where what's the material
count isn't white just up a pawn here
up upon Black's got the bishop pair the
Queens are off the board and look at
that Queen side you got a three versus
one that's a two past Pawn majority
there if anyone's pushing it's Amanda by
Black's got a tough toss in the fan yes
he wins the B2 Pawn but Robert that King
is still in the center white can hit
that Bishop on B2 and plant that Bishop
on D6 also get the pawn on C7 this is a
lot of pressure for amen it's a big
moment right now for him because Rook C2
keeping your Rook behind the past Pawn
that seems like the advice you always
received and he plays it but I was about
to say that feels inaccurate to me
because as you putting out Tanya the
bishop could go to D6 stopping Black and
castling I want my Rook on B7 and he
could have accomplished that by playing
Rook B1 Rook B7 the C Pawn it's going to
push up the board whether Rook is behind
it or not at the end you'd like to be in
contact with your Bishop but Bishop D6
here and but maybe this black king if it
gets to C6 I don't even see this game
turn around
um
and imagine spend time because you want
to play C6 right now get that pawn on C7
but that gives black the chance and the
opportunity to go E5 and Noma Bishop D6
and if you go C7 Black's King simply
steps up to D7 and in fact the C pod
just falls off the board so c6e5 is not
something that you want to allow and
Robert if you go Bishop D6 then black
does get the time Wesley does get the
time for the King march planting it on
C6 because after King D7 it also targets
the bishop on D6 no time for C6 yeah
although there are some tactics that we
need to keep looking at for like Rook D1
ideas the king will be out in the open
so I know I was thinking that a king
runs a C6 I'm not quite sure it's in
time so it's a big moment here for these
players and you can sense the moment
from a man who does Play Bishop D6 he
realizes that Rook D1 will be the
follow-up after King to D7 so what else
can black do here E5 might be made by F4
just trying to pry open the position for
the Rooks so Tanya I am struggling to
see a big idea for black
that's a really good point that you make
because if black was able to get the
king to see makes all problems solved
but because of tactics King D7 Rook D1
and maybe Robert we can just quickly
show that the problem after that is that
with the pieces lined up on the D file
now if you go E5 there's Bishop takes E5
and everything falls into place white
just wins the game on the spot so after
Rook D1 it would actually be big big
trouble uh for black starts with E5 and
now the big move that you were talking
about F4 and I'm just wondering if
Wesley plans to try and keep the center
intact with something like F6 because if
you take on F4 opening up the E line
that looks like it's asking for trouble
instead oh my God I'm in tabatabai goes
for C6 and that's not approved maybe
Castle's Queen side that's such a hard
move to see in advance but the Rook hits
the bishop the bishop has to retreat
somewhere and the King can go up to C7
he finds it Wesley so given a chance he
does not miss moves like that very often
and now his King can slide up to C7 the
bishop can drop back to B6 if there's
ever a check this is starting to look
promising for Wesley
and this is exactly what makes Wesley
such a beast in these formats he's super
difficult to beat but if he's given the
slightest of opportunities he bounces on
them and makes the most of it and he
doesn't burn the clock too much while
doing that long Castle Robert for a lot
of us it might even feel like wait a
second was that movie even legal it's so
easy to forget that it even exists in
this position but of course Wesley he
immediately spots and he immediately
plays it and I think you're absolutely
right that for amitaba tabai it was not
on his radar he just completely forgot
about the option that Black's King gets
to see it a really key Square also hits
the bishop on D6 and suddenly you see
all the Harmony in a Black's camp and
the C6 Pawn is super weak and White's
best move is pawned back to C5 to keep
the bishop defended and then play Rook
to B1 that's the problem with pushing
pawns too quickly you're told Advance
your past pawns but then you do it
you're like wait why is this not working
out for me and in all seriousness a
protected Bishop on D6 is probably more
valuable than having a Pawn on C6 just
yet and you see The Rook come to D5
right now he wants activity his Rook
wants to get to B5 to stop white from
getting to the file maybe white wants
Rook to B1 but there are ideas like
Bishop B6 and King to C7 this Pawn on C6
it actually may be in more trouble than
it is a strength so I'm really liking
the way Wesley has played as you said
Castle queenside not on a means radar
his pawns are worse on the king side he
has isolated pawns on the queen side as
well this is looking like a good
opportunity for Wesley so
really nice play there last couple
by Wesley and
with takes control of the A5 Square as
well so when the king falls back to C7
Falls forward to C7 you don't have the
option as white to go Bishop B4 Bishop
A5 checks everything under control it
looks like trouble is over for Wesley so
so we take this moment to zoom out and
take a look at our other boards Robert
action is on the fight for the top four
spots
for division one is on and wow Magnus
against
sorry I pulled up the game between
iterizaga and para maksudu first just
because we haven't seen that game yet
and to my eyes at first glance it looks
like white has a promising position with
a rook on the open file a rook sliding
to the next open file and then I look at
the eval bar and says yeah you're a full
Robert the position is better for black
and it's probably because of a move like
Bishop C5 trying to get the Knight up
there and it seems like the pawn on A4
is a nice uh just a problem for white
and a good Advantage app for black
controlling two pawns with just one
yeah I love it I love the idea of
trading off the strong Bishop on B6 and
once the Knight is out of the way
Black's C8 Bishop can also find itself
into the attack let's not forget the F4
Pawn creates a lot of threats in the
position uh you always have the idea of
cramping down white with F3 trading on
G3 the tender spot of F2 I do like
parham's position here Robert he starts
with the attack on that Bishop on B6
another really good approach because now
white is forced to give up the bishop
pair black and take on D4 plant that
Bishop on C5 and start targeting the F2
Pawn I love it Bishop C5 or Bishop F6
depending on which Pawn you want to
Target you have your options you will
have the two Bishops Advantage which it
is in this open position so I like the
chances for para maxilla but you
mentioned Magnus Carlson so hey why not
why don't we jump back over there I'm
guessing it's an interesting position so
we'll see you later Eduardo and Parham
but right now let's go over to Magnus
and you
this is an open position exactly both
Kings
and that's a big question right whose
King is more safe here and it's a tough
one to answer because yes Black's got
the King on h8 but white has got these
ideas of Rook A7 and if the queen finds
it where the 87 Pawn is super weak which
means Black's Queen is tied down to
stopping uh White Queen from jumping on
to H4 unfortunately for black he can't
double up on the G line notice that
Bishop on C4 it not only puts Black's
King on the Killzone but controls a very
important G8 Square I just don't see
black being able to create threats on
White's King meanwhile white cans start
looking at ways of going Rook A7 and
eventually also trying to get that
Bishop from E6 to F5 start targeting the
H5 Pawn there are a lot of ideas in the
position which can create trouble for
black skiing I like the look of that
because this Rook needs to make a
decision if it stays in the C file then
there could be a back rank issue at some
point to worry about and I guess if you
leave the C file you'll peace what's up
yeah I was just you know while you were
talking you would talk I was like wait a
second
Defender the bishop and ce6 and my point
was the brilliant idea I had was to go
rookate and Rook gate till I realized
that the bishop and C6 does a good job
of Defending it so please carry on no no
that's actually really instructive
because if this Rook leaves the back
rank as you're saying The Rook does need
one more Tempo because you dropped the
Rook on A8 but it's something to keep in
mind because it might be a queen Landing
there at some point if the White Queen
can get active but that just means that
Bishop E6 tactically is not that big of
an issue for black just yet and black is
down a pawn has definite compensation on
the king side some activity and look at
the clock magnets was up two minutes now
it's cut in half so he needs to find a
move and it's showing it's not an easy
position
it looks like white Squad every
[Music]
problem in magnus's campus the queen on
E1 is stuck guarding black screen from
giving a check on E3 or giving a check
on C1 and an eight six there is the
geometry of a repetition which checks
along the diagonal and that's what makes
it so difficult to get the queen into
the game Magnus does make a move he goes
Rook B6 and now there's a huge threat on
the board the one that we're talking
about if it's white to play White wins
with Bishop E6 Rook C7 Rook B8 Rook G8
check winning the queen winning the game
wow so he wants to play Tanya's idea and
he says couldn't do it just yet let me
play a slow movement Bishop E6 is still
tempting but the king is the H7 Square
so Sarge he said oh I understand what
Magnus wants I'm not going to give it to
him and the King will be safe enough on
H6 if it needs to run up the board
this looks so scary for black and he
does with Magnus he keeps all the
threats on the board goes with the King
a move to H2 this is a classic typical
Magnus move I don't know how many times
you've seen him play this today and we
saw a question mark to that move it's
not an accurate one
black trying to create counter play
White hits that Rook you've got to go
Rook C7
apparently that was what happened there
wait what could black have done instead
your Rook was under attack maybe there
was Rook E8 to go after this bishop but
Rook C7 for some reason is an error it
must be related to Rook B8 check because
otherwise you know what's the big deal
King H7
Bishop Bishop F5
King goes up to age six I mean this king
is just about to run away maybe there's
King H3 and he plays it I was wondering
about it he's just trying to win the
pawn
oh wow
and you don't have Rook H7 because Rook
B8 you've taken the A7 Square so Queen
H4 is a threat it is a cross on the boat
for King H3 but it does have a big idea
Robert are winning the pawn and it's not
an easy threat to counter right now I'm
actually trying to find a move for black
and
yeah it's not easy yeah I'm gonna reject
this Miss I don't care if it's somehow
not the most objectively strong move
whatever it's a good move it has a great
plan behind it and I'm guessing that
black has some move to survive but you
have 10 seconds remaining and now it's
under 10 seconds and I don't think sarge
is gonna find it
on the five seconds now good luck
finding it's such a great practical
choice and an immediate mistake there we
see Queen D has been played and perhaps
Magnus can just simply pick up the H4
pawn queen H4 Rook it seven actually now
is a reality because Rook B8 doesn't
work anymore so Queen d8 not without
idea I think the bishop should slide
back to F5 first take away the H7 Square
so you are ready to play Queen takes H
for next Magnus does that Sarge has no
time he's also down one and about to be
two Pawns
okay Queen H4 looks strong but C2 is
loose at the end
the D6 Falls as well does he want to
trade Queens right now with Queen H4 you
can't pick up rook the D6 Pawn you've
got to be careful with that because
there was a trick with Bishop F5 winning
the rook and we see this ending being
played out D6 will fall and the G and
the F Pawn along with the King just feel
extremely strong white can start with
King G5 and also set up some mating
ideas against black skin I love King g5s
as mate King G6 and Rook bass Checkmate
Unstoppable good idea Tanya and that is
that
wow and with that Magnus wins a game one
just needs a draw in game two to qualify
to re-on his party in the Champions
chastor division one uh wow Evan sarich
will start with the white pieces so
that's the good news for him
Robert
we've got action on on the other games
let's quickly take a look at
okay we have what's going on we levada
komsky drew their first game that's good
news Regatta he had the black pieces he
was selected by Lavon who had the first
overall pick and well maybe that
selection it could backfire so gotta
laughed and he may have the last laugh
if with the white pieces he can do some
damage to Levon but this is Wesley so up
upon Tanya at the start when we first
looked he was down upon and it looked
like white in a runaway passer now
there's a king in the center and black
is up a pawn but somehow the evil bar is
saying it's still within drawing
territory perhaps because the white king
is so active
the whites King is Super Active the
white Rook is really active on tying
down Black's Rook to F7 to defend the A7
the big decision for white is do you
want to put your Pawn on F4 or do you
want to keep it on F3 and indeed I'm in
Tabata by for the time being decides to
play F3 because black doesn't have time
to push his own F Pawn white can slide
in with the Rook give a check on e4 and
win that pawn and eventually white does
get the pawn into F4 I just don't see a
way for black to make progress with the
A7 weakness and more pawns getting
traded after H5 what Wesley wants is the
king B5 Pawn A5 just like start pushing
the a pawn because white is just going
out for these black pawns that's true
but if I can get this Pawn up the board
maybe at some moment I'll give up a king
Side Pawn to try to get A2 but look at
this right check yeah it's an immediate
threat but he does go A5
and narrow D5 is a real threat because
F5 is hanging and after King C5 I think
we're gonna see a repetition the A5 Pawn
is attacked you've got to come back with
the king the Ripple slide back again
threatening a check the king comes back
and I think this will end in a draw
right here right now yeah no need to
risk it if you're Western the black
pieces he plays A4 he reals he's not
risking all that much the check the king
comes up to B4 you will win F5 but then
you both have to start calculating who
is actually having the better chances
here with the black king entering and
attacking the white pony too
and it's a big decision to take with
just 10 seconds on the clock so a nice
practical try there by obesity and in
fact I'm in tabatabai says he's not
going in for that line he stops the move
King before Rook D5 is still coming in
with the check but it means one more
move for black he'll have to go King C4
King B3 also there's a big threat of
just going Rook before and not allowing
black to do any of this stuff Robert
yeah Rook check Rook back great find by
me and Savage with just seconds on his
clock he's just saying the King has to
say to the A4 Pawn now if I go over D5
check your King has to go back up uh
Rank and he doesn't want that the game
is officially a draw well played by both
these players very precise stuff there
and Robert the other board with the
rizaga who decided to play again sparha
Maxwell Parham won the first game with
the black pieces he takes down eturizaga
which means that a Parham just needs a
draw to make it into division one of the
aim chess rapid wow that means game one
is down in the books
it is indeed and we see the scores here
levada ronian was held to a draw by
gotakomski the other players Magnus
Carlsen Hara maksudu they're the happy
campers and I mean tempted to buy
Westies I think both of them are unhappy
because Amin was better at the opening
and then Wesley was up upon at some
point but he couldn't find a win
or maybe both of them are happy it's the
glass half full half empty situation
Robin and I think it does come down to
this to this final
riff after that the scores are tied as
well we might even be seeing some
armageddon's but meanwhile
meanwhile Ivan sarich and iterizaga have
to win on demand to force an Armageddon
not an easy task when you're playing
against Magnus no and normally I would
say beating Magnus is the most difficult
thing that can happen but he turns out
actually is the black pieces against
Parham so I'm not sure would I rather
have white against Magnus or black
against Parham when I need to win Yvonne
Sarge has defeated Magnus Carlson before
he beat him in the 2014 Olympiad he also
beat him in the grand chess Tour event
it was I think I don't remember his
Rapid or Blitz but he beat him in one of
the events in Croatia so he's done it
before he has a chance but you're down a
point you need to win from move one it's
not comfortable
not at all and he starts with the white
pieces that's the good news for Evan
sarage and Magnus we've got uh goes with
the Spanish setup here H3 has been
played and of course there are different
ways for black to continue here you can
try with Knight A5 C5 ideas or first
developed a bishop on C8 there are of
course also plans with the Nitra
treating to be it eventually rewrite
routing to D7 so a lot of different
structures and the reason that Magnus
has slowed down here is because he's
deciding what will be his middle game
approach here
yeah he has many options he's played
this position many times with both
colors so if sarich wants to force a
draw like Levon did in that Marshall
it's not a martial anymore but
regardless Magnus is happy to force a
draw it means he makes it through to
division one so the players are just
rerouting their Knights this is going to
be a slower Affair or any of the other
games whoa yes Robert I think we
immediately have to move on to the Gaga
kamski Love on our own in it's absolute
Insanity on that board and we're gonna
pull that up
what is losing a rook on A1
but that's Bishop C4 threatening a mate
in one on F7 I have no idea what's
Happening Here Queen D5
can we just what happens after Queenie
yeah I'm just gonna see how we got here
because it was a London system and I
told you this gotta compsky's been
playing the London since most people in
chat have were born so let's just start
with that he is very experienced and
Bishop F5 a distraction a deflection
tactic but it's wrong and got a copy
says yep I'll take that and you could
have B2 you could have my rook in the
corner but I'm gonna take on D5 and look
at Levon play Knight to F6 so he doesn't
even take the Rook I guess what would
have happened after Queen takes A1 is
there like a
you can't take on C4 because the Knight
on B1 is hanging you've got to First
defend that Knight on B1 yeah with Queen
B5 and then take on C4
yeah and black screen on A1 is just
horribly placed in fact there's no way
to defend B7 once B7 Falls there will be
more material that will fall and I think
that was the trap in the position Robert
nice find there by You Queen B5 is the
idea of course Levon when he walks into
a line like Bishop F5 he's got to know
what he's doing you don't just sacrifice
that Bishop on F5 unless you're familiar
with these ideas he plays Knight F6 and
now the big question where do you move
the queen because I don't see a good way
you can pick up the C4 Pawn as you're
pointing out you're still up a piece and
I'm just wondering if black continues to
delay picking up that Rook on A1 maybe
Knight E4 threatening that pawn on F2
hmm oh he doesn't he goes Queen takes a
one I think Lavon doesn't know this
opening I think he got completely uh
caught he made a quick move and the F5
Square unfortunately Fabiano caruana
made a mistake in Norway chess in that
last round against akara Nakamura by
playing a pawn to F5 in a critical
position here Queen to B3 you defend
your knight you attack B7 and if black
ever castles Queen side you're walking
into fire like you probably will get
checkmated in the near future and your
queen is trapped in the corner this
queen on A1 is not getting out of there
even if the queen just calmly goes back
to C2
problems everywhere for black so there
are two tempting moves here Queen B5 and
queen B3 I like the idea of Queen V3
because it also defends A2 not only does
it hit B7 but it traps Black's Queen on
A1 but kamski has slowed down and I'm
just wondering if he is considering the
move Queen B5 either ways I don't really
see an option for black instead of long
Castle in that position you can't afford
to drop the B7 Pawn
yeah I don't think so I mean one of the
things to note is the bishop on F4 stops
and you Rook B8 business because
sometimes I just showed this quickly is
you say okay I'll play A6 you'll take on
B7 play Rook B8 you'll take my knight
whatever I'll block it and I'm gonna get
your knight down here and then you
realize that this doesn't work in the
first place because this Rook on B8 was
always hanging so you cannot get away
with this like you would in some other
positions so that's something that's
going to be very important I think that
it makes sure that komsky is ahead in
this position and he is doing the right
thing I think spending time is important
because both these moves look kind of
the same at least to my eyes but I'm
guessing there's some little difference
there
I think it's got to be around this queen
on A1 right Queen B3 just making sure
that black screen doesn't escape and
kamski going into a bit of a tank I
think this is a critical moment it makes
a lot of sense to slow down he does
smell the blood here but he knows he's
got to be precise
and Robert while he takes a thing here
should we zoom out and take a look at
some of the other boards where action is
on right now
all right let's do it so we start with
Magnus and Sarge we just looked at Lavon
and gotta why don't we look and see how
Parham is going because he only needs a
draw and sometimes you play for a draw
and it's not the right way to play the
game because you start thinking in
results oriented terms and now we see in
this position Tanya if I'm it's a good
this is like a dream position from black
I need to win a game my opponent is
saddled with an isolated Pawn wait a
second no no you're not gonna have an
isolated Pawn You're Gonna Lose a pawn
I don't see a way to defend it you've
got two pawns Under Fire the D4 and the
G2 Pawn I have no idea how Parham got
into this mess by now he should have
castled his King a lot of different
moves should have happened but with the
King still stuck in the center if the
rizaga is gonna just end up with an
extra Pawn out of the opening a very
healthy Pawn structure
I am struggling to even find
compensation for white there
question for you Tanya so you're going
to lose a pawn no matter what if you
give up the G2 pawn and get the open
file and try to attack or do you Castle
giving up D4 thinking okay maybe I can
make a draw just down one Pawn I should
have some chances which Pawn would you
give up
I'm gonna be honest before you ask me
this question it wasn't even a question
in my head I thought that you've got to
get your king to safety you go shot
Castle give up the default pawn put the
bishop on E3 try and find activity but
the moment that you mentioned these
ideas that yes you give up G2 but Rook
G1 comes in with a Tempo it opens up the
G line and that could mean that's where
you find your compensation with the
bishop coming on to eight six in some
tactical ideas and param is about to
make his decision he goes with Bishop G5
he does go with the idea of finding that
compensation along the G line watch out
Robert do not get greedy for the D4 pawn
queen D4 runs into the Thematic Bishop
eight seven and winning the queen
exactly that is important to note that
there's a piece in between two pieces on
the same line you get that piece out the
way you win some material there's
treasure at the end and so we see Bishop
G5 played the good news for Parham is
neither player has the eval bar at their
disposal so if they knew was minus 1.7
it seriously would just take this pawn
and move his Bishop back and say I'm
better but he doesn't know that it works
and so Rook G1 can be a follow-up so
sometimes what top players do is they
Bluff a little bit by moving quickly
param took a lot of time to calculate
but I I think that iteriza you know he
could be a little bit scared to play
Bishop G2 but Donna if this was game one
if this was game one he shouldn't take
it maybe but in game two when you need
to win I definitely think he should have
captured
um there's a cross on Knight C6 Robert
but it's so easy to get scared with
these ideas and if you just back up for
just a quick moment I want to show you
something when the Knight is NBA you
capture your thinking in your head
Bishop G2 The Rook comes to G1 that's
Tempo number one the bishop moves away
let's say Bishop B7 the Knight jumps
onto H5 I'm putting threats on G7 you
take my knight on H5 the queen comes on
to H5 the H7 upon is under Fire and we
see the bar slowly does creep up it's so
easy to get terrified of these positions
and I think uh not allowing this gun to
play uh seemed like what iterizaga
wanted unfortunately for him given the
Mad situation he had to play with fire
there now that Knight C6 is on the board
Parham immediately moves back with the
Knight on E2 but that's not an accurate
Choice here
yeah it's a position where he's
defending the D4 Pawn tactically because
of the bishop takes H7 lines uh but I do
think that iterizaga he needs to win the
game so he might take a little bit of
risk and now that he has his position
maybe it's not that big of a deal maybe
he's doing the right thing because he is
better
and I think opening up that g line could
have been a lot of trouble and we know
he loves to play for the initiative he
loves to play for the attack so he would
have really enjoyed and thrived with
Rook G1 Knight H5 ideas that we were
looking at age six the default Pawn is a
long-term weakness and I think Robert
iterizaga has his chances in this game
to come back into the match and force an
Armageddon let's Zuma and continue our
tour around as we've got four big
matches in the fight for division one
where do you want to jump to next well
we haven't looked at Wesley's game
against Amin Tabitha Bai so let's go
from one Iranian player to another and
for tablet to buy he drew with the white
pieces in game one it was shaky from
both players here we see a sicilian so I
recognize the structure here I see an
isolated Pawn on A6 a potential
backwards Pawn on D6 but Tanya I don't
see many Sicilians with a black knight
on E6 like this
it's a cell for the kill and especially
once at night from E6 jumps onto F4 I'm
kind of liking these squares that black
has for the knights with potential
sacrifices on the king side but Robert
of course are eval bar it says Tanya
whatever you're saying is utter nonsense
everything is under control long term
black D6 Pawn is a weakness the A6 Pawn
is a weakness not just that how on Earth
is black ever going to get the heavy
pieces the major pieces into the attack
as long as the queen and the Rook stay
on the queen side there can be no
realistic fire down on the king side
also notice how the white Bishop for
metoo can simply fall back to F1 and
keep everything under control and
guarded so yes Knight F4 looks like a
pretty Knight but there's little that
it's going to do there yeah and I know
that David Howell likes to make fun of
himself a little self-deprecation how he
always has a bishop on E1 but Bishop E1
in some of these positions looks like a
reasonable move opening up the D file
for your pieces so I could see a future
bishop move uh the C2 Pawn is a little
bit loose it may go up to C4 but then
you have to acknowledge your giving up
the D4 Square forever we do see the
Knight come to F4 first by aminan yeah
it's a good move I think Bishop F1 is a
pretty automatic reply
yeah and then later on you can Target
this Knight on F4 but this is going to
be a heated action you can just tell
from these kind of Sicilians and these
positions that things are going to get
exciting meanwhile things are already
exciting in the Ivan sarage versus
Magnus Carlson matchup Yvonne sarage has
to win on demand and Robert he has
created his chances I'm looking at the
position right now we've got it up in
front of us evalbar says Yvonne in
driver's seat and look at those Knights
look at that Knight on F5 the queen from
B3 always eyeing the king side along the
diagonal there are potential sacrifices
as well blacks got to be careful here
and Knight E5 is the choice of Sarge
because this queen is about to slide on
over to G3 that was a nice move I was
trying to figure out a knockout blow on
these squares or a sacrifice but Knight
E5 it puts pressure on F7 it may go to
C6 and get an E7 check at some point you
can trade on D7 perhaps in the future
but Queen G3 is a big idea just
barreling down the G file trying to
exploit the fact that the black king
does not have too many Defenders
and I'm trying to find a way to fight
this idea of Queen G3 and it's not easy
which means that Magnus is forced to
burn the clock and what clock are we
talking about he's down to one minute
and 20 seconds
not good not good at all I think that
Magnus probably has to like say this
with no confidence whatsoever make a
move like Knight to G5 instead
he's giving up an exchange he wants
queen F5 Knight f8 and then play for the
initiative around it
I think it was just too dangerous to
allow a white to continue with the
attack with just a minute on the clock
this is desperation Robert this one
looks like we're gonna have an
Armageddon on our hands if Yvonne sarish
is able to convert this he starts with
the move Knight eight six and now we'll
pick up the exchange this is even nicer
you win upon you destroy the pawn
structure you could see Magnus shaking
his head I think he overlooked Knight
takes H6 check he was trying to keep up
the exchange but he didn't want to give
a pawn as well if you could just give
black another Pawn right and imagine
it's upon G7 your king is healthy you're
feeling okay but now you're feeling
terrible because your king side is open
and you're down in a rook for night and
you're also down upon too much material
too much material and Evans are just now
connects the Rook he's also targeting
the beef upon the White Queen can slide
to F3 keep everything under control and
guarded on the king's side
Queen F3 rookie for Rook G4 ideas come
to mind this is big big trouble Magnus
Carlsen down to about a minute on the
clock wow
Robin was there was Queen F6 the
decisive mistake but things seem to have
gone wrong before that yeah it's one of
those positions where the top players
like no my mistake was before that well
no objectively you're still in his I
don't care what the engine says I
couldn't find moves because I just
didn't have ideas no plans for me so
this King H7 I think we do see a plan
here that there are chances for Magnus
to survive the problem for him is sarich
is up nearly five minutes at this stage
and he's protecting everything if the
time's reversed then we may be talking
about more likely for black to survive
now it's incredibly unlikely
and look at the setup and how compact
everything is what white has done the
Queen the Rooks everything in the center
developed G3 taking making sure there
are no tactics on the king side all
white needs to do is trade off more
pieces don't go King G2 trying to defend
everything because the F4 Bishop will be
hanging and can be picked up but there
are a little unpleasant threats right
now Bishop F4 is on the board Magnus
creating a little bit of pressure here
I think King H2 that if Bishop takes F4
you may double my pawns but only after a
queen trade so I think King H2 seems to
do the trick and he plays King H2 and
yeah this is just bad for Magnus and I
was saying winning on demand against
Magnus uh good luck to you Sarge says I
don't need luck my skill will be more
than enough and look at this position
it's domination
yeah you make your luck on the
chessboard and that's exactly what Ivan
sarich has done King age to precise
defense there of course a queen trade is
as good as resigning in this position so
Magnus not going for Bishop F4 he makes
the move Rook to G6 still trying to
think how can he create his chances
maybe a night jump night to D5 coming up
next trying to create more pressure on
that Bishop on F4 but Robert there are
these ideas defensive resource of white
jumping in with the Rook to E5 always
watch out for that Knight D5 rookie five
might just win the game on the spot for
white it does because you are going to
give up your Rook for two minor pieces
and beat up with Bishop so let's hop
back to this game maybe because I see
that there's action uh going on in all
the other games
um we can hop right back here in a sec I
just want to quickly look at komsky and
aronian because that game was really
fascinating to start with in favor of
komsky but Lavon aronian actually takes
him down it's a surprising turn of
events considering what's happening in
the opening but compski must have made a
mistake some were critical and Levon
aronian wins
wow love on our onions wins this game
and wins the match and books his spot
stop it so that's left justifying his
decision of picking Gata as his opponent
in match play wow I'm just gonna very
very quickly show how it turned around
Queen B5 was the choice we were talking
about Queen B3 Queen B5 he chose the
wrong option because after E5 Pawn sack
Bishop 65 Bishop B4 getting in the
Queen's path black was able to activate
all of his pieces and the white King was
in some danger over here and look at
this move Queen B2 defending B7 offering
Queen trade this is how Lavon started
the game and went on to win but that's
over so let's go to games that are still
in progress tiny which game should we
head on over to wow that could have been
a completely different narrative had to
move Queen B3 made instead of Queen B5
and it was tough to Spot the Difference
but here it is and with that win
lebanaroni and goes through in division
one Robert let's quickly get an update
on the Wesley board
a lot has happened there
and equal material
yeah it takes me like five seconds to
count that but yes it is even material
but a very weird Pawn structure where
both sides have an awkwardly placed Pawn
the F4 Pawn doubled the C2 upon isolated
who would you rather have here white or
black
this is a big threat on the board but
it's
now that's the
I have to say if black has to trade that
Bishop on A6 after Rook A6 I don't like
that Bishop on E7 the White Knight
jumping to F5 the White Knight jumping
to C6 I do like White's position instead
of trading on A6 he falls back with the
Rook on B6 and maybe white can just
simply Retreat the bishop The Rook
jumping onto A7 a potential knight jump
to F5
I think Rusty's got good chances here
it's a very Wesley position where uh you
know black is very passive white has
good control over the center I really
like Bishop B5 why trade the bishop and
allow the rook in the game he plays
Bishop C4 instead similar plan with
Knight F5 Knight D5 so Wesley will try
to work his magic here I do see that
Magnus Carlsen lost game two so we will
have the Armageddon with bidding to
break that tie
wow so the action will continue and it's
going to be a lot of fun to watch that
one it's a lot of fun in the
parhamaksudu itarizaga board as well
this is going to be a long grind so
let's quickly jump over to that one uh
because exciting moment with that last
move that white played the pawn from G2
to G3 I look at your expression Robert
and you can smell the blood here with
that Bishop eyeing down the board a
check on H3 if this is not Checkmate I
don't know what is oh my goodness I mean
what in the world are we looking at here
Knight H3 check if that Knight we're not
there it would have been Checkmate which
means that your knight can do some
discovered work over here wait how many
isn't white down a piece too
oh wow but with all of that I didn't
even notice that and maybe if white was
white even had an extra Knight on C3 it
still might be lost this possession but
wow on top of everything down material
gives a check on E7 and if nothing else
works you can simply go Queen G4 next
this Pawn is pinned a queen H5 you're up
a piece so maybe there's Bishop E6 check
things like that but black will have F4
at the right moment and just crash
through on the king side it looks
devastating
wow so this might also be heading into
an uh into an Armageddon because
uturizaga has to win on demand so Magnus
Carlson Ivan sarich that match goes down
to the wire and here as well if the
rizaga creating his chances up an extra
piece a lot of attack against White's
King how many pawns is that that's just
one Pawn for the piece that can't be
enough it definitely is none Rook C7
that's one way to attack two pieces but
it wouldn't have worked because of
Knight D5 which would hit the rook in
the bishop there so uh there's always a
way out for iterizaga he's up two
minutes plus I think we can trust him to
take this game at this stage he is up a
piece and I think the Palms running out
of ideas now this Pawn's dropping as
well
yeah you could go D6 but it is
eventually going to fall and that would
mean opening up after this is crazy
stuff G4 on the board
it's hard to rub it is speechless
Pawn takes Bishop takes it was like
Knight takes D5 over there with Queen
takes G4 check to follow they're real
they're like some cool mating patterns
that might happen with a discovered
double check against the King on G2 so
yeah it turns out has enough time to
calculate that's the good news because
if he only had seconds then mistakes
could happen but he plays just too
calmly yeah
and barham's the one who's playing on
seconds you can't even pick up the H3
Knight the bishop on E3 hangs Knight F4
threats D5 Pawn is falling param magsudu
down to 12 seconds on the clock rookie
one played
picks up the Knight on Wow and look at
that Barham capturing that this is
desperation but everything falls apart
yeah and I am anticipating
a vintage uterizaga fist bump that's
what I'm waiting for when this game ends
he is going to do it the celebration
oh he's gonna deserve that because of
just the way he's played with the black
pieces Bishop F3 is so tempting I don't
know where's the mate but it's got to be
somewhere on the board white can pick up
the Knight on E3 you pick up that Bishop
on G4 that's Queen H5 check as well
Queen G5 check as well after that that's
gotta be game over whoa this is amazing
stuff
you have so many options here Queen G5
oh there's no Bishop C8 mate because the
Rook can take it but queen of Fortune I
like Queen effort yeah yeah you take
this bishop with check that's game over
to win 42 Saga and there it is there's
Robert you called it and oh you see
there is a guy react there he wins the
game and with that takes the match into
the Armageddon love it
and we only have one game remaining from
the second game of these matches and if
I'm looking at this correctly Tanya and
I have been miscounting in most games
thus far white has two minor pieces for
a rook and the minor pieces should be
enough for Wesley to win this game
yeah wow I'm just taking all of this in
right now so there is a pin along the a
file so the Knight on A7 is stuck there
but probably not for too long
Roberta still seems like there's work to
be done here do you start going Rook A6
targeting the D6 Pawn is that the idea
that you want he first defends the
bishop on B3 and I think eventually he
will go for that D6 Pawn yeah he's
protected everything that he needs to
Rook A6 there's Rook takes B5 so have to
be a little careful right now
what is the move at this stage King F2 I
guess everything's defended look at this
it's weird
yeah everything defends each other it's
like a family support group here the
bishop saves the A4 rug the pawn on C to
defends the bishop onto B3 the Knight on
A7 defends it Knight on B5 that's a
mutual admiration society and Rook B6
played right now but where is the
conversion here you've got to try to
break through and this is what he shows
Knight C7 freeing up the night the other
night will jump on to B5 if given the
opportunity not right now maybe Knight
D5 trade Knights take with the pawn give
yourself the C6 Square so I think this
should be sufficient
is he considering recapturing with the
bishop perhaps also eyeing that F7 Pawn
which is so tender in the position
imagine a rook landing on the seventh
rank that will be game over Knight C6
rookies seven ideas
oh it shuts the Rooks off from one
another such a Wesley type of move but
he does walk into a little bit of a pin
it is defended but trades maybe you
don't have enough material left to win
although he should
wow and just six seconds on the clock
for Amin Tabata bye but rookie ate a
nice move that he could not have allowed
Wesley to free up the night and get the
Rook on to the seventh rank Wesley slows
down a little he has to be sure that
once the Rooks are traded he's confident
off the win and going for the H Pawn
this is getting trickier than what the
eval bar tells us right now Robert yeah
King E7 do not give up D6 and the
question now becomes does white and
Knight E5 check does win this Pawn is
one able to win by Brook H Force but by
King G1 The Rook gets trapped over there
and that's why the king went back to f8
but unfortunately I don't think it's
successful take this King G1 trap that
Rook
G4 but you're just not in time as you're
pointing at the night traps the rook and
we can see it Amin tabatabai react
reacting to this position he knows that
it's all over yeah Wesley so wins and
makes his way through to division one of
the aim chess rapid Wesley has many fans
out there he is a fantastic player with
that precise almost mechanical style at
moments and he maximized that in this
game
wow
Robin what a match play this has been
and it's not over we've got two big
armageddon's but the players who did
make it through Lavon aronia and Wesley
still can wincing games by them yeah
game two was a little bit topsy-turvy
for Lavon but he was able to withstand
his disadvantage in the opening he came
up with some brilliant tactics to win
him that game and Wesley so it wasn't a
tactical Affair it was just positional
dominance just putting his pieces on
good squares so they both earned their
spot through to division one of the
anxious rapid I feel badly for a mean
tablet to buy who it's such a great
Swiss tournament and for gotakovsky who
is a legend and was off to a great start
in that second game but they will play
in division two that's going to be a lot
of fun and a lot of hard work there
because so many strong players who don't
make the top division hey they still
have a go of it in division two
yeah there's so much to fight for in
division two as well but the action's
not over we've got Armageddon coming up
a format that's so destructive that it's
called the Armageddon and you don't want
to miss this one we will be giving more
information on that two armor Gardens
are gonna be
on with us right after this break we'll
be back
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is with
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back everyone as the action
continues we are going to be treated to
very exciting armageddons and it is the
bidding Armageddon Robin which just
takes it up a notch makes it even more
fun as the players will bid for their
time and uh wow what are you expecting
from this one but before that Robert
let's take a look at the format for the
Armageddon let's just talk about that
and this is the action that's coming up
the players bid for the time and the
lowest bid wins gets to choose the color
black has got draw odds which means that
white has to win on demand Robert the
big question in armageddon's is always
how low can you go especially because
there's no increment
yeah there is no increment which means
that if you have a rook and Game King
and Rook versus King and Rook you have
to flag your opponent you have to be
Shameless in this format I know the
players they often are nice they're very
cordial they get along well with their
friends and fellow competitors but no
they're your enemy here you win on the
clock if you can and so black wins the
match with just the draw which means
white has to go all in
um so the players really want to fight
for the black pieces but for that they
have to make the lower bed and Robert we
are getting updates on the bids that
have been made but of course it is about
how much time are you willing to forego
to get the black pieces once again let's
remind everyone that black has got
resolved odds but white has got that
extra time and starts with 10 minutes on
the clock the winning bid starts with
the amount of time that they bid with
and no increment at all just like limbo
it's all about how low can you go and
for some people you know just like the
people on the limbo line they go a
little bit you're too low on their knees
failed them and they just fall on the
floor If you bid too little time like
this for nothing on did against
in the uh Global Championship I actually
misspoke now Brothers earlier and it
says powerful Spirit of too many pavels
out there but uh you know you bid too
little time you may be punished for that
on the clock you just don't have enough
time to make it work on the board
yeah you've got to be so so precise with
your time bed I'm so sure of your mouse
skills because flagging is is completely
allowed not only is it allowed it's
heavily recommended in the arm again
that's part of the plan the clock is
definitely the 17th piece in this format
Robert and we've got bids that have in
fact come in the matches are started
Magnus Carlson bid 7 Minutes 58 seconds
and he won his bid
and he'll be playing against Yvonne
saritch
wow yeah Sarge bid 725 to Max's 758 so
Sarge he went low and for Magnus I mean
will he be able to punish him using the
clock as the 17th piece as James Canty
likes to say and we're looking at this
position this is very dry would this
have been your opening choice for Magnus
if you had the white piecing as a player
Who's down two and a half minutes
yeah Robert I'm just just looking at the
bits
a bit so Magnus Carlson actually lost a
bit Ivan sarich bit 7 minutes 25 seconds
shows the black pieces Magna starts with
white gets 10 minutes on the clock for
iterizaga against Parham magsudu it is
Parham who won the bid and iturisagar
starts with white with 10 minutes Parham
starts with eight minutes on the clock
has the draw odds but Robert again the
question comes down to is that time that
Ivan sarich bid for too low with 7
minutes 25 seconds and you were asking
about what color I would choose here I
do like White's position the control in
the center more space but again giving
draw odds that's a big big give here and
is it going to be enough to win what
Magnus is eyeing for Bishop F4 a
potential Queen D2 Bishop ate six ideas
getting the Rook into the game he starts
with first blocking out the black Bishop
on B7 so there's no Bishop F3 in those
lines yeah it does look Pleasant for
white because the Knight can't slide a
D4 at the right moment up to C6 this
bishop is under attack I think black can
try Knight E4 I'm not sure if it works
out so well but the point is you start
trying to trade pieces open up your
Bishop on the G7 Square I do think that
sarge is playing this well but I'm still
looking at the clock 6 minutes 21
seconds for him it's really not that
much time and white has healthy Pawn on
D5 and that's not a good Bishop on B7
it's not a happy bishop and B7 but
anytime in the game it can reroute to
the C8 H3 diagonal as well but not at
the moment he still needs to think about
his development getting that Rook from
Aid onto the game 94 as you pointed out
has been played white has also got to
find a way to keep his Rooks into into
the Central files but right now that B2
Pawn that's a little lose Robert you
defend it immediately or perhaps throw
in a rookie one targeting that Knight on
e4 first yeah rookie one's a way of
Defending by attacking something else
but Rook B1 is Max's choice and I think
that makes sense just keeping the pawn
defended a black can try and move like
Queen to F6 but this bishop just slides
back and maybe up to D4 so this position
it looks very solid but it will be about
maneuvering so what do you say should we
head on over to Parham against itarizaga
to see what's going on there Armageddon
game
let's do it and this is uh the second
Armageddon fight with Zuri Saga starting
with 10 minutes on the clock with the
white pieces against Parham aksudlu
who's got draw odds and remember there's
no increment here well this also looks
like an extremely solid position lots of
Pawns on the board very close yes white
has the open C line and there's a C6
backward bonds but then a weakness is
only as big a weakness as much of an
attack as you can put on it and there
isn't too much that white can build
against it I think despite all this
activity on the C line it looks really
solid for black so I'm of two minds here
so help me out Tanya on one hand this
looks very solid which tends to make me
think there could be a draw but it's so
such a closed position where only one
Pawn has been traded that this game
might last forever any turizagos up two
minutes on the clock so do you think
it's closer to Black stabilizing and
drawing or wiping up time and using the
clock as a weapon
Robert with Armageddon stabilizing is
never enough to draw because it comes
down to class it comes down to actually
flagging your opponent so you need to
create decisions on the board that
actually end up simplifying the position
rather than just saying that you're
going to hold on to it and that's
exactly what Parham is doing he starts
with play along the king side also let's
point out the B4 Pawn is a weak spot in
White's Camp which ties down the queen
and the bishop to the queen side giving
black a little bit of an activity and
time to create something on the king
side yes it's stable and yes a draw is
enough but you've still got to fight for
it iterizaga will try to flag Parham as
long as pieces are on the board and the
side that has more time on the clock in
the Armageddon a big Strat is to just
keep pieces on the board you don't need
to think about winning plans you don't
need to think about what works for you
but just keep material on the board I'd
love the Mover K2 because it stopped G4
the third of G4 is it Knight D2 with a
fork so Rook A2 it also helps you double
on the C file it protects the F2 pawn
another time watch out for sacrifices
there at a critical moment the E3 Pawn
could be loose black could play H4 but
these decisions are not easy for Parham
and he's burning some precious clocks so
let's maybe head back to the other game
we're gonna go back and forth everybody
don't you worry we want to see Magnus
and Soros you want to see Parham any
terizaga wow okay we have a pure end
game here is Magnus is gonna try to flag
him
and this is exactly what we were talking
about right the player with last time
you want the pieces off the board to get
closer to the draw I think Magnus has to
try to flag him that feels like the only
chance that he has if the game ends in a
draw Ivan sarich wins the match Magnus
meanwhile has got a knight on D4 but it
looks like not too many penetrating
spots for the king objectively it's a
draw Robert it's gonna come down to the
clock here
objectively yes but I actually think
even in a classical game this is still a
bit difficult for black especially now
that this Pawn is on H5 and this Knight
at the right time can reroute so the
king will come to E3 the Knight will go
to E2 if you ever take on H4 which has
happened that frees up the G3 square and
you know I haven't read too many chess
books I've admitted that before but I've
seen enough karpov games in my life to
look at this position and say you know I
feel like white really can press and win
this game oof Anderson oh my gosh I hope
you're doing well but this position
looks like one where he would press for
a win in an end game I actually think
that Black's in big trouble
I think and that's a situation when
whitesnite gets to G3 black will have to
take a defensive setup of getting the
Bish Bishop to defend the H5 pawn and he
wants to do that via G6 but watch out
what about the C7 Pawn
but Magnus is who cares you can't you're
not gonna attack anything you play
Bishop to B1 maybe still Knight to B5
and yeah these pawns are all on dark
squares and will be targeted
and he goes for Bishop B1 the idea is
that after A3 he wants to go Bishop a do
try to put pressure on C4 we see the
eval bar creeping up Robert you you're
absolutely on point that practically not
a easy position for black to defend it
might not just be about the clock with
H5 weakness and a C7 weakness the Knight
can jump around to attack both it might
actually be a lot worse for black now
yeah but what I do like for sarge is
that the bishop tends to outclass at
night when there's things happening on
both sides of the board so if this
Knight goes to B5 at some point and the
King has to go to D4 the black king may
come up the board over here the knight's
a bit slow to get back that said Knight
takes C7 Knight E8 Knight takes D6 all
these pawns are going to be in trouble
and Magnus is he just he's really just
sitting on the position
he played B3 like he just wants this
structure
well he's gonna come in with the King if
allowed he would try to trap up that
Bishop on A2 so he couldn't stay there
for too long Bishop B1 played and now
after Knight B5 black starts targeting
White's Queen side bonds so the Knight
on D4 is actually stuck defending that
B3 Pawn right now how do you improve
Magnus looks like he's done everything
right he's got the most beautiful
position with the Knight on D4 the King
on E3 but what's next
he'll eventually move his King this way
and play for B4 like he's just gonna
look at this the black king can't enter
so that means that Magnus can play like
this for 50 moves and then play B4 so
he's just gonna waste time he is doing a
perfect Armageddon strategy with no
increment don't play B4 yet don't do
see I I don't love that even if it's
good for white he could have burned more
clock in the process
and what you're pointing out there's
Knight on D4 it really stops all
activity black skin can't get to F5 the
F4 Pawn controls the E5 and the G5
square but now what's next does white
also go A5 trying to get his own King
towards the C7 Pawn but Robert the more
pawns that get traded off the closer
black cats do that draw yes and you know
A5 takes the king would have to go up to
B7 and is this bishop going to be able
to stop it or is the black king gonna be
required to go back to d8 and that's oh
wow and he's still got time on the clock
he's got two minutes 51 seconds there's
no increment at all a draw means sorry
to wins the match and Magnus will not
make it to division one if sarich is
able to hold this position he's found a
key defensive resource don't go King F5
93 is a big fork in the air wow that was
a really great idea from Magnus I think
what's gonna happen is that Bishop d390
the king now has to go back and the
Knight is stuck and can't make progress
but he's wasting Sarge's time oh it's a
losing move that's a losing move and
that's it you just go King C6 and you
win the pawn yeah you're just winning
everything at five I think you win two
pawns just to one and your pawns are too
fast
and he does it King C6 he's gonna
he's gonna have to see Pawn is just
super fast
and it was Meg's strategy you could tell
by the way he was playing and I asked
the question earlier would you play the
solidly when you need to win he was
playing for the clock and Sarge bid 725
so he was down two minutes 35 seconds to
start look at the clock by the way two
minutes and now 25 seconds is the lead
for Magnus so he's kept the time
Advantage the whole way through and now
he's using it because he has an
objectively winning position he knows
that and he wants to accurately put this
game away hmm
well boys and girls this is how an
Armageddon is done so Magnus there he's
calculated the line uh comes back with
that Knight to E1 will give it up for
the F Pawn meanwhile the C Pawn will
advance down the board to C6 and only
then will he go D7
all right sorry it's still asking
questions not allowing this plan King D4
is it time to give up the d-pawn for the
bishop D7 does that win on the spot and
just get the king back eat up all the
king side pawns yeah here comes the
white king back to F5 and you don't even
have King E3 because Knight G2 check
forks and wins this Pawn this is game
over it means Magnus Carlson will be in
division one of the aim chess rapid
event it's the fourth leg of the
champion chess tour and well I feel for
saurus I mean he really put up a fight
he went on demand against Magnus Carlson
but his back is literally against the
walls proverbly against the wall he has
lost the game Magnus Carlson's through
wow and you could see the relief on
Magnus after that he knows that this
match was really close if I'm sorry Jim
made a comeback in a game two but then
eventually in the Armageddon Magnus
showing absolute class in the strategy
in the end game though it was a drop in
a very difficult position to hold and
with that Magnus books his spot in the
aim chess rapid that's gonna be a fun
one and of course Magnus fans excited
about that but perhaps those four
players who qualified already for aim
chess rapid can't be too pleased about
this outcome Robert no they are going to
be very upset they all love playing
magnets from this perspective of I want
to play the best players in the planet
but from a competitive standpoint where
they're like I want to win first place
they're like Magnus can you please go
back down to division two get out of
here and speaking of getting out of here
what is happening in this game why does
some have down a piece but has a Pawn on
A6 how much material how many pawns does
white have for the piece I count five
black pawns seven white pawns so it's
two pawns for a night
and there's a pass Pawn this Pawn on B5
is Lewis tired this D5 Pawn is also a
bit loose what is going on here
it's absolute Madness that's what's
going on here and of course it's easy
for us to see the eval bar and say black
is winning but when you have no idea
about what the eval Bar says it's
complete crazy stuff even with the eval
bar telling us it's hard to see what's
happening it starts with Knight H3 check
now you've got to watch out never allow
black screen to come on to F3 that would
be a Checkmate in one there are a lot of
these mating ideas even at a certain
point the H Pawn marching down the board
with H4 a potential night sacrifice on
H4 so para maxoodloo here creating his
chances with the black pieces Robert a
big time scramble coming up both players
under three minutes now I'm just gonna
show a very quick line and it might be
bad but you said it and now I'm really
into it Knight H4 it looks like a really
big idea so let me try to find a move
for white some kind of I don't even I
don't know any random moves that exist
but I want to play Knight H4 and Knight
F3 and then once I trade Knights there
bring my Bishop in to deliver the
Checkmate and I actually think that this
could work Knight H4
um if you take it you're gonna probably
get in trouble down here and if you take
like say this bishop to distract the
queen I was looking at something like
this but there is Queen D5 rookie four
potentially and if Queen one but I was
thinking I just bring my Bishop in and I
check with you but apparently everything
I've said is wrong literally everything
I've said is incorrect I'll be right
next time everybody it's okay
and even looking at that position I'm
just wondering it looks so dangerous I
have no idea some crazy computer
resource there Robert super hard to find
Queen D5 has been played Knight H4
always in the air look at the kind of
pressure that white is building again
who cares what the eval bar is saying
when that Bishop on D6 is pinned when
the beep on and the a pawn are marching
down the board anything can happen I
would be very scared with black hair and
look at the clocks both sides down to
about a minute and 50 about to be two
seconds and white has four pawns for a
rook and Bishop takes C6 that's so many
Pawns
it's a lot of Pawns but you've got to
take that Rook on C6 and this just means
that white is
white has got four pawns for the rook
and the B and the a pawn are gonna March
down the board
B5 is not possible right now watch out
that's why black defended that Queen on
F6 so that B5 is met by Bishop A3
yeah so the queen is protected
okay but white needs to find a move here
94 won't work Queen F3
there's rookie four right oh you want to
play A7 that's so tricky of you Robert
no I actually blundered but thank you
for trying to save me I appreciate that
but Queen F3 I think is just Checkmate
so I got Fancy with my bloggers
but it's actually an interesting point
because 94 rookie 4 A7 the only thing
that saves the day for black is that
part on H3 with Queen F3 coming in while
the tirizaga spots it it doesn't go for
this trap and he plays Rook to A1
A7 is all that white needs to get does
he want to go Bishop B2 and simply start
pushing the pawn is that his idea at
some point you can also think about B5
because Bishop A3 we get a queen trade
and white has four pawns for a rook and
they're all passed so that could be a
decision but look he turns out his clock
he's now done under a minute he's a very
experienced Blitz player but Parham is
superb in Blitz and bullet time Patrols
this is completely out of hand this is
anyone's game H5 Pawn also under attack
really important that Knight on D2 a key
defender in the position A7 in the air
black is a rook up for four pawns it's
not a usual imbalance that we see and
again just disregard what the eval Bar
says right now it doesn't matter at all
and that a tripod may not be hanging
because it might be gone in a second I
like Queen takes H5 but he goes Bishop
B2 be careful D5 check is a fairly
obvious one
but a big threat it is a basic threat
but one that needs to be sorted and he
goes Queen G4 stepping out of the way
and look at that eval bar it does creep
up is it time for white to start
advancing the pawns he first centralizes
the queen A7 is a big threat now he's
not only covered the diagonal but takes
under control the A8 square and look at
that the players down to under a minute
on the clock and no increment so they
don't get more time with each move that
they play they're gonna be down to their
final second this is a blitz scramble
turn into a bullet scramble at this
point and how do you stop A7
I have no idea can you just think about
getting greedy go Rook before you go a
seven I'll pick up that pawn on A7
oh my God Queen F7 is certain it is
madness he starts with queen E2 and
after A7 what do you want you wanna how
do you react to A7
he takes a bishop and up both Rooks the
Knight does protect the Rook on E7 so
Queen D2 Rook Queen ba Queen takes B2
and
is there some kind of mating threat can
this queen get to E4
Queen A2 you start with so between a two
queen A8 I want to defend my A6 Pawn I
want to guard your queen Coming on to D5
oh no time could be if I play great move
and remember white also needs to win the
game a draw is a win for black but right
now it's all about the clock
oh my gosh no increment and
it's down to nine seconds on the clock
Haram is very very quick though look at
him play
over quick Rook F5 is a good move
wow Robert this is crazy I think my
arm's gonna get flagged Prime's about to
get flagged no I I don't know he's such
a good boy's playing here comes the
Knight Knights are very tricky pieces oh
G5 look at him he's just giving all his
pieces
oh
it doesn't matter what you give away
it's just by flagging one second oh my
God who's gonna
who's gonna win
look at the celebration from iterizaga
does it oh my God it came down to those
milliseconds of the clock and he wins he
Flags Byron maxidlu unbelievable stuff
point nine seconds remained on the clock
for Eduardo eturizaga but he has made
his way through to division one of the
aim chess rapid event of this Champions
Chester Tanya we barely had words coming
out of our mouths because there was no
time remaining on the clock but only one
player had just enough time and that was
iterizaga
it has such a heartbreaking moment for
parhamak Sudley but aturi Saga he really
did Shine in those seconds and it all
just came back to those last couple of
moves absolute Madness and the bird went
down to the wire and this is what the
Armageddon is about we saw big blunders
big misses but some really cool
resources and attacking possibilities
there as well just amazing chest all
throughout and Robert Magnus winning it
in the Army Garden it's rizaka winning
it in the Armageddon meanwhile Levon and
Wesley taking it in there a rapid match
play it's gonna be a fun ride in the aim
chess rocket and you have to feel for
Parham maxulu he had the better position
throughout that game he was doing well
on the clock and he was playing so many
great moves but then the position got
tricky things got out of hand he didn't
have enough time to calculate everything
and itarizaga 0.9 that's the number his
favorite number in the world right now
that's the amount of time chat that
iterizaga had left on the clock when he
slacked barhamma
0.9 seconds
and 0.00 to Parham that's what happened
at the end of that game absolute brutal
stuff but what a brilliant day of Chess
this has been and Robert so many cool
games that we saw and this means you've
got our field for division one of the
aim chess rapid let's take a look at the
players who will be joining not a backup
dosatro Fabiano caruana Jordan van
forest and Vladimir feducev who made it
through in the Chaska cup for the aim
chess rapid and from this one from the
planes today we've got Lavon aronian
Magnus Carlsen Eduardo terizaga Wesley
so booking their spots into division one
and Robert I'm looking at that field and
it's gonna be one hell of a tournament
there are no weak spots there there are
no targets there and also we've got at
Eduardo durazaga we'll be making his
debut in division one
I felt bad for a mean time to buy for
having to play Wesley so I now feel bad
for no dear back up juicy tariff I mean
he just won in the chess kid cup he can
win another division one but he has to
play Wesley so that's not the opponent
you expect to get as the eighth seed in
the bracket but uh we'll see these great
matchups with so many Fantastic players
and look at the entrance the new the
people who just earned their spot look
at their high ratings and last but
certainly not least was Mr vamos himself
Eduardo eturizaga the fist pubs you know
just rooting himself on and he needed
every last ounce of energy to make it
through to division one I think a lot of
people will be very pleasantly surprised
by him in division one uh watch out if
you're a Fabiano caruana if you're the
other people and that's not somebody you
take lightly his so much experience and
he just proved that he belongs in
division one in the Champions chess tour
he's definitely going to have a Target
on his back for all these other players
he's that one player that they do want
to win against he's making his debut
they don't know what to expect from him
but of course the Chess World knows that
how dangerous italyzaga can be and we
saw him in his brutal format in this
last Armageddon Robert Parham I'm still
thinking about this param was an entire
Rook up and iterizaga creating that play
with the pawns rolling down the board
and then coming down to those seconds
and that's what this format takes
complete control on the nerves precision
and that never give up attitude and
that's what iterizaga has shown it is
vamos from him into division one of the
aim chess rapid and Robert it's been
such a fantastic day of Chess we started
when the sun was still out in delhi now
it's about 3 A.M in the morning where I
could not have had a better Monday this
was so much fun and also watching how
Magnus made it through his match going
down to the wire losing in round two
then qualify sign for match play and
then winning it in the Armageddon Levon
aronian from start to finish absolute
masterpieces from him yeah Lavon looked
great I mean he was shaky in that last
game as against God of komsky and we're
going to feel sympathetic for the
players who just got eliminated down to
division two that's okay there's still a
lot of prize money at stake some great
competitors in that field and I just
think that for Parham maksudu you just
think what could have been 0.9 seconds
was the difference between division one
and division two but as you said the
people who you know are in there very
strong very capable Magnus Carlson joins
them so I think that we are excited to
see the former world champion I
remembered it uh take on many of the
best players in the world and Eduardo
terzaga he may not have the highest ring
next to his name but he is a fantastic
player someone who's done really well in
the Pro chess League he was one of the
MVP candidates in fact because he had
nine wins four draws zero losses in the
protesting season in Rapid chess he has
been demonstrating excellent skill in
this time Patrol so don't be surprised
if he pulls off an upset
just amazing stuff 0.9 seconds Robert it
takes more time to say 0.9 seconds than
1.9 seconds is I mean what is that
amount of time and that's all it took
and that was the difference that got it
to rizaga through into division one
Parham Maxwell will be fighting in
division two but of course we all look
forward to seeing all the players back
in AIM chess rapid it starts on 10th of
July it's gonna be an exciting one with
Magnus re-earning his spot not a backup
this outro still there uh Fabiano
caruana who's yet to book his ticket
into the season final playoff so a lot
of excitement coming up with the
Champions Chester fourth event kicking
off mark your calendars chat it's 10th
of July the action starts but the action
continues on chess.com Robert we will be
back tomorrow as a junior speed Chess
Championship kicks off
yes we have the call for the first match
it's gonna be super exciting kukesh did
not take part in today's action he just
came off a third place finish in Norway
so congratulations to him about his work
cut out for him tomorrow against Amin
Ohan young you and I will have the call
for that and of course Christopher you
takes on pranavi buddy from India there
are two great matches in store for
everybody tomorrow in the junior speed
Chess Championship or the finals
looking forward to that a chat a big
shout out to all of you who joined us
for this incredible day of Chess on
YouTube as well as on Twitch it's been
so much fun Robert calling this out with
you a long long day but it just flew by
and I'm still gonna be thinking about I
don't think sleep's coming anytime soon
as I think about all the action that we
witnessed chat once again thank you for
joining us and we'll see you tomorrow
for the speed test the junior speed
Chess Championship it's a good night
from us
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you